SUBCOMMITTEE ON COAL THAT
NINETEEN WILL COME TO ORDER. IN
RESPONSE TO THE COVERT NINETEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC. CENTERS INCIDENTS STAFF
WE MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS AND IT HERE THIS
DISTANCING. AND WITH BOTH
ORDERS WE ARE HOLDING OUR
INFORMATIONAL HEARING IN THE
CAPITAL BUT SOME OF OUR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS WILL BE
PARTICIPATING MULTI TODAY WITH
THE USE OF THE VIDEO MEDIAN
SERVICE. OUR PANELISTS THE LA
L. THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE IN
THE BUDGET POLICY CENTER WILL
ALSO BE PARTICIPATING THROUGH
THE VIDEO SERVICE. IN ADDITION
TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC ACCESS WE
HAVE ADMITTED MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO THE HEARING ROOM TO
THE EXTENT THAT SOCIAL THING
REQUIREMENTS WERE ALLOW AND
WILL BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
SERVICE FOR INDIVIDUALS WHO
WERE TO TESTIFY. JENDA BUT MAKE
NOT. HEY AS A SOME CHALLENGES
THE SENATE SIR WE ENTERED LAW
IN AND OUT EVEN WITH. OVER TEN
PEOPLE BE I WHAT WE INTO HAVE A
TIP TO SIGN. WHICH COMPLICATED
OUR SITUATION WITH THE SERVER
BUT WE ARE WORKING VERY HARD TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE TAKING THE LIVE STREAM WILL
STILL HAVE ACCESS AND AGAIN WE
DO HAVE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
HEARING THE HEARING ROOM TO
GREET THE HEARING KIND OF
COMEDY THAT. CHECK ON PUBLIC
HEALTH. INCLUDING YOURS FOR MEN
WHO WILL BE ATTENDING REMOTELY
TO AND PANEL PLEASE NHIáU
YOUR PHONE THERE CAN. ARE IT
PER WILL MUTE ON THE VIDEO
SERVICE WHEN YOU WERE TO SPEAK.
THIS WILL GREATLY A IN LIVE ANY
BACKGROUND AND SOUNDING. I ASK
THAT EVERY YOU HAVE A CALM OR
QUESTION THAT YOU PLEASE
IDENTIFY YOURSELF FIRST. FOR
INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO PROVIDE
PUBLIC COMMENT I WILL PROVIDE
THE PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE
NUMBER AN AXIS COLD AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. IN ORDER TO
PROTECT THE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WHO ARE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. WE WILL BE ASKING THEM TO
TEST I IS IN THE TELEPHONE
SYSTEM. BECAUSE WE DO NOT HAVE
A SECURE WAY OF SANITIZING THE
PUBLIC MICROPHONE. WE CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THAT ISSUE AND AGAIN
OUR GOAL IS TO MAINTAIN
EVERYONE'S SAFETY. WE MOVE THE
PUBLIC COMMENT A MODERATOR WILL
IDENTIFY YOU INDIVIDUALLY OPEN
YOUR LINE AND AT THAT TIME YOU
MAY ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. IT
IS CERTAIN THAT WE HEAR FROM
YOU AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. FOR THOSE IN THE
HEARING ROOM WHO DO NOT HAVE
MASKS WE DO HAVE MATH HERE
AVAILABLE AND I WOULD STRONGLY
ENCOURAGE YOU. TO AB ONE AND
WHERE IT. WE CAME TO QUORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AND ANY INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE DISRUPTIVE MAY REMOVE
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE. UP
THERE CONNECTS WE- WELL EVERY
EFFORT HAS BEEN JUST THE
HEARING PROCESS AND CONDUCT OUR
HEARING IN AS CLOSE TO THE
SAME- AS IS CUSTOMARY. THERE
MAY BE SOME BLACK TIMES FOR
DISTURBANCE IN A FEW TECHNICAL
ISSUES AS WE'VE ALREADY
EXPERIENCE AS WE PROCEED. BUT I
HOPE TO ALL. BACK FULL. UNDER
THE UNIX UNDER WHICH WE ARE TO
DO THE PEOPLE'S WORK. AND
PATIENT AS WE PROCEED AHEAD.
WITH THAT I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE FRAME THE
PURPOSE OF TODAY'S HEARING IN
THE CONTEXT OF THE COLD AT
NINETEEN RESPONSE. AS THE
BECAUSE RESULTED IN THE NEED
FOR BOLDING UNPRECEDENTED
ACTIONS IN ORDER TO PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH. ON MARCH SIXTH
THROUGH THE PASSAGES OF SB
EIGHTY NINE THE LEGISLATURE
GRANTED BROAD AUTHORITY FOR THE
GOVERNOR TO SPEND UP TO ONE
BILLION DOLLARS FOR ANY PURPOSE
RELATED TO THE CORONA BY.
EMERGENCY GOVERNOR IS WERE
THERE TO HELLO THIS THE LEAD.
TO THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE OF WHICH I AM
CHAIRWOMAN. AS THE
ADMINISTRATION UTILIZES THIS
FUNDING. AND OUR STAFF CAN
REVIEWS OF EACH PROPOSAL TO THE
ADMINISTRATION PROCEEDING.
ALBEIT WITHIN A CONDENSED
TIMELINE. HOWEVER AS MYSELF AND
MY COLLEAGUES CONSISTENTLY HERE
FROM OUR CONSTITUENTS AND
OTHERS ACROSS THE STATE IN OUR
DISTRICTS OF THE SEVERE IMPACT
OF THIS CRISIS AND AS. TO MEET
OUR OST OF DEADLINE TO PASS A
FOR TWENTY TWO ONE TO YEAR IT
IS THE SENSE THAT WE A CALM.
DISCUSSION AND THESE ARE THE
THREE AREAS THAT WE'RE GOING TO
FOCUS TODAY'S HEARING ON.
NUMBER ONE. THE USE OF THE ONE
BILLION DOLLARS THAT WAS
ALLOCATED TO SB EIGHTY NINE. TO
HOW THE ADMINISTRATION IS
UTILIZING OR INTENDS TO UTILIZE
ITS AUTHORITY TO SPEND FUNDS
FOR EMERGENCY PURPOSES FROM THE
DISASTER RESPONSE EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS ACCOUNT. AND THE
GOVERNOR'S EXECUTIVE ORDER
STIPULATED HE INTENDS TO
UTILIZE ANY OTHER LEGALLY
AVAILABLE FUNDS. AND THREE HOW
THE FEDERAL STIMULUS FUNDS
INTERACT WITH OUR STATE
RESPONSES AND FISCAL DECISIONS.
I'D LIKE TO RECOGNIZE ALL OF
THE WORK THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION IS DEVELOPING.
IN REAL TIME TO CONTINUE TO
RESPOND TO THIS PUBLIC HEALTH
AND HAPPEN NOT ECONOMIC
PANDEMIC. FROM THE BUDGET
COMMITTEES PERSPECTIVE IN
PARTICULAR I KNOW THE
DEPARTMENT FAN FINANCES WORKING
TIRELESSLY AROUND THE CLOCK TO
DEVELOP AND ADMINISTER STATE
STRATEGIES IN RESPONSE TO THIS
UNPRECEDENTED CRISIS. AT THE
SAME TIME THERE FOR FEELING
THEIR RESPONSIBILITY IN
BUILDING E. SENSUALLY A NEW
BUDGET FOR THE MAY REVISE. SO
AGAIN I'D LIKE TO RECOGNIZE AND
COMMEND THEM FOR ALL THEIR WORK
DURING THIS SPEAKS ONLY CHILD.
DAYS I'M SURE THAT COLLECTIVELY
WE UNDERSTAND THE FISCAL
RESOURCES THAT ARE AVAILABLE IN
OUR STATE AND HOW THESE
RESOURCES ARE BEING DEPLOYED.
WE KNOW THAT MOST OF THE WORK
IS AHEAD OF US. AS THE
LEGISLATURE ENGAGES IN THE
PROCESS WE HOPE TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE ADMINISTRATION TO
ENSURE WE ARE DOING ALL THAT WE
CAN TO EFFECTIVELY UTILIZE THE
RESOURCES IN ADDRESSING THE
IMPACT. OF NINETEEN ON OUR
STATES READ. BUSINESS IS NOT.
RELIGIOUS OR- AND LOCAL. FOR
THIS HEARING EVER SEE NEW
LETTERS AND EMAIL SYMPTOMS THE
STAKEHOLDERS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE WE UNDERSTAND THE GRAVITY
OF THE SITUATION AND AS TODAY'S
HEARING IS TO GO THROUGH EACH
AND VERY PATIENT IT IS AND- TO
UNDERSTAND THE DYNAMICS THAT
EXIST IN ORDER TO OF IN THE. WE
ARE EMBARKING ON DIFFICULT
FISCAL TIMES. THE GOOD NEWS IS
THAT. THANKS TO RESPONSIBLE
BUDGETING STRATEGIES IT'S THE
LAST RECESSION CALIFORNIA IS
MUCH BETTER PREPARED THAN EVER
TO ADDRESS. AN ECONOMIC
DOWNTURN. FINANCES THE BRUNT
DOWNTURN A DECADE AGO IF WE
HAVE EXPERIENCE AS- A BROUGHT
DOWN TURN A DECADE AGO WE WOULD
ALREADY BE OUT OF QUE IN FORCED
INTO EXPENSE EXTERNAL WING. THE
BUDGET CUTS. EVEN WARNS THAT
THE PAYCHECKS. HOWEVER OUR
PREPARATION WILL MOST IKELY
NOT INSULATE US FROM ECONOMIC
HARM COMING OUR WAY IT IS
CRITICAL THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT STEPS IN PROVIDE
ENOUGH SUPPORT STATE.
GOVERNMENTS THROUGHOUT THREE.
GOVERNOR NEWSOME IN THE BY
PRESSING GOVERNORS ASSOCIATION
HAVE REQUESTED IN WRITING. WELL
TODAY FAR FISCAL CONDITION IS
STABLE THE LEVEL OF INCREASE
SUPPORT FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT WILL DETERMINE HOW
LONG THAT REMAINS THE CASE AND
HOW WELL WE WILL BE POSITION
FOR. ECONOMIC RECORD ALL OF
THIS CURRENT PUBLIC HEALTH
PANDEMICS. WITH THAT I'LL ASK
MY COMMITTEE VICE CHAIR IF HE
HAS OPENING REMARKS AND THEN WE
WILL ASK THE SECRETARY TO TAKE
ROLE SENATOR NEAL. THE MATH
TEACHER AND THANK YOU FOR
READING THIS VERY IMPORTANT
HEARING. INDEED THESE ARE OUR
USUAL TIMES AND IT'S ALL THE
MORE GO NOW THAN EVER BEFORE
FOR THE LEGISLATURE TO EXERCISE
ITS OVERSIGHT AUTHORITY.
REGARDING THE BUDGET AND
EXPENDITURES OF MONIES FROM THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THE
ADMINISTRATION AS I'VE NOTED
HAVE BEEN VERY BUT THE WORK
WITH OVER THE YEARS. BUT NOW
WE'RE STAGE. LARGE CONTRACTS
ARE BEING LET WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT THEY'RE ALL ABOUT. MONIES
BEING OBLIGATED. IN OUR BUDGET
IS ALSO BEING AFFECTED IN
OBLIGATED THEREFORE THIS
OVERSIGHT IS EVEN MORE
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT AGAIN
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR FOR
ALLOWING OPPORTUNE EVEN UNDER
THESE ADVERSE CIRCUMSTANCE. AND
WE ASK THE PUBLIC COLLEGE TO BE
A STANDING OF HOW DIFFICULT
THIS YEAR'S. WE APPRECIATE YOU
DOING THE HEARING TODAY MADAM
CHAIR GLAD TO BE WITH YOU THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SIR TO NELSON AND
WILL COME AGAIN TO ALL OF MY-
WHO ARE PARTICIPATING REMOTE
LOOKING MAN. TERRY WOULD YOU
PLEASE- CALL THE ROLL SENATORS
MITCHELL HERE MITCHELL HERE.
ZERO COPYRIGHT HERE CABALLERO
HERE SENATOR DOLLY. SENATOR
DOLLY. HI. SENATOR DOLLY ONE
MORE TIME. HERE SENATOR DOLLARS
HERE SENATOR MORLOCK. CAN YOU
AND ONE MORE TIME I'M SORRY
CENTER MORE LUCK. AS IN SENATOR
NIELSEN NIELSEN HERE SENATOR
AND- THEIR PRESENCE IN SENATOR
PAN IS PRESENT SENATOR RALPH.
DEAR SENATOR OFFICE HERE
SENATOR SKINNER. DEAR SENATOR
SCANNERS HERE AND SENATOR WHY
CAL SKI. SENATOR LIKE OWSKI
HERE CENTER BY CASKEY IS HERE.
EXCELLENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THE SECRETARY NOTICES THE
PRESENCE OF A QUORUM ALL THIS
REMINDER JUST SHARE WITH ALL OF
MY COLLEAGUES HE SAID WHY
CASKEY OFTEN THAT THE I. T.
STAFF HE- IN MANAGING ZOOM IS
DOING A WOMAN'S ONCE I DID NOT
WHO'S COMING X. YOU WILL CREATE
FIRST GOAL THE X. THIRTY WOULD
YOU LAWS TO GET. TIME ON MUTE
AND BEGIN SPEAKING THE- AND
AGAIN BILL CAN ON MEETING YOU
FROM AND HE ROOM. BEFORE WE
BEGIN WITH OUR SPEAKERS AT LIKE
TO INVITE THE PUBLIC WANTED TO
PARTICIPATE TO CALL IN. AGAIN
WERE. SHARING THE EIGHT HUNDRED
TOLL FREE NUMBER WITH YOU NOW.
WE WILL NOT TAKE PUBLIC COMMENT
UNTIL THE END OF THE HEARING
THAT MEANS AFTER ALLTHREE
PRESENTERS IS THAT. MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AFTER QUESTIONS
AND WE WILL ALL. BOB SUGGEST
THAT YOU MAKE NOTE OF THE
NUMBER NOW AND THE CODE AND
THERE'LL BE A LATER POINT THE
HEARING LAW BRING IT TO YOUR
ATTENTION THAT YOU MIGHT WANT
TO CALL IN AND CATCH UP. AGAIN
AS BUDGET YEAR I AM REAL WE
HAVE SUCH MASS INTEREST IN WHAT
BUT NOT IN THE STATE NOW AND
THE BUDGETS RESPONSE. AGAIN
HARD TO DEBATE THE TENS OF YOU
THAT WOULD WANT TO PARTICIPATE
SO WE'RE GOING TO GIVE YOU THE
NUMBER NOW SEC QUEUE UP FOR
THE- END OF. COMMENT TAKE A-
THAT NUMBER IS EIGHT SEVEN. TWO
TWO SIX. EIGHT TWO ONE SIX ALL
REPEAT. ONE EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN.
TWO TWO SIX EIGHT TWO ONE SIX
AND THE CODE IS ONE FIVE NINE.
THREE TWO NINE FIVE. ONE FIVE
NINE THREE TWO NINE FIVE WE'LL
BEGIN OUR HEARING FROM OUR
FIRST PRESENTER OR LEDGE
ANALYSTS WELCOME MR PANIC. GOOD
AFTERNOON- GAVE PATRICK
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S AND I
WANT TO START BY SAYING. THANK
YOU TO. YEAH YOU MADAM CHAIR
MISTER VICE CHAIR AND MEMBERS
FOR INVITING OUR OFFICE ARTIST
EIGHT IN TODAY'S HEARING. WHO
IS SEVEN THE HOST IF THEY
COULD- ALLOW ME TO SHARE MY
SCREEN- COULD WALK THROUGH MY
SLIDES. JUST TO BEGIN ALL ALL
MENTIONED THAT OUR OFFICE HAS
ESTABLISHED A LANDING PAGE ON
OUR WEBSITE WE HAVE A VARIETY
OF POST. HOW THE RECENT COBIT
NINETEEN RELATED FEDERAL
LEGISLATION THAT CALIFORNIA.
AND IN ADDITION OUR OFFICE IS
WORKING ON OUR ECONOMIC AND
FISCAL OUTLOOKS WHICH SHOULD BE
AVAILABLE FOR YOU TO CONSIDER
IN IN MAY SH. OKAY. SO WITH
THAT I WILL MOVE TO THE FIRST
SLIDE. AND YET HERE I WILL
BEGIN BY ADDRESSING THE
ECONOMIC SITUATION. ARE THE
PACE OF JOB LOSSES THAT WE ARE
SEEN IN RECENT WEEKS. SB ABRUPT
HALTING OF ECONOMIC ACTIVITY
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT THE ECONOMY
HAS BEEN SESSION IMPOSSIBLE. ON
APRIL THIRD THE LABOR
DEPARTMENT REPORTED THAT US
THAT THE US ECONOMY LAST SEVEN
ONE HUNDRED AND ONE THOUSAND
EIGHT ROLE JOBS. IN MARCH WE-
INCREASED FROM THREE AND A HALF
PERCENT TO FOUR POINT 4% THIS
IS THE LARGEST ONE MONTH
INCREASE IN THE UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY
FIVE. HE'S YEAR'S IS BAD AND
THEY ARE NO DOUBT UNDER DATE
THE EXTENT OF JOB LOSS THAT IS
OCCURRING. IT'S MORE BASED ON A
REFERENCE MARCH TWELFTH WHICH
IS FAIRLY EARLY IN THE PERIOD
DURING WHICH THE RESTRICTIONS
ARE BEING PUT INTO PLACE. WHAT
WE DON'T KNOW YET IS JUST HOW
DEEP THE DOWNTURN WILL BE. HOW
LONG LAST OR WHAT THE SHAPE OF
THE RECOVERY WILL LOOK LIKE.
BROADLY SPEAKING THERE ARE TWO
WAYS THAT SEEM PLAUSIBLE. I'LL
START WITH THE OPTIMISTIC
SCENARIO HERE THE SHARP
DOWNTURN ECONOMIC ACTIVITY THAT
WE ARE ALL EXPERIENCING NOW IS
FOLLOWED BY SOME PERIOD OF TIME
WE'RE ACTIVITIES. REST
NATIONALLY IS FOLLOWED BY A
PRONOUNCED REBOUNDED. EITHER
LATER THIS YEAR OR EARLY NEXT
YEAR YOU CAN YOU SHAPE TO THE
CYCLE. THE NARRATIVE THAT WOULD
ACCOMPANY THIS SCENARIO. WOULD
BE THAT BECAUSE THE SHUTDOWN
WASN'T ACTUALLY AND USE OF
MEDICAL NECESSITY IS MORE IS
MORE LIKELY THAT AND WILL BE
ABLE TO BACK ONCE THE CHILDREN
PLAY. THE REQUESTED. IN THE
LAST THE MYSTICS AND RADIO THE
RECOVERY WOULD HAVE MORE OF AN
ILL SHAPE. WHERE THE VIRUS IS
TO DISSIPATE THE DESK PAINTING
THAT RESTRICTIONS REMAIN IN
PLACE HOUSING ECONOMIC OUTPUT
TO STAY DEPRESSED FOR LONGER.
ENJOY OUR PROTRACTED IN AUGUST.
THE WORST CASE. OF COURSE WOULD
BE IF THE PANDEMIC SEEMED TO
RECEDE. THE REST WERE LIFTED.
IN AUGUST SEPTEMBER THE VIRUS
CAME ROARING BACK CAUSING US TO
HAVE TO RESTART HELLO OVER
AGAIN. MAR READ THE- AND THAT
WE SEE A YOU AND AT ALLOW. THE
ECONOMIC OUTCOME LIKELY DEPENDS
TO A LARGE EXTENT ON THE
EVOLUTION OF THE VIRUS ITSELF.
THE AMER BASELINE INSPECTION
SEEMS TO BE THAT THE PANDEMIC
WILL BEGIN TO RECEIVE SOME
COMMENTS MONTHS. QUESTIONS THAT
WE HAVE ON ACT ON OUR
ACTIVITIES. ECONOMICALLY
SPEAKING HOWEVER WE STILL WON'T
BE IN THE CLEAR BECAUSE AT THAT
POINT THE NORMAL RECESSIONARY
FACT. OVER REALLY THESE ARE THE
MAN AND THE INCREASE IN
HOUSEHOLD SAVINGS BOTH OF WHICH
ARE COMMON IN THE WAKE OF.
THESE THIS COURSE OF EVENTS
WITH. THE NATIONAL UNEMPLOYMENT
RATE IN THE RANGE OF ANYWHERE
FROM 923% BY THE FOURTH COOPER
WITH THE POTENTIAL TO BE HIGHER
BURKE AND REMAIN HILL EATING
SOME AFTER. YOU CAN GRADUALLY
OFFICE SEEM. SOME VERSION OF
THIS. THE US UNEMPLOYMENT RATE
WOULD STILL BE A 9% AT THE END
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE. TURNING
TO SPECIFICALLY THE STATE'S
UNEMPLOYMENT DATA FOR MARCH ARE
NOT YET AVAILABLE BUT RECENT
CLAIMS UNEMPLOYMENT CLAIM
SUGGEST SOMEWHERE BETWEEN
TWELVE AND THREE. RENDON SAID
NOW LOST. SO TOUCH ON WHAT THIS
COULD MEAN FOR SOME OF THE KEY
SECTORS IN THE STATE. THIRTEEN
ANY ACCOMMODATIONS AND FOOD
WHICH INCLUDES RESTAURANTS BARS
OTHER KINDS OF TRAVEL RELATED
LEISURE SERVICES AND THIS IS A
MATTER. THESE FIRMS ACCOUNTING
FOR A MAJORITY OF THE NATIONAL
JOB LOSSES THAT WE SIGNED MARCH.
IN MARCH THEY'RE BEING HIT VERY
HARD BY THE DROP OFF IN TOURISM.
AND IS THAT CONSUMERS ARE YOU
MORE CAUTIOUS GOING FOR THIS
SECTOR MAY BE SLOW TO RECOVER.
AND SINCE THERE LOWMARGIN
BUSINESSES TO BEGIN WITH WE
COULD SEE AN INCREASE IN
BANKRUPTCIES AMONG THESE FIRMS
LATER IN THE YEAR. THERE'S A
SIMILAR CITY. AMONG RETAILERS
IN. ESPECIALLY THE BRICK AND
MORTAR STORE FRONTS THEY'RE
THEY'RE LIKELY TO BE HIT VERY
HARD AND- WILL RECOVER FOR MANY
OF THE SAME REASONS AS TO THE
RESTAURANTS AND BARS HAVE A
SLIDE FOR EVERY POINT.
YESTERDAY THE COMMERCE
DEPARTMENT REPORTED THAT RETAIL
SALES FELL BY BY- 9% ON A
SEASONALLY ADJUSTED BASIS IN
MARCH THAT WAS THE SINGLE. BEST
ONE MY- AB THAT REPORTED SINCE
AND TRACKING MISSTATED IN.
NINETY TWO. IN CONSTRUCTION WE
SEE A SECTOR THAT IS VERY
SENSITIVE TO ECONOMIC
CONDITIONS IN ACTIVITY HAS
ALREADY BEEN IN CONSISTENT OVER
THE PAST YEAR. WELL AFTER THAT
I PLANNED PROJECTS WE'RE- BOTH
THE MAN BEGAN FINANCING FOR NEW
PROJECTS WILL LIKELY BE
LIMITED. THE TECHNOLOGY SECTOR
MAYBE ONE AREA SILVER LINING.
BECAUSE IT COULD BENEFIT FROM
INCREASED DEMAND. THEN WE SEE
FOR YOU KNOW TECH DATA
TECHNOLOGY SOLUTIONS THAT
SUPPORT TELECOMMUTING PROMOTE
EDUCATION. AND THEY ALSO HAVE
THE ADVANTAGE THAT MANY OF THE
EARNED ALREADY CAN SUPPORT A
REMOTE WORKING OF COURSE. SH
SO- WITH THAT I'LL I'LL MENTION
THE RESPONSE THEY WERE SEEN
HERE- THE FIRST IS THAT THE-
USING THE- WE WANTED TO JUST
MENTION THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT MORE THAN EIGHT. HE
HE WITH THE FISCAL CAPACITY IN
THE INSTITUTIONAL WE WAY TO RUN
DEFICITS WHICH ENABLE IT TO
REPLACE A MEANINGFUL PORTION OF
THE AGGREGATE SHORTFALL AND
THAT WERE SEEN. THE ADEQUACY OF
THE FEDERAL RESPONSE MAY IN
FACT PROVE AN IMPORTANT FACTOR
IN THE CASE OF THE INITIAL
ECONOMIC. WE SEE. ON THE
PRESIDENT SIGNED THE CORONA
VIRUS AID RELIEF AND ECONOMIC
SECURE ACT THE CHAIRS ACT THE
PACKAGE WAS HISTORIC BOTH IN
ITS SIZE IT TWO POINT TWO
TRILLION WHICH IS EQUAL TO
AROUND 10% US GDP. ALSO THE
REPEATEDLY WITH WHICH WAS
ENACTED. JUST WISHING INCLUDED
SOME POLICIES THAT ARE LIKELY
TO BE QUITE HELPFUL SUCH AS THE
PAYCHECK PROTECTION PROGRAM AND
EXPANDING UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE BENEFITS. STILL IT'S
ALMOST CERTAIN THAT MORE ACTION
WILL BE NEEDED WELL THE PACKAGE
PROVIDES SUPPORTS TO
INDIVIDUALS AND BUSINESSES IT
LEAVES OUR SIGNIFICANTLY
DELAYED DATE TO CERTAIN
HORRIBLE DELUSIONS OF SECULAR I
DON'T THINK THE DOCUMENTED
RESIDENTS IN I. ABOUT A HUNDRED
AND FIFTY IN AID STATE AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO SEE THEM
YEAH WITH THE DIRECT COSTS OF
RESPONDING TO THE PANDEMIC.
CALIFORNIANS ELIGIBLE TO
RECEIVE ABOUT FIFTEEN POINT
THREE BILLION THIS WITH SIX OR
SEVEN BILLION THAT GOING TO
LOCAL. HOWEVER THE SEVERITY OF
THE DOWNTURN. THERE IS AN
ARGUMENT THAT MORE MORE AID IS
NECESSARY AND IN PARTICULAR IF
THEY CAN BE DELIVERED THROUGH
THE STATE. THEY ARE GOOD
VEHICLE FOR GETTING ME. IN
LARGE MONEY AN INMATE IN A
RELATIVELY QUICK FASHION AND
I'M- AND I THINK THE GOVERNOR
HAS RECENTLY MADE A REQUEST-
DISCRETIONARY AID WHICH WOULD
BE HELPFUL. SO FINALLY MOVING
TO THE STATE'S FISCAL OUTLOOK
ON THE THIRD SLIDE. AT THIS
POINT WE THINK IT'S VERY LIKELY
THAT THE STATE IS GONE FROM AN
ANTICIPATED SURPLUS IN NOW
FACING LIKELY FACING A BUDGET
PROBLEM AND POTENTIALLY
SIGNIFICANT WHAT. UNDER WHEN WE
SAY BUDGET PROBLEM WE ARE
REFERRING TO SITUATION WHERE
THE STATE'S REVENUES PLUS IT'S
DISCRETIONARY RESERVES ARE
INSUFFICIENT COVERAGE EXISTING
SERVICE LEVEL. REALISTICALLY IT
WILL PROBABLY TAKE SEVERAL
MONTHS FOR US TO GET A CLEAR
IDEA OF THE BUDGET SITUATION.
PART OF THIS IS THE NEW TO THE
INTERNET YOUR DISCOUNT. THE
DOWNTURN HAS IN CERTAIN IN
RECENT AND BY OCCURRING IN THE
SPRING IT MEANS WE ARE
FINALIZED. IT'S WITH. A SURE.
MORE TAX FIVE DATE WAS PUSHED
JULY IN WALL WAS IT APPROACH
WEIGHT BUY RELIEF TO TACK IT
DOES COMPLICATE OUR DEDUCTIBLE
NEIGHBOR LAST YEAR REVENUE S.
SO YEAH. FOR THE DURATION OF
THIS DOWNTURN PAST EXPERIENCE
DOES SUGGEST TO US THE SCHOOL
TAX WILL BE SEARCHED FOR
SEVERAL BUDGET CYCLES. AND AS A
REMINDER THAT GREAT. I THINK WE
ENDED IN JUNE OF TWO THOUSAND
NINE BUT THE STATE WAS STILL
GRAPPLING WITH BUDGET PROBLEMS.
TWELVE AND THIRTEEN. NOW WE
HAVE INCLUDED RECESSION
SCENARIOS IN OUR NOVEMBER
FISCAL OUTLOOK IN RECENT YEARS
IN THIS PAST YEAR AND IN
NOVEMBER WE LOOK AT IT WAS SORT
OF FULLER THIRTY TODAY BRIDGE
POST WORLD WAR TWO SESSION
UNDER THESE CAN. WE ESTIMATED
IN THE FOR YEAR REVENUES WOULD
BE TO. LAST PRAYER BACK THREE.
BUT THERE'D STILL BE A NOT
THIRTY BILLION. LOS OVER THE
NEXT COUPLE OF YEARS SO FOR
THAT THAT'S FOR A TOTAL OF
FIFTY BILLION DOLLAR SHORTFALL.
AND UNFORTUNATELY PRELIMINARY
INDICATIONS ARE THAT THE
REVENUE LOSSES IN THE CURRENT
DOWNTURN COULD BE WORSE IN
THIS. CENTURY ON A PAR WITH THE
TYPE OF DOWNTURN WE SAW IN THE
GREAT RECESSION. THAT WOULD BE
CONSISTENT WITH A THIRTY FIVE.
REVENUE SHORTFALL THE FIRST
YEAR IN. ADDITIONAL EIGHTY FIVE
BILLION REVENUE SHORTFALL IN
THE YEARS. AFTER SO THE BUDGET
PROBLEMS OF THIS MAGNITUDE WERE
TO EMERGE THEY WOULD EXCEED THE
STATE'S RESERVES WHICH WE
ESTIMATOR CURRENTLY AT
SEVENTEEN AND A HALF BILLION.
ALL THE STATE. WE ON TRACK THE
SCHOOL YEAR WITH. RESERVES OF
ALMOST TWENTY ONE BILLION THIS
FIGURE- ARRESTED NOT A LOT OF
IT HAS COME DOWN SOMEWHAT SINCE
THE ONSET OF THE VIRUS AND THE
STATE'S RESPONSE. THE PROBLEM
HE LARGE AND WILL LAST LONGER.
WE RECOMMEND THE JUNE YOU OF
THE- AT LEAST AT FIRST UNTIL WE
HAVE A BETTER SENSE OF WHAT THE
REVENUE PICTURE WILL BE.
PRACTICE ONE APPROACH YOU MAY
WANT TO CONSIDER WOULD BE TO BE
GET IT'S CUT BUDGET
CONVERSATION GOING BACK TO
NOTION OF BASELINE. WE NOW MAY
MAKE IT EASIER TO ADDRESS.
PROBLEM DOES EMERGE LATER THIS
SUMMER. AND TO ASSIST YOU WITH
THAT WE'RE SETTING ASIDE MUCH
OF THE WHAT HAD BEEN UNDER
CONSIDERATION FROM JANUARY
THROUGH APRIL TO DEVELOP
ESTIMATES OF THE BASELINE
BUDGET AS IT WOULD BE TO. SHE
COULD THINK OF. SURE THIS.
UPDATING OUR BASELINE BUDGETING.
WHEN I SAY BASS LINE I MEAN IS
THE COST OF THE CONCERT.
ACCOUNTING FOR REVISED CASELOAD
ESTIMATES ANY INCREASES IN
MANDATORY EXPENDITURES ACROSS
THE RECENTLY ENACTED
LEGISLATION POSSIBLY JUST MEN'S
NOT JUST. SO AS YOU CAN SEE
FROM WHAT I JUST SAID THAT THE
CONCEPT OF A BASELINE- WORKLOAD
BUT IS OPEN TO SOME
INTERPRETATION. THEREFORE
MISSION THIS WE'RE ALL WELL IT
BEING SORT OF A BASS LINE. LOW
ESTIMATE. WHAT THE COST WOULD
BE IN OTHER WORDS. WHAT WOULD
BE. THE COST TO IN THE BUDGET
TO MAINTAIN SERVICE LEVELS TO
STILL MAINTAIN SERVICE LEVELS
BUT WITHOUT FULLY FUNDED ALL
THE- SCHOOL THAT MIGHT
OTHERWISE BE INCLUDED. PACIFIC
ECONOMIST FLAT FOR EXAMPLE OR
PULLING BACK GRANT ST HAVE YET
BEEN AWARDED OR REDUCING
NONESSENTIAL EQUIPMENT CAPITAL
OUTLAY X. THOSE ARE THOSE ARE
EXAMPLES OF WHAT THE LOW. HELLO
LOWERING THE BAIT AND WOULD
LOOK LIKE. SO I'LL KNOW I'M
INCLUDING HERE THAT BEFORE HE
DOES THE BALANCE REQUIREMENT SO
THIS. THE STATE'S ABILITY FOR
ECONOMIC IN THE WAY THAT THE
FOR I CAN. AND AFTER HAVING
LEARNED SOME TOUGH LESSONS IN
THE LAST RECESSION THE STATE
ENTERED AS ONE ON MUCH BETTER
FISCAL TWENTY. SO THE CAR
SHOULD BE SIGNED BUDGET MIGHT
BE ONE OF THE MOST EFFECTIVE
WAYS THE STATE CAN PROMOTE
POLICIES THE BILL TACTICS EXIST
IN STATE PROGRAM. NEVER
ANSWERED SHE- ALWAYS OUR OFFICE
WILL BE STANDING BY. READY TO
ASSIST YOU AS YOU THROUGH THAT
AND THAT IN THE COMING WEEKS
NINE. THANK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MISTER PATRICK AND AS
ALWAYS TO THE BUDGET PROCESS SO
WE LOOK FORWARD TO OUR-
RELATIONSHIP WITH YOU THE LA ON
ALL THE ALISON YOUR UTENSIL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IN CALL X.
UP THE WILL OF I TOLD ALL MY-
L. THREE PRESENTERS STAR. NAY
WE'LL HEAR FROM THE DEPARTMENT
OF FINANCE WELL TO MISS THIS
ONE OFTEN THREE SCALP. IN WITH
THIS. GOOD AFTERNOON YOU HEAR
ME WE CAN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE WE WELCOME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ENGAGE WITH YOU
ASKED TAKE THIS AND- MINE AT
STAND ON THE LINE WITH ME
STREETS ACCOUNT WHERE WHO'S
PLANE A LEADING AND TRACK ALSO
WORK EXPENDITURES IN TO IN
NINETEEN AS AS- CALL. SERVICES
AGENCY ARE NATURE IS OF THE
DEPUTY SECRETARY OVER THE AS
WELL AS YOU KNOW CURRY RISKY
JACK DIRECT. CALIFORNIA GOT
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY START EACH
DAY ON THE LINES HELP SPEAK TO
CLASS FROM TO OUR PUBLIC. IN MY
BRIEF TIME ANY I JUST WANT DO
TO NUMBER. TOUCH BRIEFLY ON THE
OVERALL ECONOMIC SAID. AS WE
HAD AND THE FUTURE. AND THEN
NUMBER TO DISCUSS THE STATE'S
RESPONSE. ON THE OVERALL I CAN
SITUATION AS THE UP AND DOWN
THE- ON HEALTH. AND MEASURES
AND DROPPING ACTIVITY WELCOME
BY YEAH. LOOTING WHAT WE SEE
WILL BE YES YES NEGATIVE EFFECT
ON REVENUE USE BOTH IN CURRENT
YEAR WELL AS THE UPCOMING SHE-
CONTACT. IN JANUARY AND THEY
GOT LIKE DEPARTMENT FINANCE
EVERY SCENARIO. ONE SACK YEAR.
IN THE GREAT RECESSION TEN
YEARS AGO UNEMPLOYMENT HE WOULD
OVER CHRIS. READY ON PLAYING
RATES AND INSTALL GIVEN ENOUGH
THAT WERE SEEING AND THAT THE
ONLINE. THAT THE ITEM RATE IN
THIS CAN GO HIGHER THAN. AS THE
CHAIR NO WE MASON CON WORKING
THE LIKES. IN THE WALLS.
PUTTING ADDITIONAL MY OR NOT
WIND. IN A RESEARCH AND
ENACTING BUDGET LAST YEAR THAT
WAS STRUCTURALLY NOW. YET EVEN
WITH THIS QUESTION WOULD IS
NEVER OF OUR THAN WHAT WE WENT
TO DURING THE LAST. YEAH
DECISION YOU WILL IT HAD. OR
ANY PROPOSALS. ACTUALLY HAD AND
THE NAY REVISION. SO THAT THE
GENERAL KIDS I CAN TAKES. WHEN
IT COMES THE PUBLIC HEALTH
RESPONSE THE ADMINISTRATION IS
GREAT FOR THE APPROPRIATE. YES
EIGHTY NINE AND ASKING ONE
SEVEN. WE'VE ALREADY I YOU KNOW
TO A LOT OF THE RESOURCE
THROUGH THOSE APPROPRIATIONS AS
WELL AS THROUGH THE THREE I
WATCHED THIS IS THE DESIGN
RESPONSE MERGE OPERATIONS.
WE'RE ALL AT TIME WE EXPECT
APPROXIMATELY BILLION. THIS
YEAR IT SURE IS THIS CALL THE
NIGHT. TWENTY AND THEN ON TOP
AND ACE. CASE WHAT X. AS THEY
RELATE TO OUR CAL. WORKS HOW
WORKS FROM IS UNDER. WE ACCESS
THE KNOWLEDGE THAT WE EXPECT
THAT FOR EXPENDITURES IN THIS
AREA. EMAIL WILL REIMBURSE ON
ASSEMBLY LINES. AND SO OUR TO
AS WELL AS OTHER TO AND
AGENCIES ACROSS THE EXACT CRASH
ARE REALLY HARD TO TRACK LOS
FUNDING AND. EVERY CHILD. I
MENTIONED THE STIMULATE DON'T
MICHAEL EVEN TWO POINT TWO TROY
DOLLARS IS REALLY ENOUGH TO
ADDRESS OUR GIVE THE SCALE THAT
WE AS WELL AS STATES THE OUR
STATE SO THE GOVERNOR LASTLY
CENTRAL TO WHO ASK FOR IT ONE
TRULY DOLLARS IN REALLY LOCAL
GOT. CATION WORK PROTECTION.
SUPPORTING OUR SMALL BUSINESS
AND- AS EVEN ONCE DOLLARS WILL
BE IN TO AVOID THE WHOLE THAT
WERE IN BUT IT'LL HELP US IN MY
THE MOST DEVASATING CUTS AND
MAKE OUR WAY THROUGH THE CRISIS.
BEFORE I TURN IT OVER TO TRACE
AND BEFORE WE ANY I WANT TO
MAKE. POINTS NOW WE KNOW AS THE
CHAIRMAN. THIS IS ON PRESS
SITUATION AND WE HAVE OUR TEAM
ON TE LINE IS LOW THE
SECRETARIES FROM A TEACHER AND
WE. HEARING THAT AND MAYBE
YOU'RE- SURE TAKE YOUR INNER
AREAS WHERE WE MAY HAVE TO UP
IN THE DAYS WEEKS WITH MORE.
NUMBER ONE HUNDRED EACH YEAR
ALSO TO THE CON IS MOST OFHE
IN OTHER. THIS INFORMATION IS
HANGING TIME AND I KNOW WITH
WE ASK WILL RESPOND TO BEST OF
HER BY GIVE HOW MUCH IS LACKS
WE MAY HAVE TO UP WITH MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. YOUR IN WHICH
WE- MORE DEEP. WE ARE JUST ARE
PLANNING CURRENT PASSAGE.
STANDINGS A LOT OF THAT SEVEN
GOING DOLLAR EXPENSE OR WHAT
THE BIBLE ACTUALLY A WILL BE
FOR THE TWENTY TWENTY YEARS IS
UNCERTAIN WE ASK YOUR PATIENCE
ON THAT AND THEN I DON'T AREA
THE SIZE AS DELHI ON NINE STAND
AN ASK YOUR STAND. RIGHT NOW A
CRISIS WHICH OF COURSE MAKES UP.
BUDGET ISSUE. IS AS WE KNOW THE
NEIGHBOR WILL BE RELEASED AND
THAN A MONTH BUT IN THIS COUPLE
WEEKS. GOVERNOR IS STILL. A
SONY FINAL EXCUSE FOR HOW YOU
TO APPROACH THAT PROJECTS SO IN
FOR SOME YOUR QUESTIONS THAT WE
MAY NEED TO FOLLOW UP WITH YOU
BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT TO
SPECULATE ON COURSES ACTION. I
GOVERNOR. ASK YOUR PAY. IN
THOSE HERE. PLEASE THAT WE'RE
DOING EVERY THAT WE CAN.
PROVIDE IT FOR. TO THE
LEGISLATURE THAT IS THE TIMES.
AND SO THAT THE LEGISLATURE TO.
ITS OVER. ROLE AND WE LOOK
TOWARDS CONTINUING TO TOUCH
WITH YOU AND WORK TOGETHER. I
SALAS AFTER THIS YEAR. AND SO
THAT ALTERNATE OVER TO MY
COLLEAGUE RECENT CALVERT WILL
PROVIDE. DETAILED ACCOUNTING OF
THE STATE'S EXTENDED. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THREE SO GO AHEAD.
HAPPENING BUT DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I WILL BE GETTING A
LITTLE DESCRIPTION OF THE
ALLOCATIONS MADE- PARTICULARLY
IN THREE AREAS OF THE BRAIN SB
EIGHTY NINE AND ALSO THE
ALLOCATION FROM THE DISASTER
RESPONSE EMERGENCY OPERATIONS
ACCOUNT AND ASKING SEVENTEEN.
SB A NINE ALLOCATION TOTAL
APPROXIMATE SEVEN HUNDRED AND
SIXTY NINE MILLION DOLLARS AND
HAVE BEEN FOR THE FOLLOWING AND
WHAT WE'LL CALL IS A LIST OF A
NUMBER OF ITEMS. BUSINESS
SERVICES AND HOUSING IN. THE
NINETEEN PREVENTION AND
CONTAINMENT AMONG THE HOMELESS
POPULATION. FIFTY MILLION FOR
THEIR PART OF THE SOCIAL
SERVICES FOR HOTEL MOTEL DANCE
AND- SEVEN. EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES A HER HEALTH SURGEON
BUT AND THAT TRANSFER SERVICES
ONE POINT FOUR MILLION FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH
CARE HOSPITAL FACILITIES IN
LABORATORY CAPACITY. FIVE
MILLION FOR THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES OUR IN HOUSE
BORDER SERVICES THE MONISTAT
CALLS AND THEN. TWENTY NINE
PARTNER SOCIAL SERVICES FOR ME.
ONE MILLION OR SOCIAL SERVICES
FOR RESPONDING TO THE NINETEEN
IN RESIDENTIAL CARE FACILITIES.
FORTY FIVE MILLION FOR THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
AND DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES FOR OUR COUNTY
ADMINISTRATION. NATION FOR THE
BOARD OF STATE AND COMMUNITY
CORRECTIONS FOR REIMBURSEMENT
ACCOUNT INFORMATION DEPARTMENTS
FOR SUPERVISION OF OFFENDERS
RELEASED FROM PRISON EARLY. IN
NINETEEN. FIVE POINT SEVEN
MILLION FOR THE CORRECTIONS AND
REHABILITATION FOR
REIMBURSEMENT COUNTY JAILS FOR
HOUSING INMATES NOT BE
ACCEPTABLE PRESENTED TO
SUSPENSION OF INTAKE. FIFTY
MILLION OR THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT TO SUPPORT SMALL
BUSINESSES EXPERIENCING
HARDSHIP. ONE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY EIGHT POINT WO MILLION
TO THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES FOR THE PROCUREMENT OF
DEPENDABLE SUPPLY MEDICAL GRADE
MASKS. AND THERE'S AN
ADDITIONAL ALLOCATION AND ALL
COVERED IN THE NEXT SET.
RELATED TO THIS ITEM. EDUCATION
FOR THESE COVERINGS BLESSING
CLINGING FOR CHILD CARE
FACILITIES. FIFTY MILLION TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION FOR
EXPANDED ACCESS TO SUBSIDIZE
CHILD CARE FOR CHILDREN OF
ESSENTIAL WORKERS AT RISK
CHILDREN. FORTY TWO POINT SIX
MILLION TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES FOR OUR STAGE
ONE CHILD CARE WRITER
REIMBURSEMENTS IN CHILD WELFARE
SERVICES. AND SEVENTY SIX POINT
THREE NINE TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SOCIAL SERVICES. THIS
INCLUDES SIXTY THREE POINT
THREE MILLION TO ASSIST
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS
NEGATIVELY IMPACTED BY CO IN
NINETEEN. NINE GENERAL
ELECTRONIC BENEFIT TRANSFER.
THIS IS. AND THREE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR FOSTER YOUTH
PROGRAMS. AND. I THERE'S ALSO
LESSEN THE FINANCE WEBSITE THAT
SHOW HE'S ALREADY. I AM IN
ADDITION TO THOSE SB EIGHTY
NINE ALLOCATIONS A LARGE STRIKE
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
PROVIDED A NOTICE OF A ONE
POINT THREE BILLION DOLLAR
TRANSFER FROM THE SPECIAL FUNDS
FOR ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTIES TO
THAT RESPONSE REGENCY
OPERATIONS ACCOUNTS. THOSE
ALLEGATIONS FROM THAT PART OF
FUNDING HAVE BEEN- A ONE
BILLION DOLLAR ALLOCATION
DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL SERVICES
FOR A SURPRISE THIS INCLUDES.
BUT MEDICAL SUPPLIES AND
ENHANCING SEARCH HOSPITALS AND
MEDICAL. I ALONG WITH A THREE
HUNDRED SIX TWENTY MILLION
ALLOCATION TO THE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES WHICH IS
RELATED TO THE ISSUE NOTED
EARLIER FOR THE PROCUREMENT OF
SUNLIGHT OF MEDICAL GRAY MASS.
LASTLY AN SP ONE SEVENTEEN WAS
SIGNED BY THE GOVERNOR MARCH
SEVENTEENTH AND PROVIDED A
HUNDRED MILLION FOR LOCAL
EDUCATIONAL AGENCIES FOR
EQUIPMENT. AND SANITIZING
NUTRITION AND DISTANCE
LEARNING. AND I WANTED TO
REITERATE THAT AT THIS TIME WE
ARE MEETING AGAIN OF 35% IN
PERSON FOR THESE COSTS. QUICK
RUNDOWN OF THE ALLEGATIONS AND
WE HAVE A TEAM AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER QUESTIONS- AFTER THE
SNEAKERS. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
APPRECIATE THAT I ALSO TO MAKE
SURE PEOPLE UNDERSTAND- AND-
THAT THE- DOCUMENT THAT THE LA-
WENT THROUGH AS WELL AS-
DEPARTMENT FIVE INTERPRETATION
IS AVAILABLE ON THEIR WEBSITE.
AS WELL AS THE FULL AGENDA FOR
TODAY'S HEARING ALL WILL BE IS
AVAILABLE ON THE SENATE BUDGET
COMMITTEE WEBSITE FOR PEOPLE TO
HAVE ACCESS TO THOSE. DOCUMENTS
THE SERVICE THIS ONE I THOUGHT
I WANTED THIS ONE OFF AND I
WANT TO THANK YOU AND IT NOT
THAT WE FULLY UNDERSTAND THE
UNIQUE CIRCUMSTANCES UNDER
WHICH YOU. ARE ALL OPERATING AS
WELL AS ATTEMPTING TO. BUILD
THE BUDGET SO MANY UNKNOWNS WE-
WE FULLY GET THAT YOU WANT TO
AND THE- THIS IS THE
LEGISLATORS OPPORTUNITY FOR US
TO THE- PUT ON RECORD THE
QUESTIONS. INQUIRE WE HAVE SO
WE UNDERSTAND THAT MANY OF YOUR
ANSWERS MAY BE WE DON'T NOW BUT
I HOPE YOU UNDERSTAND THAT THIS
IS OUR OPPORTUNITY. TO ENGAGE
IN OVERSIGHT AND RAISE THE
QUESTIONS FOR YOU TO CONSIDER.
ON AN ONGOING BASIS SINCE THAT
IS. WITH WHICH WE WILL ENGAGE.
YOU UNDERSTAND OUR PERSPECTIVE
AS WE WILL UNDERSTAND THAT. YOU
MAYES SOMETIMES HAVE ANSWERS
THAT WE FOR THE STAND. AT THIS
POINT AGAIN COLLEAGUES ARE
GONNA HOLD ALL QUESTIONS- THE
END WHICH IS OUR OUR THIRD AND
FINAL SPEAKER- TODAY- WHICH IS
CHRIS. HOMES AND NOT A STRANGER
TO THIS CAN. EXECUTIVE THE BY
THE POLICY CENTER. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH YES. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. NUMBER ONE. WE AT THE
CALIFORNIA BUDGET IN THE CENTER
PUSH THE OP. TO PARTICIPATE IN
TODAY'S HEARINGS MY REMARKS
TODAY WILL FOCUS ON THE STATE'S
OPTIONS FOR HOW IT RESPONDS THE
ECONOMIC IMPLICATIONS OF THE
CRISIS WITH A PARTICULAR FOCUS
ON THOSE CALIFORNIANS WERE MOST
AFFECTED AT SEVERAL LIKE WEEKS
AGO WE OUTLINED A SET OF
PRINCIPLES FOR HOW THE STATE
RESPONDS THE FIRST OF THOSE IS
TO MAXIMIZE. WE CAN MAXIMIZE
IMPACT ADMITTEDLY WITH
CONSTRAINED RESOURCES ARE
RECOGNIZING THE FISCAL
REALITIES OUTLINED BY THE LA-
BUT ALSO RECOGNIZING THAT THE
STATE. MUST STILL SET
PRIORITIES FOR ITS SPENDING IN
WAYS THAT WILL HELP COMBAT THE
ECONOMIC IMPLICATIONS OF
CRISIS. AND THAT MEANS ARE
PROVIDING WELL TARGETED
RELEASED BY WRAPPING AROUND
CURRENT INVOLVING FEDERAL
FISCAL RELIEF TO FILL IN THE
GAPS ARE PRIORITIZING THE NEEDS
FOR THOSE WHO ARE MOST AFFECTED
AND HELP IN THE CALIFORNIANS
WHO. WON'T BE REACHED BY
EXISTING SYSTEMS. ENSURING THAT
THE RELIEF IS ALSO TIMELY AND
RECOGNIZES THE LENGTH OF THE
ECONOMIC DOWNTURN WILL ALSO BE
IMPORTANT THERE IS BOTH AN
IMMEDIATE NEED FOR IT A RELIEF
BUT THERE'S ALSO A NEED. FOR
POLICIES THAT PROVIDE RELIEF
BEYOND WHAT IS HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW GIVEN THAT IT APPEARS THAT
THE EFFECTS OF THE CRISIS
ECONOMIC CONTINUE BEYOND. THE
NEXT FEW WEEKS AND MONTHS AND
THAT MOST OF THE FEDERAL RELIEF
COULD RUN OUT FOR ECONOMY HAS
RECOVERED. WE RELEASED A SERIES
OF BRING FOR PORTS EXAMINING
WHO ARE THE WORKERS MOST
AFFECTED BY THE ECONOMIC
IMPLICATIONS OF THE CRISIS
INCLUDING TWO FACTIONS RELEASED
THIS MORNING COMBINED THOSE ON
OUR- OCTOBER NINETEEN PAGE ON
OUR WEBSITE A CAL BUDGET CENTER
.ORG. THOSE FACT SHEETS SHOW
AND WORK WE'VE DONE PREVIOUSLY
IS THAT MOST. THOSE WILL BE
MOST AFFECTED INCLUDE
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES HAS HAS HAS BEEN
REFERENCED EARLIER.
CALIFORNIA'S HOME TO TWO TO
THREE MILLION UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS ABOUT 6% OF THE
STATE'S POPULATION. TWO THIRDS
OF UNDOCUMENTED INDIVIDUALS
HAVE BEEN IN THE STATE FOR MORE
THAN TEN YEARS. THEY ARE
EMPLOYEES CURRENTS CHILDREN.
AND THEY ARE OUR CO WORKERS AND
NEIGHBORS THE VAST MAJORITY
ELEVEN MAKE STATUS HOUSEHOLDS
INCLUDE U. S. CITIZENS. THERE
ARE MANY OF OUR ESSENTIAL
WORKERS WORKERS TO GROW PREPARE
AND DELIVER OUR FOOD BUILD AND
MAINTAIN OUR FACILITIES. I
CHAIR FOR US OUR CHILDREN AND
OUR PLAYERS AND THEY CONTRIBUTE
THREE BILL DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
ACT HOW THE OUT OF. EIGHT AND
MANY OF THIS AND SUPPORTS THAT
AVAILABLE OTHER WORK BUT OUR
SHORTLY. THE WORKERS AND
FAMILIES MOST THERE ARE ALSO
PEOPLE OF COLOR AMONG WORKERS
AT HIGH RISK OF LOSING JOBS ARE
HOURS BECAUSE THEY WORK IN A
HIGHLY EFFECTIVE IN THE STREET
NEARLY TWO AND THREE ARE PEOPLE
OF COLOR. AND THEY ARE ALSO
WORKERS WHO TEND TO HAVE LESS
EDUCATION ARE PAID LESS. ONE IN
THREE CALIFORNIA WORKERS WITH
LESS THAN A HIGH SCHOOL
EDUCATION WORKING INDUSTRY
MEDIA LIST IMMEDIATELY AFFECTED
BY THE COLD THE NINETEEN SLOWED
DOWN AND MANY OF THEM ARE IN
OCCUPATIONS A LOW A GET WAGERS.
PROVIDE LESS BENEFITS ANOTHER
PROTECTIONS AND RESULT THEY
WERE PAYCHECK TO PAYCHECK
LIKELY TO HAVE ASSETS BOB TIME
TO GET THEIR JOB IS THERE'S-
MON. OF THE KEY GAS IN THE
CURRENT AND INVOLVING FEDERAL
FISCAL REALLY AFFECT
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES. AND IT'S ABUNDANTLY
CLEAR THAT FUTURE FEDERALLY FOR
CONTINUE TO LEAD THESE GAPS
MAKING IT EVEN MORE IMPERATIVE
THE CALIFORNIA AS A STATE TAX
REBATE REBATES NOTABLY EXCLUDED
UNDOCUMENTED INDIVIDUALS. WITH
FEDERAL IDENTIFICATION TAX ART
BUT WITH I'M SORRY WITH FEDERAL
INDIVIDUAL TAX IDENTIFICATION
NUMBERS ARE AYE TENS AND
REQUIRE THAT EVERYONE IN THE
HOUSEHOLD HAVE SOCIAL SECURITY
NUMBER. AND WHAT THIS MEANS IS
IN OTHER WORDS IS OF THE RED
REBATES ARE NOT AVAILABLE NEXT
STATUS FAMILIES. WE HAVE BEEN
SAYING THAT THE STATE CAN AND
SHOULD ADDRESS THE EXCLUSION BY
PROVIDING EMERGENCY AID
DISTRIBUTED EITHER THROUGH
LOCAL COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS ARE COUNTY SOCIAL
SOCIAL SERVICE AGENCIES. AND
PROVIDE A STATE CREDIT OR
REBATES TO THE CALATHEA ATC AND
YOUNG CHILD TAX CREDIT RIGHT
TEN PILAR'S. AND WE THEREFORE
APPLIED THE GOVERNOR'S
ANNOUNCEMENT YESTERDAY THAT THE
STATE WILL PROVIDE SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS SUPPLEMENTAL
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS TO COME
FROM AND TO BE A ONE TIME CASH
ASSISTANCE FRIEND DOCUMENTED
ADULT. THAT ASSISTANCE IS MUCH
NEEDED AND IT WILL START TO
HELP TO ADDRESS THE IMMEDIATE
IMPACTS OF THE CRISIS. BUT WE
ALL ALREADY KNOW THAT THE
IMMEDIATE IMPACT IS GREATER AND
THE NEED IS GREATER AS WELL AND
AS I NOTED EARLIER IT'S ALSO
CLEAR THAT THE ECONOMIC
IMPLICATIONS OF A CRISIS WILL
CONTINUE BEYOND THE IMMEDIATE
AREA. I'M NOT BE A NEED FOR
ASSISTANCE BEYOND. TODAY'S NEED.
THAT MEANS THE STATE SHOULD
CONSIDER BUILDING OFF OF THE
GOVERNOR'S INITIAL PROPOSAL BY
BUILDING ON THE CALORIE I. T.
C. AND THE YOUNG CHILD TAX
CREDIT TO INCLUDE I. TEN
PILAR'S. INCREASING THE COST I
AM SORRY INCREASING THE SIZE OF
THE CREDIT. FOR THOSE
HOUSEHOLDS THAT WOULD OTHERWISE
BE RECEIVING SMALL AMOUNTS
UNDER THE WAY THOSE CREDITS
STRUCTURE CURRENTLY. AS TODAY'S
EMPLOYMENT INSURANCE DALY
REVEAL THEIR ALSO CONTINUE
NEEDS TO ADDRESS THE ALREADY
HIGH LEVELS OF UNEMPLOYMENT IN
OUR STATE. FEDERALLY IF IT'S
HELPFUL BUT IT NOTABLY EXCLUDES
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS WHO ARE
NOT ELIGIBLE FOR UNEMPLOYMENT
INSURANCE. IN THE STATE TO
PROVIDE ITS OWN UNEMPLOYMENT.
BUT WAGE REPLACEMENT BY AND-
PROVIDE WE CLEAR LUMP SUM
PAYMENTS TO THOSE. WHOSE WORK
AND DO NOT QUALIFY FOR
INSURANCE. ANOTHER WAY TO HELP
UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS AND THEIR
FAMILIES SYSTEM TO ENSURE THAT
THEY HAVE ACCESS TO HEALTH
INSURANCE. WHICH IS PIVOTAL TO
THEIR ABILITY TO RESPOND TO
BOTH THE HEALTH AND ECONOMIC
ASPECTS OF THE CRISIS. WE
APPLAUD THE STATE'S NEW POLICY
ANNOUNCED LAST WEEK THAT ALLOWS
EVERYONE ROLLED MEDI CAL
INCLUDING AN ACCURATE
IMMIGRANTS TO RECEIVE NO COST
OVER NINETEEN. STING
IMPROVEMENT BUT OVERALL MOST
UNDOCUMENTED ADULTS STILL LACK.
I HEALTH COVERAGE IN THE STATE
COULD CONTINUE TO MAKE PROGRESS
IN THAT ARENA. THERE ARE OTHER
GAPS IN THE FEDERAL FISCAL
RELIEF THAT ARE SIGNIFICANT AND
WAYS OF THE STATE MY RESPOND
THE ADDITIONAL PAID LEAVE
PROVIDED BY THE FEDERAL RELIEF
INCLUDES IN EXCLUDES EMPLOYERS
OF MORE THAN FIVE HUNDRED
EMPLOYEES. 44% OF CALIFORNIA'S
WORKFORCE FOR MORE THAN EIGHT
MILLION WORKERS THAT MEANS
ADDITIONAL WORK PROTECTED
LEAVE. INDIVIDUALS AND
PARTICULARLY FOR THOSE
RESPONSIBLE FOR CARING FOR
CHILDREN OR ADULTS WHO ARE
UNABLE TO WORK DUE TO THE
CLOSURE OF FACILITIES THAT
COULD BECOME INCREASINGLY
IMPORTANT AS THIS GOES ON.
CALIFORNIA WILL RECEIVE THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN RELIGIOUS FOR CHILD
CARE ASSISTANCE DELIVERED. THE
FEDERAL CCTV G. PROGRAM BUT WE
KNOW THE MOST CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS BEEN FORCED TO
TEMPORARILY CLOSED MANY
ESSENTIAL WORKERS ARE
STRUGGLING TO FIND THAT CARE.
AND THEY'LL BE A CONTINUED NEED
IN THAT ARENA GOING FORWARD.
AND LASTLY IN THEIR IN HOPE IN
THAT IN TERMS OF HOMELESSNESS.
FEDERAL RELIEF PROVIDE SOME
ASSISTANCE FOR SUBSIDIZED
HOUSING EMERGENCY GRANTS
ASSISTANCE AND THERE MAY BE
MORE FEDERALLY IT'S WORTH
COMING. BUT WE KNOW CALIFORNIA
IS ALREADY DEALING WITH THE
HOMELESSNESS CRISIS BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC AND MANY MORE PEOPLE
WILL NOW BE AT RISK OF FALLING
INTO HOMELESSNESS. BECAUSE OF
THE URGENCY TEN ZERO CRISIS THE
STATE REQUIRES A RESPONSE
SHOULD CONTINUE TO PRIORITIZE.
FUNDING FOR LOCAL CURRENCY. IT
IS A- STABILITY FOR THE RAY OF
METERS AND SUPPORTS. IN CLOSING
I CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMIC POLICY
RESPONSES TO FOCUS ON TARGETED
AND WELL TIMED ACTIONS TO
ADDRESS THE NEEDS OF WORKERS
AND FAMILIES WERE MOST SEVERELY
AFFECTED LEAST LIKELY TO BE
ABLE TO HELP. ME HELP BY
AVAILABLE SYSTEMS AND SUPPORTS
AND MOST AT RISK OF I'M TERM
ECONOMIC AND SECURITY THOSE
EFFORTS WILL PAY OFF IN THE
BEEN PROVIDING ECONOMIC
SECURITY AND STABILITY OF THE
HIGH CRISIS HELP STIMULATE THE
STATE'S ECONOMY THEREAFTER I'M
SURE THERE WILL BE THOSE WHO
WILL SAY THAT. FOR THESE SORTS
OF TARGETED IN. WE RECOGNIZE IT
RESOURCES WILL BE CONSTRAINED
AND THAT YOU WILL BE ABLE TO DO
EVERYTHING. I'D OUTLINED A FEW
THINGS HERE THAT WE THINK ARE
HIGH NEED OPTIONS AND WE SUBMIT
THAT WE CAN'T AFFORD TO DO
NOTHING BUT YOU GET A LITTLE.
LONGER TERM COST TO OUR STATE
ITS ECONOMY AND ITS PEOPLE WILL
FAR OUTWEIGH THE SHORT
BUDGETARY US. IT HAS SHOWN IT
CAN WHETHER DOWNTURNS IN THE
FISCALLY PRUDENT. THE BILL
RESERVES TO PREPARE FOR FUTURE
NEEDS. POLICY MAKERS CAN LEAD
THE STATE FORWARD AGAIN BY
ENSURING THAT CHILDREN FAMILIES
AND WORKERS THE HARDEST NOW.
AND OUR ECONOMY OVERALL DON'T
PAY THE PRICE OF THE KOBE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC FOR YEARS TO
COME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
LOOK FORWARD TO TAKING
QUESTIONS THE APPROPRIATE TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
APPRECIATE BOTH A- BUDGET AND
POLICY CENTER IS ALL THE LA-
FOR IDENTIFYING STRATEGIES WE
MIGHT CONSIDER AS WELL AS-
IDENTIFYING GAPS IN FUNDING AND
SUPPORT THUS FAR WE APPRECIATE
YOU- CHRIS BEFORE WE MOVE ON
WOULD YOU MIND GIVEN THE- UP.
BUDGET AND POLICY CENTER
WEBSITE ONE MORE TIME. THAT YES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
THAT'S CAL BUDGET CENTER DOT
ORG THANK YOU EXCELLENT THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. OUR COLLEAGUE
YOU'RE GONNA TRANSITION NOW-
INTO OUR OPPORTUNITY TO ASK
QUESTIONS OF MEMBERS I'M GOING
TO START WITH A FEW JUST TO.
SET THE STAGE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE CLEAR ABOUT KIND OF THE
FOCUS IN THE INTENT OF TODAY'S
HEARING ALL OF THE IN A TODAY
SUBCOMMITTEE HEARING IS NOT.
FULL EXPANSIVE- REVIEW OF THE
OVERALL BUDGET BUT REALLY IS
FOCUSED ON THE THREE THINGS
IDENTIFIED DURING OUR- UNDER MY
OPENING STATEMENT SO BY MAY
BEGIN. I WANT TO ASK THE
FINANCE. IT'S CLEAR THAT YOU
AND THE LA YOU AGREE THAT WE
WILL LIKELY FACE A BUDGET
CHALLENGE AS A RESULT OF THIS
PANDEMIC I WONDER IF YOU CAN
BEGIN BY TELLING US IF YOU
BEGUN TO SEE IN THE IMPACT TO
OUR COLLECTIONS ARE. WHERE DO
WE CURRENTLY HAVE COMPARED TO
THE JANUARY REVENUE PROJECTION.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR SO I
THINK WHAT WE'RE SEEING RIGHT
NOW IS THAT THIS CRISIS IS COME
ABOUT OF COURSE IT'S BEEN IN
THE MAKING FOR SEVERAL MONTHS
THANKS THE IMPACT HAS BEEN IN
THE LAST SEVERAL WEEKS SO
CITING THAT THE MOST RECENT
DATA. WE HAVE. EVEN THE
INCLUDING- SUMMER UNEMPLOYMENT
WE ARE ALSO. NUMBER OF CLAIMS
INCREASE EVERY WEEK BUT WHEN IT
COMES TO OUR CASH COLLECTIONS
JOBS REPORTS THE BEST EVIDENCE
WE HAVE RIGHT NOW IS ACTUALLY
MOSTLY CREE CRISIS AND SO
COMING INTO THE GOVERNOR'S
EMERGENCY DECLARATION ON MARCH
INSTEAD WORRY AT THIS POINT WE
WORK SEVEN EIGHT MONTHS INTO
THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY IT'S
JUST GOING YEAR. PERSONAL
INCOME TAX CASTLE PORTIONS WERE
ACTUALLY RUNNING ABOUT A
BILLION DOLLARS OVER IN ABOUT
THE TWENTY NINETY BUDGET AX
FORECAST YEAH AND SALES TAXES
AND CORPORATE TAXES WERE LITTLE
MORE NEUTRAL BUT WE WERE
RUNNING OUT OF NOT WORK. COMES
TO THOSE. MY YOUR MENTIONING WE
EXPECT TO SEE THAT AND DATA
SOON BUT WE'LL HAVE TO WAIT FOR
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION I THINK
ONE OTHER THING PUBLIC ALL
BASED ON THE- REESE. IS THAT
BOTH THE FEDERAL GOT. AND THE
STATE GOVERNMENTS HAVE TO.
ACTION FOR MOST TAXED. LAST
FROM APRIL SIXTEENTH CONSOLE
JULY. AND THEN THERE SOME
RELIEF NICE WITH TO SELL STOCK
FOR SMALL AS WELL SO FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ARE ANXIOUS A PRETTY
STEEP DECLINE IN THE CAST WE'RE
COLLECTING OVER THE NEXT THREE
MONTHS OF COURSE THAT CASH WILL
COME BACK BY JULY FIFTEENTH.
SENATOR DAN WHAT. THERE ARE.
GETTING OUR- BUDGETARY
PROJECTION FOR THE NAY REVISION
AND ASK FOR THE OP COMING
FISCAL YEARS AND IN ADDITION.
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NAME
IS XIN ARE WORKING VERY CLOSELY
WITH THE STATE COMPTROLLER'S
OFFICE TO MONITOR CáC. GEN AND
MAKING SURE WE HAVE A QUESTION-
BETWEEN NOW AND- YOUR- THANK
YOU AGAIN FOR FINANCE- YOU
TALKED ABOUT THE NEED FOR A
YEAR YOUR CURRENT ESTIMATE
BEING OF ABOUT SEVEN BILLION
DOLLAR IN STATE EXPENDITURES TO
COMBAT CALL THAT TEAM- MY
QUESTIONS WILL ALL THIS FUNDING
BE DONE THROUGH THE SECONDARY
FIX PROCESS. BUT HELLO BY THIS.
THIS IS OF A PROCESS QUESTION
WHAT CAN WE ANTICIPATE AS THE
LEGISLATURE. NICE GOING DOLLAR
FIGURE AS DISCUSSES UNCERTAIN
SO WE WILL CONTINUE TO UPDATE
AS WE HAVE MORE CLARITY OF WHAT
THE LEVEL OF THOSE EXPENDITURES
ACTUALLY WILL BE WHEN IT COMES
TO THAT AND THEN NOW IN THE
NEXT COUPLE WEEKS AS YOU KNOW
WE CAN MAKING. EXPENDITURES OUT
OF PROCREATION MONEY NASTY
EIGHTY NINE LOS SP ONE
SEVENTEEN AND THE TRIO. WHEN IT
TO THAT REVISION- THEN WILL
FOUR ACCOUNTING TERMS THAT HOW
RECEIVED AT THAT POINT AS WELL
AS A SENSE OF HOW WE WILL BE
ALLOCATING SOME OF THE FEDERAL
DOLLARS COMING IN. WERE MAKING
ASSUMPTIONS ABOUT THE
REIMBURSEMENT THAT WE'RE GONNA
JACKSON THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
FOR THE COST SHARE AND WITH
EACH PASSING WE WILL HAVE MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT THAT AS WELL.
TO SEE TIME. AND THE REPRESSION
THAT WE WILL HAVE. WORKS FULL
SEVEN GOING OR WHATEVER IT NEXT
YEAR ALSO WE WILL BE JUST THE
OF STREET SMARTS WILL. BUT
CERTAINLY IS THE CASE THAT. THE
NEIGHBOR WE'RE GONNA BE PUTTING
OUT BUDGET PLANS FOR THE SCHOOL
YEAR. BASED LINE BY BY WHICH
FOR TWO WEEKS FOR THE PLACES WE
INVEST FOR RESPONSE TO WORK
GOING TO GET THE THAT WE CAN
PROVIDE AT THAT TIME AND OF
COURSE IF THIS THING JANET
JACKSON TO USE THROUGHOUT THE
SUMMER WHICH IS MY YOU KNOW WE
MIGHT NEED TO DO SOME. WORK
WITH SELECT. OUR SHE'S. THANK
YOU THISMY LAST QUESTION FOR
YOU MISTER THIS ONE OFF AND ON
THE MOVE ON TO THE LA IF WE
HAVE TO YOU LAW THE RAINY DAY
FUND COULD YOU WALK OF THROUGH
WHAT ARE THE AND PROCESS YOU
LIE THE RESERVE. YES SO I'M
HAPPY TO BRIEFLY DISCUSS AND
THEN I KNOW LA- MAY HAVE SOME
COMMENTS AS WELL SO BASICALLY
THE RAINY DAY FUND IS STUFF
FROM THE BY. PROPOSITION TWO
WHICH LETTERS ARE. BALLOT
INITIATIVE THAT WAS ENACTED BY
THE VOTERS NUMBER OF TWENTY
FOURTEEN. AND BASICALLY THE WAY
IT WORKS IS THAT. THE FUNDS IN
THE RAINY DAY FUND AND WE SPEND
MANDATORY DEPOSITS IN THERE
WHICH IS THE MAJORITY. RENDON
RAINY DAY SIGNS CANNOT BE. ON
NUMBER ONE AT THE RISK. MERGING
YOU WOULD IS DECLARE BY I GOT
ARTS AND I INCLUDES SOME SWITCH.
DISASTER PERIL FOREST. IN WHICH
REVENUES COMING IN ALLOW LEVEL
THE LAST. FOUR YEARS AND THEN
THE SECOND THING IS NOT TO
APPROPRIATE FROM. THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD ALSO HAVE TO
TAKE ACT. AND THE THIRTEEN
THING TO. IS THAT THE
COMPOSITION TWO INCLUDES A
PROVISION THAT ONLY HALF OF THE
AVAILABLE SIGNS. IN THE RAINY
DAY FUNDS CAN BE WITHDRAWN IN A
GIVEN. YEAR AND HE SAID THAT-
THE REASON THAT PROVISION
EXISTS JUST TO MAKE SURE THAT
TIME ISN'T SIMPLY AND- ALL FROM
FISCAL YEAR. AND THEN YOU'RE
LEFT WITH NOTHING IN THE NEXT
FISCAL YEAR THE ECONOMIC IMPACT
OF WHATEVER RECESSION OR CRISIS
YOU'RE DEALING WITH EXTENDS
BEYOND THE FIRST THE SCHOOL
YEAR AND I STAYED WITH THE LA-
MENTION. THERE'S A VERY STRONG
POSSIBILITY WITH THIS CRISIS
THAT WE WILL SEE THE IMPACT NOT
ONLY IN THE CURRENT YEAR NOT
ONLY. YOUR AFTER BASS AND
EIGHTY EVEN HERE. THAT SO- THAT
IS A- KAPLAN TERMS IS THAT AND
HOW THAT CAN BE APPROPRIATED-
BUT THE ACTUAL NOW WILL BE
BASED ON ACT DISCUSSION.
RATIONS AND THE LEGISLATURE AND
THEN I THINK YEAH. ONE OTHER
POINT I'LL MAKE ON THE- RAINY
DAY FUND IS THAT I DON'T KNOW
YOU KNOW THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF
DISCUSSION IN TERMS OF THAT.
YOU KNOW WHAT'S YOUR MOUNTAIN
THE RAINY DAY SIGNED IT'S- UP
TO PROJECTIONS THE ACTUAL NINE
RAINY DAY FUND. WAITING TO SOME
COMP TIME. DON'T YOU WAIT. THAT
ARE BASED IN PROPOSITION TWO
KNOW WHEN IT COMES TO THE
NEIGHBOUR BASED. WE WILL HAVE.
ASKED IN THE IN TERMS OF WHAT
THE LEVEL AND THAT'S- ACTS WILL
BE FOR THE UPCOMING YEAR. IN A
WILL FINALLY AGAIN WITH REGARD
TO THE TRAIL ACCOUNT COULD YOU
TALK TO A SPECIFICALLY ABOUT
THE WHAT WHAT THE ONE POINT
FOUR BILLION IS BEING UTILIZED
FOR. AND IF YOU INTEND TO
TRANSFER ADDITIONAL FUNDS INTO
THE ACCOUNT. WE KNOW THAT ONE
TRANSFER IS TAKING PLACE DO YOU
INTEND TO DO MORE. YES IT IS
TRANSFERRING TO RESET MAY BE
ABLE TO SPEAK UP A LITTLE MORE
IN TERMS OF THE SPECIFICS FROM
THE TRAILER TRANSFER BUT THAT
TRANSFER WAS FOR. PROTECTIVE
MEDICAL EQUIPMENT RELATED FOR
THE FROM THE NINETEEN
EMERGENCY. IT IS POSSIBLE THAT
A GIVEN THE RECORD OF THE
GOVERNOR SIGNED AS SAYING ON
THAT UNDER THE EMERGENCY
SERVICES ACCESS RESPONDING TO
THIS CRISIS WE MAY NEED TO TAX
ANY LEGALLY AND IT PULLS. MAY%
TWENTY IT'S NOT FAR. IN THE
THREE OUR ACCOUNT IN ORDER
RESPOND. EMERGENCY IN REAL TIME.
THE ACTING NO ONE WE WILL MAKE
SURE. NOTIFICATION OF THAT THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVED A THREE
HOUR STATUTES AND THEN SECOND
IN THE NAY REVISION- WHEN IT
COMES TO ANY TRANSFERS THE ON.
THAT INITIAL ONE POINT THREE OR
ONE PRICE FOR THAT UNITED
STATES MAKING SURE THAT WE
SQUARE THAT UP IN OUR NEIGHBOR.
SO THAT YOU UNDERSTAND EXCEPT
THE BROADER FISCAL. IN WHICH
THAT. AT UP MISTER. QUICK FOR
PLEASE SIR. YOU KNOW WE'VE-
BEEN APPROPRIATELY BUILDING
RESERVES IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS
AS WELL AS WE PAY DOWN DEBT
INCURRED FROM- THE GREAT
RECESSION ABOUT A DECADE AGO-
CAN YOU TALK ABOUT OTHER
OPTIONS BESIDES USERS OF THE
STATE MAY HAVE. ACCESS TO THAT
WE- HOPE WE PROTECT PROGRAM AND
SERVICE LEVELS WITHOUT HAVING
TO CUT. MANAGER BUT IT'S A VERY
GOOD POINT THAT OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS THE- THE STATE
HAS. TO PAY DOWN VARIOUS KINDS
OF BUDGETARY DEBT THAT WERE
ACCUMULATED DURING THE CRIER
BUDGET CRISIS OF THE THAT THAT
STEM FROM THE GREAT RECESSION.
THERE ARE GENERALLY THREE OR
FOUR MAIN AVENUES THAT THE
LEGISLATURE CAN CONSIDER. ONE
ONE OF THEM WOULD BE WILL FUNDS
FROM OTHER SPECIAL FUNDS OF THE
STATE. NOW THERE'S PROBABLY TEN
BILLION ACCUMULATED BALANCES
AND THE OTHER NON GENERAL FUND
FUNDS OF THE STATE ALTHOUGH NOT
ALL OF THAT IS AVAILABLE IT IS
ONE SOURCE OF BUT- SOLUTION
THAT COULD HELP WITH THAT.
BUDGET PROBLEM. AS AS MANY
PEOPLE KNOW THE STATE ALSO
DURING THE PRIOR. THE BUDGET
CRISIS USED- DEFERRALS AND YOU
KNOW SORT OF A SHIFTING
PAYMENTS FROM ONE PERIOD OF
TIME TO A LATER PERIOD OF TIME
BUT I DON'T LIKE WIZARDS THOSE
OFFER ONE TIME SORT OF
BUDGETARY BENEFIT TO HELP WITH
IMMEDIATE BUDGET PROBLEM. AND
THEN- FINALLY THERE CAN BE.
SOME SOME USE OF FUN SHIPS
FUNDS THAT ARE TRADITIONALLY
USED IN ONE WAY CAN BE SHIFTED
OVER TO HELP THE GENERAL FUND
FOR A TIME AND I JUST MENTION
THAT ALSO A MAJOR A MAJOR THIS.
FORM OF ASSISTANCE ACTUALLY
COMES FROM FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
ALTHOUGH THAT'S NOT REALLY ONE
THAT YOU HAVE. HE TO DICTATE
WHAT THEY- I HAVE EIGHT OR
LEVEL OF A THEY PROVIDE BUT
THAT IS ALSO BEEN AND OTHER
SOURCE OVER THE YEARS THAT IS
HELP THE STATE WHEN THERE'S
BEEN A NATIONAL RECESSION.
THANK YOU MISTER THIS WILL
OFTEN DO YOU WANT TO RESPOND TO
THAT QUESTION OR SHOWING MOVE
ON. I THINK ALL DAY TO MOVE ON-THANK YOU THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE THAT- AT THIS TIME-
WE'RE GONNA. TURN TO MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE TO ASK QUESTIONS
SO FAR I HAVE Q. THAT. WHAT
MISTER MOORE LAW ONE SECOND MR
MORE LIKE WHAT I WANT YOU TO
KNOW THAT YOU'LL BE NEXT AND
SENATOR NIELSEN AND ADDING YOU
TO THE LIST WELL BEFORE WE DO
THAT I WANT TO MIND MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC THAT AT THE POINT IN
TIME WE GO BACK TO OUR WEEK AT
THE END OF THE ROOM THE PUBLIC
CONTRA I'M GONNA GIVE YOU THE-
AND- CO GET YOUR ACCESS TO IT.
PHONE ONE. EIGHT. TO TWO SIX
EIGHT TWO ONE SIX AND WHEN
PROMPTED THE ACCESS CODE IS.
ONE FIVE NINE THREE TWO NINE
FIVE AGAIN. ONE EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN TWO TWO SIX EIGHT TWO ONE
SIX. THE ACCESS CODE IS. ONE
FIVE NINE THREE TWO NINE FIVE.
WE'LL BEGIN WITH SENATOR MORE
LOCK. SENATOR MORE LOCK WHEN
YOU BEGIN IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
IDENTIFY WHO YOU'RE DIRECTING
THE QUESTION TO JUST SELL THE
I. T. TEAM HERE WIL BE READY
THAT WHEN YOU'RE DONE TO SWITCH
DIRECTLY TO THE PERSON YOU'D%
LIKE TO HAVE ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION FAIR ENOUGH. AS YOU
WISH MANAGER THANK YOU SIR
PROCEEDS. MANAGER LIKE TO
DIRECT MY FIRST QUESTION TO
MISTER CRADDICK THE LEGISLATIVE
ANALYST'S. I THANK YOU RELEASED
A REPORT ON APRIL STEP. THE
STATE BUDGET FACTS OF RECENT
FEDERAL ACTIONS REGRESS
NINETEEN AND ON PAGE TWO DO YOU
TALK ABOUT A HIGHER DRIVER
COSTS HIGHER. HIGHER DIRECT.
INDIRECT US IN THE LOWER
REVENUES AS A RESULT OF CHANGES
IN THE ECONOMY AND I'M I'M
WONDERING SINCE YOU DIDN'T
MENTION CALPERS YOUR CAL STARS
IF YOU HAD ANY COMMUNICATION
WITH EITHER OF. THEM TO SEE
WHAT MAY HAPPEN. IN THE NEXT
YEAR TO THREE AS RELATES TO
HIGHER COSTS FOR CONTRIBUTIONS
ON AN ANNUAL BASIS. THANK YOU
SENATOR MORE LACK. WE HAVE BEEN
IN COMMUNICATION WITH THEM ONE
ONE. ISSUE THE YOU MAY BE AWARE
OF IS THAT THERE. IS A
SIGNIFICANT LAG BETWEEN THE
TIME WHEN THE THERE'S A CHANGE
IN ASSET VALUES IN THE MARKET
AND THE WAY IT GETS
INCORPORATED INTO THE ACTUARIAL
ASSESSMENTS ASSESSMENT SO. THE
ASSUMING THAT THE MARKETS DO
NOT RECOVER AND THE- ONE IS FOR
THE YEAR IS SUBSTANTIALLY BELOW
THE ASK THE ACTUAR EARLY
ASSUMED RATES OF RETURN FOR
THIS YEAR WHICH SEEMS HIGHLY.
POSSIBLE AT THIS POINT WE COULD
EXPECT HIGHER CONTRIBUTION
REQUIREMENTS ARE IN TWO YEARS
FROM NOW ESSENTIALLY. THANK YOU
MY NEXT QUESTION MY LAST TWO
QUESTIONS MATTER JUROR TO WHAT
MR OF THIS ONE OF FUND. THE
FIRST IS THAT WE HAVE NOT
REALLY BEEN PUTTING MONEY ASIDE
IN THE SCHOOLS RAINY DAY FUND
SO I'M CURIOUS HOW. WE'RE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO ASSIST THEM
ESPECIALLY OF SOME NEVER GOING
TO BE DEALING WITH SICK MATT
THE FISCAL CRISIS MANAGEMENT
TEAM AND THEN THE SECOND
QUESTION. WOULD BE IF YOU CAN.
ACT. YES THANK YOU SENATOR MORE
LOCK UP A COUPLE OF QUICK
POINTS ON THE DAY SCHOOL WAS
AND THEN I WILL I STARTED OF
JANICE OUR CONTENT- YES YOU
KNOW CARI WITH REGARDS TO BE Y.
DE CONTRACTS I THINK THE FIRST
THING FOR THE RULES AS WE
ACTUALLY DID MAKE OUR FIRST
EVER DEPOSIT INTO THE PUBLIC
SCHOOL SYSTEM STABILIZATION
ACCOUNT LAST YEAR IT ALSO GOES
THROUGH ACTUAL PROCESS MAKES IF
I RECALL CORRECTLY. THERE'S
ABSOLUTELY AND HOURS IN THERE
NOW I THIS CASE ON THE OVERALL
COST NINETY EIGHT. WHICH OVER
EIGHTY BILLION. IT'S SMALL. BUT
NOT BE A- AND WE UNDER THE
RULES. IT'S ALSO ME BY. THIS
YEAR AND MENTION. FOR BECAUSE
LIKELY PROPOSITION NINETY LEVEL
WILL LOWER AND NEXT YEAR GIVEN
RIGHT USED WE'RE SEEING BACK.
TO THAT HUNDRED DOLLAR
APPROXIMATELY WILL BE AVAIL.
NINE EIGHT SO NOT SHOULD HELP
BEAR. IT'S NOT A LARGE NUMBERS
I THINK THE SECOND THING I'LL
SAY IS THAT. THE I. DEPOSITS
MADE ON OF THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
LAST YEAR ARE FOR THEIR TELLS.
LOWEST ON. SINCE BURKE'S CLASS
FINDLAURIE. THAT WAS TO
PRESSURE ON THIS DISTRICTS JUST
MY YEAR AND THIS YEAR BY OVER
TO BECAUSE THEY WERE TO. FOR IN
LONG HAUL. THE SYSTEMS AND IN A
LOT FASTER AND ALL NATION IS
THAT THE JURORS ACT IN ADDITION
TO THE OVERALL ONE HUNDRED
SIXTY BILLION DOLLARS IN AID
PROPERTY FOR STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. ALSO A SEPARATE-
BUCKET MONIES. FOR EDUCATION
AND I THINK IT WAS IN THE RANGE
OF ABOUT THIRTY BILLION DOLLARS
STATES AND SO WE'RE HAPPY TO.
MORE DETAIL ONCE THE SPECIFIC
SHARON BACKS FOR CALIFORNIA BUT
ALL OF THAT SHOULD HELP IT
CERTAINLY. DOESN'T NEGATE.
SOURCES THAT WE MIGHT TO MAKE
ARE GET TO SELL SUPPORT FROM
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT THAT
WERE SPEAKING ON AND THAT IS
THIS. THAT WE SEE RIGHT NOW AND
ALTERNATE OVER TO MY COLLEAGUES
HERE WITH REGARD TO THE WHITE.
THANK YOU. CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THE
QUESTION- WITH REGARD TO THE
PEOPLE ID CONTRACT HI AGAIN
THIS YEAR SORRY CALIFORNIA- YES
YOU CAN BE DIRECTOR THERE IS AS
AS WE KNOW THIS PANDEMIC AMONG
THE MANY CHAO. AND HARD. AS A
TREMENDOUS SHORTAGE AND VERY
NEED OR PERSONAL PROTECTIVE BUT
MATTER PP THAT AMONG THAT-
THINGS LIKE IN NINETY FIVE MASS
SURGICAL MASK RIGHT REJECTED
BUT NOT ONLY FOR OUR HEALTHCARE
WORKFORCE SO. UNDER THOSE IN
NEED THIS IS FOR UP AT
COMPETITION AROUND THE WORLD
AND IS EXTREMELY. OR OR NORMAL
SUPPLY CHAINS TO MEET THAT
DEMAND I'M SO CALIFORNIA LIKE
MANY OTHERS HAVE BEEN WORKING
ON THIS PROBLEM DAY AND NIGHT.
AND WE HAVE HAD A MULTI PRONGED
APPROACH FIRST WAS TO PURCHASE.
EVERY BABY CAN'T. HE IS
CRITICAL USING OUR SOURCES
USING THE STATE STOCK. MAKE
YOUR FOR THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
TO PROVIDE THAT DIRECTLY IN
ORDER TO YOU- YOU KNOW TO GET
AS MUCH SPEAKING OUT AS QUICKLY
AS WE CAN. WE'VE ALSO. OUR
CALIFORNIA AT EIGHT. WE BY
CLEANING TECHNOLOGY AWAY TO
STERILIZE ANNOUNCES. HELLO AND-
THAT'S BEEN CERTIFIED BY THE
FDA AS A WAY TO REUSE IT AND
THEN THE OTHER PROBLEM WAS THIS
APPROACH THAT. CAME UP WITH
BECAUSE OF THE SCALE OF ALL YOU
NEEDED IN CALIFORNIA WE HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO SECURE- AT
WHAT WE WHAT WE CONSIDER A
DEDICATED SUPPLY PIPELINE AND
THAT IS TRUE THAT THE-
CONTRACT. AND SO WE WORKED VERY
HARD AND ONLY ON THIS CONTRACT
FOR BUT I'M OF ALL AT. REQUIRE
THAT YOU. OR OR THE NEED WHY
AND OTHER PROTECTIONS TO MAKE
SURE THAT NOT ONLY ARE WE GOING
TO GET THESE THINGS THAT WE-
PEOPLE THAT NEED AT BUT ALSO
FOR TAX. OR IS IT LAST MINUTE
YEAH YOU KNOW WITH THAT
APPROPRIATE CONSIDERATIONS AND
ABILITIES TO PASSED- THAT BEAT
I'M DAVE MOUNTAIN THE TERMS IF
IT DOES NOT MEET OUR
SPECIFICATIONS SO- SO THAT'S
GENERALLY THE DESCRIPTION OF-
WHAT WE PUT INTO. THAT KIND OF
THIRD. YEAH YOU NEED TO WORK ON
THIS. HEY YEAH YEAH YOU GIVE
YOUR PURCHASE LIKE WHAT WE CAN
IN WHATEVER WE CAN'T MEET THE
REAL TIME HE- WE HAVE. MORE
THAN 90% OF PHARMACEUTICALS
BEING MANUFACTURED NOW TRYING
TO I'M JUST CURIOUS WHY WOULD
WE WANT TO ALL BY. STRUCTURE I
CAN WE FIND A PRODUCER
ENCOURAGE DEMONSTRATE
CALIFORNIA TO MAKE THE MASS.
THANK YOU FOR THAT QUESTION
THAT'S AN EXCELLENT POINT WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING ON THAT AS
WELL TO SEE WE CAN DO TO READ
YES TO CREATE SOME. YEAH THOSE
THINGS NOT BEEN COMING ONLINE
ENOUGH TO MEET THAT NEED AND
THAT THE SCALE BUT WE ARE
CONTINUING TO PURSUE THAT
AVENUE WE KNOW THAT THE NEED IS
GOING TO GO ON FOR SOMETIME
POTENTIALLY WE DON'T KNOW. HOW
LONG THIS WILL LAST IN ORDER.
OUR OUR YEAH BUT YOU THE VAST
AMOUNT BECAUSE WE HAVE SOME
PEOPLE CALIFORNIA SO MUCH. IN
THE CALIFORNIA AS QUICKLY WE
COULD BUT WE ABSOLUTELY ARE
PURSUING THOSE OPTIONS AS WELL.
BY ONE OF THE GERMAN FOR ASKING
ABOUT THIS INNER CORRESPONDENCE
REGARDING THE ESTABLISHMENT OF
EVEN THIS THIS PARTICULAR
MEETING. WELL THE CHAIR OR
ANYONE THAT IS LATER LIKE
MYSELF SEE THE CONTRACT. WE DO
INTEND TO PROVIDE THAT
CONTRACT- WE HAVE- EARNS ABOUT
RELEASING TOO MANY DETAILS
EVENT BECAUSE AGAIN OUR GOAL IS
TO GET THE SUPPLY INTO
CALIFORNIA OR THE PEOPLE YES IT
IS YOU CAN IMAGINE BUT
SOMETHING THAT IS SUCH HIGH
DEMAND IN A FIGHT. WE'RE
LOOKING. THERE ARE A LOT OF
THINGS COME INTO PLAY JUST
DEPENDS WE JUST WROTE THAT. TO
YOU KNOW IT IN THAT ARE WE THAT
AND WAY AND WE WERE NOT BE. OLD
HEALTHCARE IN. AND OTHER
RESPOND OR SO WE DO. TO PROVIDE
THAT WHEN WE HAVE A SURE AND-
AS THIS FIGHT IS. GOING TO BE
ARRIVING IN. IT WHICH I
REQUIREMENTS. PART BANK YOU
THANK YOU MAY CHAIR THAT'S MIKE.
KATIE VERY MUCH MORE LAW WILL
GO NEXT THIS. KERR THE- SHARE
HOLDING THIS HEARING AND FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO ASK YOU A
QUESTION IS- I WANT TO THANK
THE ADMINISTRATION FOR THEIR
TIRELESS WORK IN YOUR
COMMUNICATION. LAST MONTH OR
SO- THIS IS NOT EASY WORK AND I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE WORK DONE
AND I ALSO WANT TO SEE THAT IF
THERE'S ONE THING THAT THIS.
RIGHT HAS DONE AS WE ONLY.
MAGNIFYING GLASS ON THE
INEQUALITY SAID WE HAVE IN THE
STATE IS PART OF THE CHALLENGE
IS GOING TO BE TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW WE ADDRESS SOME OF THE
SENATE ALREADY GERMAN NOT. THAT
JUSTICE A STATEMENT MIGHT MY
QUESTIONS ARE GOING TO GO TO.
INDUSTRY SHOULD THROUGH OF.
YOU'VE GOT DIRECTOR THIS ONE
OFF AND I AND I HAVE QUESTIONS
IN THREE DIFFERENT AREAS ON ME.
SURE IT NOT IN RECESSIONS STATE
OUT OF OUR GOVERNMENT I. ROUND
DURING NINE WHEN ARE YOU ARE
EACH SIGNED WENT DRY WELL WHAT
IS THIS THE CURRENT ARE YOU I
YEAH WHAT ARE. OPTIONS THE
WEATHER WAS BE ABLE TO TAP INTO
FEDERAL LAW THIS TIME STE.
THANK YOU SENATOR CABALLERO
I'LL MAKE A COUPLE BRIEF POINTS
AND THEN MY COLLEAGUE CHRIS
**** ON THE LINE AND THEY HAD
SOME ADDITIONAL AS WELL. THE
FIRST IS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT IN
THE WAY SESSION CALIFORNIA
BORROWED MONEY FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AND THAT IS
STRUCTURED IN. THAT WHICH IS
ACTUALLY BACKS TIME. WITH JUST
EMPLOYER YOU XIN I WELL AS
INTEREST FROM THE GENERAL FUND
AND I WAS ACTUALLY JUST FINALLY
PAID OFF RELATIVELY RECENT IN
THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS. IN
THE SCALE OF WHAT WE'RE SEEING.
OBLONG FACE WE HAVE ALREADY
TAKEN ACTION. THANK YOUNG
GROWING FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOR WHAT WE'RE
LIKELY TO SEE IN THE NEXT
COUPLE YEARS THIS WILL BE
CERTAIN BILLIONS AND BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS THAT'S SOMETHING WE
ARE GOING TO MANAGE OVER TIME I
THINK THIS IS ONE AREA IN
PARTICULAR WHERE WORKING. FOR
MANY. LOS IN THE CALIFORNIA
TEEN THANKS WE'LL MAKE A
PAYCHECK FOR BECAUSE THAT LOW
ITSELF IS SOMETHING THAT HAS TO
BE PAID BACK OVER TIMES IN
ADDITION INTEREST AND WHEN THEY
DO HAVE TO BE MADE FROM THAT
GENERAL FUND AND- SEVERAL.
KNOWINGLY DOLLARS AND GIVEN
EVERYTHING UP. RIGHT NOW THAT'S
NOT SOMETHING THAT. THE
ADMINISTRATION BELIEVES YOU'RE
MISSION IN THAT BURNING WAS
ACTUALLY THE PROBLEMS THAT
WE'RE FACING SO WE'RE GRATEFUL
TO THE CONGRESS FOR. EXTENDING
GENERAL SAYING ANY INTEREST
THINGS WON'T BE DUE RESTORE THE
ONE TWENTY CALENDAR. VERY MUCH
HOPING THAT CONGRESS AND ITS
NEXT US FEDERAL ACTION THERE IS
A DO WHATEVER THE NEXT. WILL EX
ACT AND WHAT. SURE THAT STATE
GOING WITHIN BURDEN WEBER ALL
RIGHT TO DEAL WITH. AND MY
COLLEAGUE CHRIS SECTION ONE HAD
ANY ADDITIONAL DETAILS. WELL.
YES THANK YOU CHRIS C<c.cyan></c>
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- AS OF
EARLIER THIS MONTH THERE WAS
ABOUT TWO POINT TWO BILLION-
REMAINING IN THE U. I FIND AND
AS MY COLLEAGUE HAS NOTED THAT
DOWN THE DEPARTMENT- IMPORTANT
DEVELOPMENTS IT HAS BEEN
WORKING WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO MONITOR- THE
AVAILABLE CASH AND SO THEY HAVE
ME REQUEST YOU TO INITIALLY
BILLS BILLS FIND VALUABLE I'M-
SO. CONTINUE HE DID YEAH I'M
ADDITIONAL FUNDS FOR LONG. VERY
GOOD- THE NEXT QUESTION HAS TO
DO WITH THE- H. R. SIXTY TWO OH
ONE WHICH WAS PASSED THE
FAMILIES FIRST A CORONA VIRUS
RESPONSE ACT. THAT THE FRENCH
CASTANET. REQUIRED THAT THE
STATES ARE. MAKE SOME REFORMS
TO ARE YOU AYE BENEFIT- PACKAGE
AT THE GOVERNOR HAS HAS WAIT
HAS TAKEN A COUPLE OF THE ITEMS
IS NOT. WHAT IS THE STATUS OF
THE REFORMS THAT ARE REQUIRED
IN YOUR BELL AND WE OUT PLANS
FOR MANY. I'LL TURN THIS OVER
TO CHRIS AGAIN WHO SPECIALIZES
IN THIS AREA. RIGHT SO
GENERALLY SPEAKING THERE HAVE
BEEN SOME REFORMS THAT YOU NEED
THE R. HAS MADE SEVERAL
STREAMLINING- THEY THEY
STREAMLINED THEIR PROCESS WITH
REGARDS TO- HOW THEY'RE
APPROVING CLAIMS SO THEY'RE
IMPROVING CLAIMS MORE RAPIDLY-
I KNOW THAT THEY ARE THEY ARE
WORKING OUTSIDE TO GET ON THAT
ENDEMIC UNEMPLOYMENT ACOSTA-
PROGRAM UP AND RUNNING THE
WORKING. YOU S. SYSTEM TO DO
THAT AS WELL- IN ADDITION THERE
MAKING EFFORTS TO STREAMLINE
OTHER PROCESSES FOR EXAMPLE
THAT THE WORK SHARE PROGRAM TO
STREAMLINE THAT PROCESS TO GET
THAT UP AND RUNNING SO- AND
EMPLOYERS CAN CONTINUE TO- KEEP
THEM. THERE STAFF BUYING BUT BY
REDUCING SOME OF THEIR HOURS SO
IT HELPS THE ECONOMY BOUNCED
BACK A LITTLE BIT QUICKER SO
THEY'RE THEY'RE DOING A LOT OF
THINGS CURRENTLY AS WELL. TO
ADDRESS THE CLAIM PROCESS THEIR
THEIR READ SO. EXPAND CALL
CENTER HOURS IN SUCH. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THAT IS THAT'S
THE X. EXPEDITING THOSE CHECKS
GOING OUT IT IS PART OF WHAT I
WAS CONCERNED ABOUT WHETHER
WE'RE DOING ALL OF THAT THE
NEXT ISSUE HAS TO DO WITH. THE
RESOURCES THAT WERE THAT
SPENDING TO DEAL WITH THE
HOMELESS ISSUE- I THINK PEOPLE
UNIVERSALLY UNDERSTAND THAT-
THAT WERE. ON TOP OF CHIU
CRISIS ONE IS THE HOMELESSNESS
THAT'S THAT'S GROWN.
EXPONENTIALLY SEEMS AND THEN.
SO WHAT CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT
HOW COMMUNITIES ARE USING
HOUSING RELEASE HOMELESSNESS
ANY PARTICULAR- WHAT I'M
CONCERNED ABOUT IS THAT. THERE
THERE THERE IS ACTION OF THE
GOVERNOR'S TAKEN SOME ACTION TO
A LOT OF MONEY TO BE USED TO
HOUSE HOMELESS TELLS AND WE
HAVE CERTAIN RULES ABOUT HOW
THEY SHOULD BE UTILIZED IN
PARTICULAR THAT THAT. THAT
INDIVIDUAL TURNS INTO A
TENTATIVE TO STAY MORE THAN
THIRTY. AND ALSO- THE WHOLE
ISSUE OF TRAINS YOU KNOW. LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND I'M WONDERING
IF WE IF WE DECIDE SIGNED A
STRATEGY TO DEAL WITH ALL OF
THAT SO THAT- WE SHOULD HAVE A
TRANS. AS WE TRANSITION OUT OF
THIS CORONA VIRUS- THAT CAN
DAMAGE. DO WE HAVE A STRATEGY
FOR WHAT WE'RE GONNA DO WITH
WITH. WITH THE HOME THAT WE MAY
HAVE PLACED IN THESE. A HUGE
ISSUE BUT I'M WONDERING IF WE
HAVE A PLAN AND A STRATEGY-
SOMEONE'S WORKING. YES THANK
YOU SENATOR AND ABSOLUTELY AND
OF COURSE THE FOR THIS CRISIS
SENATE AND THE GOVERNOR. AND
MADE A SNEAKY AND REALLY THE
ONLY- ISSUE THAT YOU'RE DRESSED
RATHER STATE OF THE STATE
ADDRESS. BEFORE EVERYTHING
BEGAN AND- WE ARE CONTINUING TO
WORK ON A COORDINATED STRATEGY
I WAS ALL THERE SO I WOULD
SUGGEST NOW A YEAR. AND I GOT
HER SENIOR COUNSELOR ON HOUSING
HOMELESSNESS ISSUES WORKING ON
THESE DIRECTLY WITH COLLEAGUES
ACROSS THE ADMINISTRATION'S
FROM THE DEPARTMENT. THANK YOU
HHS AND YES ASK YOUR BUSINESS
CONSUMER SERVICES AND HOUSING.
ELEMENT COUPLE POINT. AND I
WILL ALSO THROUGH NUMBER SIX
CHRIS KIND OF- WHO'S JUST USING
WELL AS MARK A MESSAGE FROM.
HHS I THINK THE FOR. OKAY
CANNOT. THE LEGISLATURE FROM
MILLION DOLLARS YOU TO AND HOME
IN THE NINETEEN ISSUES IN THIS
AREA IN ADDITION THE POWER THAT
I'M I KNOW WE TALK ABOUT THIS
LOCAL RELATION THE EDUCATE
RELEASE AND ALSO IN IN MY FOR
EMERGENCY SOLUTION GRANT FOR
ALL HELPED STATE. ALMOST ISSUE
WERE FACING SPECIAL IN THIS
CRISIS AND WE SHOULD FOR MORE
WE KNOW NOT A- THANK THERE IS A
NEAR TERM ACTIVE TEAR OUT
MAKING THAT. TEEN. CORD ON
LONGER MOST VULNERABLE.
INCLUDING THAT ARE ARE WE CLOSE.
AND MAKING SURE AN ADWORDS WITH
THESE HEALTH CHALLENGE. BUT
WERE ALSO AT THIS AS AN OUT. TO
SURE THAT FRAMEWORK WHICH UP
YOUR THIS ISSUE. THAT WERE
PUTTING MY INTO THOSE MAKING
SURE THAT WE HAVE THAT BROADER
STRATEGY WHERE WE'RE NOT ONLY
YOUNG YOU NEEDED PRICES BUT
MAKING SURE THAT OUR LOCAL
PARTNERS. SUPPORT NEED SO I
WHAT I'LL DO IS I'LL REACH FOR.
CHRIS **** WHO TALKED ABOUT
SOME OF THE- FUNDING. WAS FROM.
SCA NINE NINETY ALLOCATION. AND
THEN I'LL TURN IT OVER TO MARK
TO TALK PRICE FROM EACH
SOMEBODY. WERE WORKING ON THREE
YES. RIGHT THANK YOU CHRIS COOK
AGAIN WITH DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE- BE. AS MY COLLEAGUE
NOTED A HUNDRED MILLION WAS-
WAS AWARDED IT TO LOCALS FOR-
RAPID DEPLOYMENT- FOR THEIR
THAT TO PAY YOU BACK OFF OF
THE- HOME ARE HOW FUNDING
FORMULA THAT WAS USED LAST
YEAR. WE'RE WE HAVE SPENT A LOT
OF THESE USES ARE FOR THE
LOCALS WERE TO BE USED AND
WE'VE BEEN HEARING BACK FROM
THEM SAYING THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO BE USING THAT FOR THE ROOM.
ARTS THEY'RE GONNA BE. TO
PURCHASE. EQUIPMENT AND
SUPPLIES TO PREVENT THE SPREAD
OF IN IN. FOR EXAMPLE SUPPLIES
PP AND SANITATION STATIONS. AND
ALSO THEY'LL BE USING IT FOR-
EXPANDING SHELTER CAPACITY TO
HELP WITH THE SOCIAL DISTANCING
EFFORTS- EIGHT. HOMELESS
CORNING FINANCING COUNCIL
WITHIN THE- BUSINESS ARE
CONSUMER SERVICES AND HOW THE
AGENCY HAS BEEN IN CONTACT WITH
THEM PROVIDING. WE NEED IT HAS
BEEN A STRONG. IN THOSE THOSE
LOCALS TO SPEND THEIR FUNDING-
ACCORDINGLY AND IN ACCORDANCE
WITH OUR TWO FOR PROJECT ROOM
KEYS SO THEY CAN MAXIMIZE THE
AMOUNT OF FEDERAL- REIMBURSED
MISTAKE IMPACT. MY TO MAXIMIZE
THE IMPACT OF THOSE DAHLE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION
THIS IS MARK FROM EACH WITH A
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AGENCY AB ONE OF THE
IMPORTANT THINGS HERE WITH OUR
PROJECT. IS REALLY TO LOOK AT
THE MOST VULNERABLE AB WHO ARE
ON THE STREETS WHO EITHER HAVE
BEEN IMPACTED BY C<c.cyan> AT</c>
NINETEEN OR HAVE BEEN EXPOSED
ARE AT HIGH. IN WHO ARE OUR
DATE OUR HAVE WORK VERY WHAT
OUR COUNTY KALI TO ACQUIRE
CLOSE IN A LITTLE OVER. NINE
THOUSAND. THIRTY SIX HUNDRED
ROOMS ARE OCT TODAY AND YOUR
EARLIER WE ARE QUIRK. YEAH I
WOULD REQUIRE COUNTY COLLEAGUES
MAKE SURE THE WE'RE STILL YOU
ALL IN THE SHORT TERM AND THE
LONG A FREE. TO ADD THE NEEDS
OF THESE AND- YOUR- THANK YOU
FOR THAT REPORTING AYE AYE I
WANTED ADD AS A FOOTNOTE FOR
MOVE OFF THIS THIS ISSUE THAT.
THAT ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT IS.
REALLY CRITICAL AND COMMUNITY
IS. THE OVERCROWDING THAT WE
SEE AND- MANY FAMILIES THAT CAN
AFFORD TO PAY THE RENT AND SO
MULTIPLE FAMILIES- LIVING.
INSTRUCTIONS THAT WERE MEANT
FOR A SINGLE FAMILY AND THAT
OVERCROWDING IS PARTICULARLY
WORRISOME DURING THIS PROGRAM
IRIS. CAN GENERATE BECAUSE
FAMILIES ARE ARE- ON TOP OF
EACH OTHER SO TO SPEAK YEAH. IN
MANY OF OUR COMMUNITIES ARE
THEIR FARMWORKER FAMILIES THEY
ARE WORKING IN THEIR CENTRAL
AND THEIR STUFF HERE. AT IN
YEAH THAT AM I GOING TO WORK
THAT DAY WILL CONTRACT DISEASE
BRING IT HOME AND IT'LL SPREAD
LIKE WILDFIRE THROUGH THE
COMMUNITY BECAUSE OF THE
OVERCROWDING. AND SO THERE IS A
PLAN BEING CONSTRUCTED. YEAH
THEY YEAH TROLL YES. THEY WILL
BE PROVIDED HOUSE. AND TO ME
THAT'S ABOUT. AND SO I WANTED
LOOK FOR OP FOR US TO BE ABLE
TO REDUCED. CROWDING IN MANY OF
OUR COMMUNITIES THAT. THAT
COULD COULD REALLY GOING TO SET
RISK BECAUSE OF THE. I'M SORRY
I'M- QUESTION FOR YOU RIGHT NOW
BUT I'M I WANT TO HAVE TO
COMMERCE ABOUT ME OVER IN IN
FOR PEOPLE THAT ARE AT BEEN AND
AS WORKERS AND ALLOW THEM TO DO
YOU TRANSITION INTO OTHER KINDS
OF HOUSING MAKE TELLS. AND
THERE JUST THAT ARE BEING
CONSTRUCTED SOME OF THE
FAIRGROUNDS TOWARDS THE-
OVERFLOW OF HOMELESS- I JUST
THINK THAT THAT THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE MAY NEED TO
LOOK AT. OKAY THERE'S- FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION. BUT I DON'T SO
I DON'T HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT
THAT RIGHT NOW WE JUST PUT THAT
OUT THERE I HAVE A COUPLE
QUESTIONS YEAH AND THEN IN THE
MEDICAL FIELD AGAIN- THIS ONE
UP AND- ONE HAS TO DO WITH THE
EXPENDITURE RESOURCES. AS AND
YOUR CREATE FACILITIES IT MAY
BE A ROUTINE THE OVERFLOW I
HAVE HEARD FROM A NUMBER OF MY
SMALL BILLS THEY ARE AT RISK
GOING BANKRUPT BECAUSE THEY HAD
TO STOP ALL NON CRITICAL
SURGERIES AND PROCEDURES
MEDICAL PROCEDURES AND OUR
HOSPITALS IN ORDER. FOR THAT
PANDEMIC. THESE PROCEDURES ARE
ARE HOW THE HOSPITAL. BASICALLY
MAKES ITS MONEY AND PROVIDE
SERVICES TO THE LOCAL COMMUNITY
AND THEY HAVEN'T SEEN AN INFLUX
SO FAR KNOCK ON WOOD IT'S A
GREAT BUT BUT THE ARE IN DIRE
STRAITS AND SO- I WE COULD TALK
A LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT THIS IS
MY- FOR THESE. THIS THIS NEW
WAR NOT DO ANYTHING THAT ON
IT'S NOT A NICE OR OR EMERGENCY
PROCEDURE AND BE PREPARED FOR A
PANDEMIC WEARING A HABIT REALLY
HAD THAT- THEY HAVE A JOB. AND
SO ON BOTH OF THEM ARE START IT
I HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH A
NUMBER BUT THERE ARE TWO THAT
ARE CRITICAL. SINCE YES
ABSOLUTELY GOT UNDER IS SAID
AWARE THIS IS AND POSTED AND
THIS WHERE- HOSPITALS ARE
BRACING FOR THE PIZZA IT'S
CALLED THE NINETEEN AND OTHER
DIFFERENT MODELS AROUND THAT
BUT ALSO HAVING TO MOVE WORK
CANCEL I'D BE SOMEBODY SELECT
PROCEDURE IS AN AWESOME RIGHT
AROUND YOU AND MAJOR TIME DAHLE
TO STAY AFLOAT AND PROVIDE THE
OTHER SERVER TAX ALL THE TIME
DAHLE SO ABSOLUTELY GET ON
AWARE OF THAT. IN THE. CURE I
SIX HUNDRED ONLY DOLLAR. I TO
HELP WITH. AND HEALTH ARE SOME
FIRST. BUT AS WITH SO MANY
THINGS THESE NUMBER SWITCHED
YOU KNOW WHAT IS SO IN A PRE
COLLEGE WHIRLS AROUND NOT. AND
SO THEY GOT. IT IS LAW TO THE
FEDERAL AND ITS TO OUR REGION
RELEASE ALSO ASKED SPECIFICALLY
FOR A- AGE OUR HOSPITALS HEALTH
EXECUTIONS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY CAN IT. AND FOR SOME
ADDITIONAL. ALTERNATE OVER. TO
THANK YOU AND SENATOR THANK YOU
FOR THAT QUESTION I DO YOU OUT
ONE TO KIND OF HIGHLIGHT ONE
ASPECT OF YOUR QUESTION THAT IS
REALLY IMPORTANT AND THAT IS
OUR RESPONSABLES ACROSS THE
STATE ALL FOUR HUNDRED AND
SIXTEEN GREAT STEPPED OUT. IN
RESPONSE TO THIS WHERE AB AND I
MAKE. IT IS SHOWN BY THE ACTUAL
THEY EARLY. ALL MEANING MAKING
SURE THAT THEY THINK LIKE
CANCEL MY SURGERIES I DON'T
BUILDING UP YOUR STERN IN FOR
US TO MAKE THAT WE THE BILL TO
TAKE OUR OUR COLOR HOW ARE SO
I'M AND SENSE OF GRAPHIC FROM
ALL OF US AT THE STATE LEVEL TO
OUR HOSPITAL PARTNERS WHO
REALLY HAVE STEPPED UP AS PART
OF OUR OUR MEMBERS IN WITH
HOSPITALS ANDCALIFORNIA. GEN
WE'RE WATCHING CLOSELY HOW AS
THESE NUMBER AS CHAIN STATE
FROM DAY. AND WE'RE ALSO INCOME.
AROUND A LOT SEARCH. I AND WAY
THE HOSPITAL'S ARE MAYBE A TO
START DOING LIKE THIS SURGERY.
YEAH WE NOT THERE YET THANK YOU
WANT TO READ. A MOMENTOUS WRITE.
OUR COST ALL ACROSS. WHO DONE
IT. AMOUNT OF WORK TO BE
FEATURE. AND BUILT THIS. AND
WE'RE I BELIEVE GREAT AND I
MIGHT CALL BAY BAY I MENTIONED
THAT. BROWN THAT AND WE ARE OUR
CRIME TO HAVE BASS ABOUT IT A
LETTER TO. OUR FEDERAL. ASKING
FOR DISH FUNDS IN SUPPORT OF
OUR HOSPITALS. ACROSS THE STATE.
GREAT TO HEAR AND AS AS DO THAT
LET TO THE FRONT GOVERNMENT
MAYBE. APPROPRIATE AS WELL. TO
ADD THAT CONCERNING CALIFORNIA
WHICH IS. THAT WE'RE BEGINNING
THE AGRICULTURAL SEASON AND WE
EXPECTED INFLUX OF THOUSANDS OF
AGE THREE WORKERS FROM OTHER
COUNTRIES. AND YOU KNOW FOR THE
MOST PART WE ASK PEOPLE TO
SHELTER IN PLACE NOT TO TRAVEL
FROM ONE. AND THEN- DESPITE
THAT BECAUSE OF OUR NEED FOR.
FRESH PRODUCE GOOD. WE'RE GONNA
BE IMPORTING THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF WORKERS AND I ARE
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM IS EXTREMELY
CONCERNED ABOUT- MAKING SURE
THAT WE HAVE THE RESOURCES. TO
ME THAT- THAT HEALTH CARE NEEDS
OF ADDED INDIVIDUALS ARE.
BECAUSE OF A FAT. FEDERALLY
APPROVED SO THAT GOING TO BE I
THINK SOME THAT YEAH OUT I CAN
TO CALL. ABOUT I HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH THE NUMBER OF
DOCTORS ARE LOCALLY ABOUT THEIR
CONCERNS THE GOVERNOR. RECENT
PRESS CONFERENCE MENTION A
KNOWLEDGE THAT FINANCIAL STRESS
THAT MANY OF THE POSITIONS ARE
FACING- BE BECAUSE THEY'RE
HAVING TO BECAUSE- EVERYTHING
IS KOBE NINETEEN AS IT SHOULD
BE AND- ONCE SPEEDY SHELTER
PLACER IS LIFTED AND WE JUST
THAT ARE LONGER TRACK BECAUSE
HE JUST. THIS IS. A FLOW ALL
ALL THAT IN MONEY INTEREST HAS
BEEN IN INDIA WITH. I'M
WONDERING IF THE MINISTER.
THOUGHT ABOUT ON WHAT OF RELIEF
MY BE NECESSARY OR OR
STRATEGIES FOR THESE THAT HAD
THEIR BUSINESS. YOU ARE RIGHT
THAT. I CAN I CAN SPEAK BRIEFLY
AND THEN MARK ARE YOU STILL
FREE TO TIME AND ALSO. CORRECT
SO I THINK- CENTER YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHT THIS IS BOTH
THAT THIS IS HEREBY THE
HEALTHCARE INDUSTRY ISSUE BUT
ALSO A BROADER SMALL. BUSINESS
YEAR IN SMALL BUSINESS AND
ECONOMIC RECOVERY IS SOMETHING
THAT HAS REALLY BEEN ON THE
GOVERNOR'S MIND AND WE'VE
ALREADY SEEN SOME ANNOUNCEMENTS
BOTH IN TERMS OF WHAT THE STATE
IS TRYING TO DO AND- ALSO WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO PUSH THE
FEDERAL. SIX THANK YOU MORE
ABOUT AND THE CASE AND AHEAD.
HERE AT THE FIRST THING THAT WE
REALLY WANT TO DO IS YOU KNOW
CAN YOU TO CALL FROM. ON ON
THOSE POSITIONS POSITION THAT
ARE FEELING UNDER ANY SPECIAL
TO THE EXTENT ANY OF THE OR
ELSE. FOR SOME SMALL TOOL IN
ROMANS SOMETHING LIKE.
SECRETARY OUR- OUR GROUP
PRACTICE FOR THAT ON NEXT SOME
THAT WE WANT TO MAKE YOU WE ALL
KNOW TAX PROGRAM THAT RUN OUT
OF MONEY I BELIEVE IN THE WAY
TWENTY HOURS SALES WE ARE
SAYING ARE CORRECT PARTNERS TO
RE AUTHORIZE. OR CREATE MORE
MONEY THAT I PART OF A KIND OF
IN WASHINGTON D. BUT DEFINITELY
AS WE WORK THROUGH THOSE ACT
NOT RECOVERY PACKAGE. CERTAINLY
NOT WILL BE ISSUE TOP OF MIND
MARCO SHOULD JUST TO ADD
ANYTHING THAT. EVERY THAT MAKES
SENSE DON'T THE ONLY THING THAT
I LEARNED ACT. THANK COMMENTED
THAT THE- OF SUPPORT THAT WE-
FROM PROVISIONS ALL OF.
HEALTHCARE WORKERS AND
TREMENDOUS AND AS THE GOVERNOR
LAUNCH JACK CALIFORNIA HEALTH
OR HOW BE THE AMOUNT. I SUPPORT
THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT CAME
TO THAT WEBSITE AND SIGN UP
RESPONSE. ALLOW ME I LOOK FOR
TO OUR UP WITH THOSE
INDIVIDUALS ACROSS THE STATE IN
RESPONSE. FOR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I REALLY. YOUR TO THE
QUESTION HERE STATE AT MATTER
MADAM CHAIR YOU I GO ON ALL DAY
IS. THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT
AND ENSURING THERE CAN BE TO
ASK AND QUESTION OF THANK YOU
ENERGY ARE I APPRECIATE THAT
MUST COME ON A APPRECIATE YOU
FOR NOT DOING SO. MOST PEOPLE
WHO WANT TO SENATOR WHITE.
SPEAKER THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
USING THE ZOOM- TOOL OF RAISING
YOUR HANDS I WANT YOU TO KNOW
I'VE SEEN YOU ALL AND WE JUST
GIVE YOU THE ORDER SO YOU CAN
ANTICIPATE. ARE THE ORDER IN
WHICH YOU'LL BE CALLED UPON
NEXT WE'RE GONNA HAVE SENATOR
WHITE HOUSE SKI. FOLLOWED BY
PAN NIELSEN SKINNER DOLLY AND
ROCK. THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR
WEISS GET WHY CAL SKI- PLEASE
LET US KNOW WHO YOU'RE
DIRECTING YOUR QUESTIONS TO SIR.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR OF MY
FIRST QUESTION WILL BE TO IT MR
POTTS CHECK BASICALLY TRYING TO
TRY TO TEACH THE SEVERITY AT
THIS SITE THE CULINARY
ASSESSMENT ON THE ECONOMIC
IMPACT ON THIS YEAR'S BUDGET
AND THEN I'LL GO TO MISTER
DESPITE OSTROM. SWAY LAST SHOT
LOW SORRY I AND TO. IN BETWEEN
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT POLICIES
THAT THEY'VE TAKEN I'M LOOKING
AT HE IS THE GOVERNOR'S
PROJECTIONS IN THE JANUARY
BUDGET I SEE THAT WE'RE AT A
HUNDRED AND FORTY. THREE
HUNDRED FORTY SIX BILLION
DOLLARS- WE'RE SITTING HERE IN
APRIL AND WE'VE NEVER SEEN
ADELINE SHOWS UNEMPLOYMENT
CLAIMS BEING BEING FILED WE'VE
GOT ANOTHER MONTH BEFORE WE SEE
THE MAY REVISE. AND I ASSUME
THAT SOME OF THAT. WE'RE GONNA
BE TAKING A GUESS WE GET THE
MAY REVISE WHAT ACTUALLY DID
REVENUES TO EAT AT THE END OF
JUNE AND AGAIN I WAS AROUND.
MADAM CHAIR AND- SEN SKINNER IN
200-011-2000 TWELVE IT WAS JUST
IT WAS A SLOW RECOVERY BUT
THERE WAS SOME WAY TO GAUGE IT
I DON'T KNOW IF WE'VE EVER SEEN
ANYTHING LIKE THIS SO MY
QUESTION IS THAT WHAT TOOLS YOU
HAVE. AND THEN IF WE JUST GO TO
ONE OF OUR- CONCERNS IS THE
PROP TO MONEY. WE MADE AND
DESCRIPTIONS OF HOW MUCH RIVER
WE'VE WE'RE GONNA HAVE WE PUT
MONEY IN IN PROP. IN THE RAINY
DAY FUND THAT WAS. WE COULDN'T
TOUCH IT. IS MANDATORY IS THAT
GOING TO BE REVISED WHEN WE
REALIZED OUR REVENUE SPORTS SO
WHY WE NEED TO PUT THAT MUCH
MONEY IN. AND OUT HOW DOES THAT
AFFECT- OUR- ABILITY TO SPEND
THAT MONEY. GOING FORWARD.
SENATOR MY COUNTY WHO WERE YOU
DIRECTING THE QUESTION TO WAS A
MISTER PETTIT. MISTER PATRICK
OF THANK YOU. OKAY THANK YOU
SENATOR WHITE HOUSE KEY I THINK
AT THIS POINT. YOU KNOW IT IS
TRUE THAT THE PROPOSITION TO
MEASURE HAD SOME TRUE UP IN
TRUE DOWN PROVISIONS. THAT
AREN'T MY COLLEAGUES FROM
PARKER FINANCE MENTIONED. AND
IT TO THE EXTENT THAT THE
CAPITAL GAINS RELATED TAX
REVENUES ARE LOWER THAN WHAT WE
HAD ANTICIPATED AND THE CURRENT
FISCAL YEAR THERE CAN BE A TRUE
DOWN. ELEMENT TO IT WHICH WOULD
MAKE SOME OF THE- FUNDS
AVAILABLE FOR SPENDING. BUT WE
DON'T KNOW YET WHAT WHAT THAT
WILL BE. OUR ABILITY TO
ESTIMATE THE REVENUES IS
SIGNIFICANTLY IMPAIRED RIGHT
NOW ALL BECAUSE OF THE- DELAY
TAX FILING DATE. AT THE SAME
TIME WE ALREADY THINK THAT
THERE IS A SIGNIFICANT DOWNWARD
REVISION THAT IS NECESSARY TO
THE REVENUES THAT THAT YOU-
REFERENCED IN THE JANUARY
BUDGET PROPOSAL. AND AS I WAS
SAYING IN THE OPENING REMARKS-
YOU KNOW IF IT WAS A TYPICAL
RECESSION YOU CAN MAYBE THINK
ABOUT A TWENTY BILLION DOLLAR
REDUCTION BUT IN A MORE SEVERE
RECESSION. THEY CAN TO THE
GREAT RECESSION THEN YOU YOU
WOULD INCREASE THAT AMOUNT TO
SOMETHING AROUND THIRTY FIVE
BILLION. AND SO FAR THE EARLY
INDICATIONS ARE THAT THE
EXPERIENCE THAT WE MIGHT BE
HAVING NOW IT COULD BE CLOSER
TO THE GREAT RECESSION
EXPERIENCE. IN SPEAKER I DO
THINK THAT THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD PREPARE FOR FAIRLY
SUBSTANTIAL DOWNWARD REVISION
BUT IT JUST WON'T BE. SOMETHING
THAT WE'RE- ABLE TO. PROVIDE A
PRECISE ESTIMATE ON PROBABLY
UNTIL JULY WHEN WE HAD THE TAX
PAYMENT DATE. MEANS SO FAR
APRIL IS TYPICALLY ONE OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT MONTHS OF THE
YEAR FOR THE STATE'S TAX
COLLECTION FOR PERSONAL INCOME
TAX. SO FAR IN THE MIND WE'VE
HAD MORE TAX REFUNDS PAID OUT
THEN WE HAVE COLLECTIONS COMING
IN SO IT TELLS YOU THAT IT'S A
RADICALLY DIFFERENT KIND OF A
YEAR. AND SO. YOU KNOW NOT ALL
OF THAT IS JUST A FUNCTION OF
TIME EITHER AND- THE
WITHHOLDING TAX IS UNAFFECTED.
WITHHOLDING FROM OUR PAYCHECKS
IS UNAFFECTED BY THE DELAY IN
THE TAX FILING DATE AND THAT'S
ALREADY. SHOWING A 10%
REDUCTION. SO I THINK YOU CAN
EXPECT TO SEE VERY SUBSTANTIAL
DOWNWARD REVISIONS TO THE
REVENUE ESTIMATES. THE BILL
LATER THIS YEAR. THE NUMBERS IN
IN MAY IT WILL HAVE PROBABLY
THE GREATER- UTILITY TO THEM
AND THEN WE WILL REFINE AND THE
SUBSEQUENT TWO MONTHS. THANK
YOU. FOR FINANCE COULD SET. I'M
SURE FINANCE I'M- VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT CONSUMER GET
YOU KNOW I THINK THAT CONSUMER
DEBT IS SKYROCKETING
SKYROCKETING I AM CONCERNED
ABOUT DEBT COLLECTING AND
FILING A BANKRUPTCY. YOU KNOW
WE HEAR ABOUT THIS TWELVE
HUNDRED BUCKS THAT'S GOING TO
BE OUR- COMING FOR EVERYBODY
WHO'S ADDITIONAL PAYMENTS FOR.
PEOPLE WHO ARE UNEMPLOYED AND
I'M WORRIED ABOUT THE YOU KNOW.
SELECT YOUR STATE IN THE MONEY
FOR THE- ACTUAL CALIFORNIANS
RECEIVED IT. THIS IS A PLAY
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
THAT IS STATE GOVERNMENT ARE
THEIR ACTIONS THAT ARE INCLUDED
IN THERE. ARE GOVERNOR'S FOR ME
PROGRAM THIS IS GOING TO YOU
KNOW PUT A- YOU KNOW. THE HOLD
ON AS YEAH I COLLECTING
CONSUMER DEBT FORECLOSURES AND
A LIGHT. SO I THINK I COULD SAY
I CAN'T SPEAK TOO MUCH TO WHAT
MAYBE TIMING HIS THAT'S STILL
UNDER DEVELOPMENT BUT SENATOR
TO YOUR POINT ABOUT WHEN PEOPLE
ARE ALREADY SIGNS OF STRESS AND
THESE TYPES OF COLLECTION
ACTIVITIES- DAY MINISTRATIONS
BEEN ACTIVE IN THIS AREA AND
FROM SEVEN WORKING WICKS BANKS
AND OTHER FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHEN IT COMES TO. SOME OF THE
PAYMENTS THAT ARE DUE THEY'RE
GETTING- THEY'RE GETTING
EXTENSIONS TO THOSE PAYMENTS
ALL RIGHT WHEN YOU'RE FACING A
PRIME COULD MUCH LOWER AND THAT
TWELVE HUNDRED DOLLAR MAX.
REFUND INTO YOU MENTION. THAT
THEY'LL BE ABLE TO HAVE X. ON.
IN ADDITION WHILE I DON'T A ALL
THE DETAILS OF THE EXCHANGE
RIGHT HERE I THE THAT. THE
FRENCH TAX. HAS ALSO TAKING
ADDITION STAFF. TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS. OF CRISIS THIS. ARE
UNDER A LOT OF STRESS YES OF
THOSE EXTRA. WHEN IT COMES THAT
BROWN PICTURE AND GOVERNOR'S BY
SHAKES. DOES THAT STATE
FINANCIAL. LOS ANY UNIT WITHIN
THE DEPARTMENT OVERSIGHT WE ARE
LOOKING YOU KNOW AT THIS
PROPOSAL ON EVERY NEW PROPOSAL
THAT WAS CREATED IN JANUARY AS
PART OF THAT WORK ON BUDGET
REDEFINITION WE WERE
DISCUSSING- BUT CERTAINLY THIS
REMAINS AN AREA. PRIORITY WITH
THE GOVERNOR AND IS YOUR TEAMS
THEY WERE THE ONES REACHED OUT
AND HELPED NEGOTIATE AN
AGREEMENT I'M THESE MAJOR
FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS AND
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO SEE
WHAT WE CAN DO. THANK YOU.
FINALLY FOR I NOTED THAT THE US
WERE SERVICES A PRESCRIBED
BURNS SOMEHOW TO PROTECT FIRE
PERSONNEL WE'VE GOT NUMBERS ARE
COMING IN ARE YOU KNOW ONE
THING ABOUT THE IN ACTIVITY
ECONOMICALLY SPEAKING IS OUR
AIR QUALITY IN LOS ANGELES
AROUND THE STATE IS FANTASTIC
THIS CAL FIRE HAVE PLANS TO
SUSPEND PRESCRIBED BURNS AT
THAT THIS IS THE TIME WE WILL
BE DOING WE'RE RAMPING UP THE-
HOLES. SO I DON'T KNOW THE
DETAILS THAT I HAVE BOTH TO
RESET COUNTER AND STEVEN BANKS
AND- ON THE LINE WHO MAY KNOW
MORE SALT FOR IT OVER TO THEM
BANKS THERE IS A CHANCE THAT
THEY ALSO MAY HAVE TO GET BACK
TO YOU BUT AS- RECENT WORK
STEPHEN YOU WANT. IN. YEAH
THAT'S- SOMETHING WE'LL HAVE TO
FOLLOW UP ON SENATOR WE DON'T
HAVE THAT. AND MARK THAT AS A
FOLLOW. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU MANAGER. I APPRECIATE
YOU FLOOR CATHY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WILL TRANSITION TO SENATOR
PENN. THANKS VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR AND- I THINK ALL THE
PRESENTERS HERE TODAY- MY FIRST
QUESTION ACTUALLY I DID NOT
FOLLOW UP ON CENTERS MOLEX
QUESTIONS AROUND THAT FEW KEY
ARE CONTRACTED AVAILABILITY
AND- YET AS A HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONAL I RECOGNIZE HOW
IMPORTANT IT WAS TO GET. IT IS
TO GET A RELIABLE SOURCE. HE TO
FOUR ALL OUR NOT ONLY HEALTH
PROFESSIONALS BUT MANY OTHER
CENTRAL WORKERS- TO PROTECT
THEM. AND BUT SHE- SO FIRST OF
ALL CAN YOU ELABORATE I MEAN I
REALIZE THAT THERE MAY BE
DETAILS YOU CAN'T SHARE YEAH-
BUT FOR EXAMPLE IS THIS A
CONTRACTOR. GOING TO BE GOING
FOR WHAT IT IS I AM ARE IS
UNIQUE. TO WE FIRST EXPECT TO
GET THEN MORSE SPECIFICALLY HOW
EXPLAINED DISTRIBUTE. THE
SUPPLIES THAT BECAUSE YOU KNOW
YOU HAVE PEOPLE WORKING NURSING
HOMES YOU HAVE YOU KNOW WE HAVE
PEOPLE IN GROCERY STORES HAVE A
LOT OF DIFFERENT PEOPLE WHO
NEED. TO EAT AND THEN RELATED
TO THAT RECOGNIZING THAT SO YOU
JUSTICE SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUE WITH
TV WE ALSO SUPPLY CHAIN ISSUES
WHAT OTHER THINGS ARE.
ESSENTIAL TO US ACTUALLY
GETTING TO THE POINT WHERE WE
CAN LISTS ARE- ARE STAY AT HOME
ORDERS AND SO FORTH THAT THE
GOVERNOR OUTLINED AND SO FOR
EXAMPLE I UNDERSTAND WE HAVE
BOTTLENECKS AND TESTING RIGHT.
AND MEDIA ARE BETTER. ARE
THERE'S EVEN A- BOTTLENECKS
MEDICATIONS NOW FOR WE'D HAVE
THIS LOOK LIKE WE HAVE THE
FASTER OTHERS DO BUT FOR
EXAMPLE IF WE DID NEED TO
ACTIVATE SOME WRITERS AND WHAT
SHORTAGES OF SEDATION
MEDICATIONS AND OTHER TYPES OF
MEDICATIONS NECESSARY FOR
PEOPLES ARE. FOR PEOPLE ARE IN
THAT REGARD TOO SO THERE ARE
THERE ARE ALSO PLANS TO PERHAPS
ALSO ENGAGE AND- OTHERS
CONTRACTING OR- INTEL
MANUFACTURING OF. THOSE TYPES
OF OUR SUPPLIES AS WELL SURE WE
HAVE A RELIABLE SUPPLY AND I
JUST FINALLY PERHAPS TALK ABOUT
MASKS. YOU KNOW WE HAVE TO
SEVERAL COUNTIES TALKING ABOUT
REQUIRING PEOPLE TO WEAR S. OUR
SEARCH ACOSTA MASKS- SO WHAT
ARE WE ARE WE GOING TO BE
ENGAGING AND TRYING TO GET. A
GREATER SUPPLY THOSE OF THE
PEOPLE ARE FINDING YOU CAN GET
CLASS MASK THEN TAKING UP.
SURGICAL MASTER OF THE THEIR
NEW BY FOR WORK AND BY
PROFESSION. I THANK YOU SENATOR
FOR THOSE QUESTIONS I THINK I
CAN TAKE PROBABLY. FOUR AND
THEN MARCO WELL A LITTLE IS AS
WELL SO FIRST IN TURNS OUT AND
WE FOUND I WAS WRITING NOTES AS
YOUR IF YOU WERE ASKING SO
POLICE- IF I IF I DID NOT
REPORT YOUR QUESTION CORRECTLY
PLEASE. AREN'T ME BUT IN TERMS
OF THAT SCHEDULED WHAT I CAN
SAY IS THAT YOU HAVE A DELIVERY
SCHEDULE IS PART OF THE
CONTRACT. PLATE. THAT. NOW THAT
HE'S GOT THAT IS HOW ONE OF THE
THAT WE IN THAT CONTRA YOU YEAH
HE WHAT WHAT WE HAVE AS AS WE
AS WE GET THERE THE SECOND IN
TERMS OF HOW THE JUST JUST LIKE
I OTHER DISASTERS WHERE HELLO
YEAH AND THE SEA CENTER IS A-
WE ARE IN TOUCH WITH OUR QUE IS
SIXTY OUR HELP BEARS OTHER IN
HIS. IN EVERY DAY. WHAT THEY
NEED. AB IS ABOUT MOM. IT'S A
BAND AND THAT IS HOW DO WHAT WE
CALL THE MANAGEMENT SO WE GET
REQUESTS IT'S METHODICAL IT
COMES INTO THE STATE OP CENTER
AT THE STORE. EASE I GUESS. WE
SHOULD ANY ANSWER AND I THAT
YOU IS WORKING REALLY ON THIS.
SO I GUESS THE OVERSIGHT
POINTED YOU ARE YOU'LL BE.
ABOUT WHERE MASK SO I UNDER THE
SUPPLIES ARE GOING SO I
UNDERSTAND THAT CERTAINLY YES
THE TO DO IT YET WITH THE
SUPPLY. I TRIED A YOUNG
DISTRIBUTE THEM APPROPRIATELY
TO THE RIGHT PLACES BUT I IS
IT. FROM AN OVERSIGHT
PERSPECTIVE CAN WE ALSO.
PUBLISH WHERE THAT WHAT
DECISIONS THEY MADE. WELL I
WILL ADDRESS THAT BY SAYING
THAT JUST LIKE IN OTHER NATURAL
DISASTERS THAT IS A PROCESS
WHERE WE'RE IN CLOSE
COMMUNICATION WITH THE COUNTIES
AND- JUDY KIDDING HOUSING SOME
OF THESE THINGS ARE SCARCE. AND
MAKING DECISIONS ON WHERE THEY
IF THERE ARE SPECIFIC- INCREASE
YOU HAVE BABIES SITUATION OR
DID YOU DO YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN
ACROSS THE STATE AND WE'D BE
HAPPY TO. HELP WITH THOSE THE
CONCERN WOULD PROVIDE. ALL OF
THAT INFORMATION- PUBLICLY IS
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE ESPECIALLY
IN THE CASE OF EAT VERY VERY
HIGH VALUE- HIGHLY DESIRED AND-
IT COULD POTENTIALLY OPEN UP
THAT YOU DON'T. ISSUES WITH
QUESTIONING DECISIONS OR-
YOU'RE FREE PROCESS IT'S
OUTSIDE OF WHAT WE HAVE
UNDERSTANDS- SO YEAH WE WANT TO
BE DELIVER AND WE WANT TO BE
WORKING FOR THIS IS. THAT WE
HAVE. CLOSELY WITH. YEAH YEAH
SOMEHOW HE THAT HAS NOT BEEN
COMMUNITY TO US AND WE THAT.
ASIAN AND IF THERE'S ANYTHING
THAT THEY YOU HAVE YOU NEED TO
TEACH YOU WITH CERTAIN BROKER
PLEASE PLEASE WORK WITH THAT
BUT IN TERMS OF JUST BROADLY
PUTTING OUT YOU KNOW IN THIS
WOULD FOR ANY YOU KNOW FIGHT.
OR ANY OTHER TYPE RESOURCE
MANAGED THERE ARE YEAH WHAT I
IT WOULD BE FOR US TO JUST HAVE
OF THAT DECISION OUT OF WITH.
THE. RAISE QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
USES AND LOTS OF YOU KNOW. OR
ARE REDIRECTING OUTSIDE THE
SYSTEM. I GUESS I GUESS WHAT
IT'S IS THAT. GIVE THAT AT
LEAST- SINCE WE'RE A CO EQUAL
BRANCH AT LEAST YEAR THAT
PRIVATELY WITH THE LEGISLATURE
SO WE KNOW BECAUSE WE HAVE TO
EXERCISE OVERSIGHT FUNCTION.
AND THAT IS SOMETHING CERTAINLY
WE GET REGULAR CALLS YOU KNOW
WITH THEM LEGISLATIVE BRANCH
WE'VE EXPANDED THAT INTO YOU
KNOW DIFFERENT MODES THE NEED
TO REACH ALSO WE CAN WORK. OKAY
AND THEN I THINK I. OKAY
MURATSUCHI A LOT ONE IN THANK
YOU FOR EVERYTHING QUESTION
OTHER IF YOU. AND NINETY OF
COURSE FOR THE HELL
PROFESSIONAL ARE CERTAINLY THAT
NEED BUT WE HAVE INCLUDED ARMOR.
THEIR TYPES OF PVP THE SURGICAL
MASK WITH OTHERS MORE THE
GENERAL USE AN INTERNAL MEET
AND IF THERE ARE REQUIREMENTS
THE STATE TO PROVIDE THOSE. AND
BE- YOU WOULD HELP WITH THE
SUPPLIES THAT THAT WE- AS WELL.
ANOTHER ADDED OTHER ENTITIES
ASIDE FROM AND WITH NOW I DID
WE I KNOW THE GOVERNOR'S OR ON
BUT IN TERMS OF STOCK TESTING
SUPPLIES AND THAT A BOTTLE AND
OTHER MEDICATIONS. I HER
DAUGHTER DR BEN THIS IS MARCO
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY IN TERMS
OF YOUR SPECIFIC QUESTIONS
AROUND TESTING WE ARE WE HAVE
FORMED A ASKING HOW DESPERATE
THAT'S A PRIVATE PUBLIC
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN. THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH AS
WELL AS ALL MARKET WHICH IS THE
PRESIDENT'S YOUR BLUE SHIELD
AND THEY ARE WORKING FEVERISHLY
AND ADD SOMETHING THAT SUPPLY
CHAIN THERE TO PARTICULAR
ISSUES THAT WE'RE WORKING ON
SEEING YOU LOSE ALL OF THEM.
THE FIRST ONE BEING SWAPPED OUT
WE ARE WORKING WITH VARIOUS
ENTITIES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO LOOK AT OTHERS
WHILE OPTIONS THAT ARE FDA
APPROVED WE ARE ALSO WORKING
WITH ACADEMIC IT FUSION. THAT
EITHER. OR YOU. OPTIONAL
REPRINTING SLOBS IN ORDER PRICE
TO BE TO MAKE THIS CHAIN ISSUE
I'M BYRON YEAH IT DOESN'T YOU
WHERE I'M WITH ARMY IS IT'S THE
IN THE TO ONE YOU TAKE THE. AND
IF YOUR COMPANIES ACTUALLY IN
CALIFORNIA TO PRODUCE OUR OWN
MYRON MEDIA AND WE'RE WORKING
ON THAT PROCESS RIGHT NOW WE'RE-
IF YOU COMPANIES TO LOOK AT
THAT IN ORDER TO ALLEVIATE.
OKAY THANK YOU- SO MY NEXT
QUESTION CAN GET IN BAXTER TO
FINANCE IN MINISTRATION- SO NOW
THE GOVERNOR LAID OUT CERTAIN
SIX ITEMS NECESSARY FOR US TO
FINALLY RESTORE YOUNG MOVE
FORWARD- YEAH RECOGNIZING THAT
ARE BUDGETARY PROBLEMS ARE
STEMMING FROM THE FACT THAT WE
DON'T HAVE THE ECONOMIC
ACTIVITY THAT WE- THAT. WE NEED
TO MOVE BACK TOWARD- NOTE
RECOGNIZING THAT'S GONNA TAKE
TIME- SO THE FIRST. ITEM THAT
THE GOVERNOR POINTED OUT WHAT
IS THE ABILITY TO MONITOR
PROTECTOR COMMITTEES TO TESTING
CONTACT MISSING ICE BLADING
SUPPORTING THOSE ARE POSITIVE
ARTS LETTERS. SO IN ORDER TO
GET THEIR- WE'RE GONNA BE TOO
GREAT STAND ARE TESTING WERE
CONTACT TRACING WELL WE MAY BE
ABLE. YOU TECHNOLOGY WE'RE
GONNA NEED A LOT MORE. WORKING
FOR HEALTH DEPARTMENTS YOU KNOW
WE'VE GOT A LOT MORE TESTING
CAPACITY WE'RE GONNA NEED
PLACES FOR PEOPLE TO GO TO
QUARANTINE. WE NEED TO THANK
YOUNG. ONCE YOU KNOW HOW SO HOW
WHEN WILL YOU STACK TO SEE
PROPOSALS FROM THE- FROM
FINANCE I MEAN THESE THINGS
WILL COST MONEY TO SO WHEN.
WHICH WILL EXPECT TO SEE
PROPOSALS FROM ADDED
MINISTRATION REGARDS TO
ACHIEVING THOSE PARTICULAR ENDS
I UNDERSTAND THERE'S A TASK
FORCE AND SO SOME OF THE
QUESTIONS MAY STILL BE WORKED
ON BUT FOR EXAMPLE. WE NEED TO
START DISSIPATING HOW MANY
PEOPLE YOU TO HIRE FOR HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS EVERY MORE MY-
HIGHER PEOPLE. GOING TO HAPPEN
RIGHT HOW WE CONTACT DO WE NEED.
WHAT KIND OF óRDENES SO WE
NEEDS I KNOW WORK OUR TO GET
PLACES FOR. A HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL TO STAY. WORKER
AND PEOPLE ARE HOMELESS AND SO
FORTH BUT THAT. WHAT REALLY
CAN'T QUARANTINE SO WHERE WE
WOULD THAT AND WHAT AND WHEN DO
WE EXPECT TO SEE PROPOSALS AND
ALSO. BUDGET RELATED TO THIS
I'D SO WE CAN ACTUALLY A KIND
MAYBE. MOVING SO A LITTLE MORE
THAN IT'S MOVING NOW. THANK YOU
SENATOR WHEN IT COMES TO THE
FUNDING OF THESE PROPOSALS WE
ARE DEFINITELY WORKING ON THAT
INCLUDING IN THE NEXT SEVERAL
WEEKS LEADING UP TO. NAY
REVISION AND AS YOU NOTED THE
GOVERNOR HAS IDENTIFIED THIS AS
A TOP PRIORITY AND KEY. TO ALL
THE OTHER ASPECTS SINCE ALL
WITH THE SIX PROCESS THINKING
ABOUT WHEN AND HOW WE CAN
REOPEN THE ECONOMY ONE OF THE
REASONS THAT THE GOVERNOR
ISSUES THAT EXECUTIVE ORDER- BE
ABLE BETWEEN NOW AND THE END OF
THE FISCAL YEAR. DRAW ON ANY
LEGALLY AVAILABLE SIGNS UNDER
THE EMERGENCY SERVICES ACCESS
IS TO RECOGNIZE THAT THE STATE
THAT WE CAN WRAP THIS THING UP
AND WE KNOW IT'S AN AREA WHERE
THE UNREST AND- HE'S- IF YOU DO
THAT AS SOON AS- BUT WE ALSO
THAT. CONTINUING TO THE YEAR SO
THAT'S OF MIND FOR US DON'T
HAVE FUNDING RIGHT NOW BUT I
SEE THAT NOT BECAUSE WERE NOT
WORKING ON IT BECAUSE
EVERYTHING IS GOING DIRECTLY
THROUGH OUR CLOTHING NINETEEN
EMERGENCY RESPONSE FOR
DIFFERENT BUCKETS SACKS MY WE
WERE DISCUSSING BEFORE AND I
SHOULD ACTUALLY TURNED OVER TO
MARKON THE CASE PLAY ON THE
LINE WORKING WITH SECRETARY MY
ONLY. JUST THINKING ABOUT HOW
WE'RE RARE ARTS THESE ALTERNATE
OVER TO MARK UP. THANK YOU HAVE
RAISED A NUMBER A REALLY
IMPORTANT QUESTIONS THE
FRAMEWORK AT THE GOVERNOR LATE
HOURS EARLIER THIS WEEK- IS
INTENDED TO BE A FRAMEWORK TO
HELP US. I'LL LOOK AT HOW WE
MODIFY AND OVER THERE YEAH YOU
GUYS ARE THE NON PHARMACEUTICAL
INTERVENTIONS THAT WE PUT IN
PLACE. I IN ORDER TO MITIGATE
THE SPREAD OF THE VIRUS ACROSS
THE STATE WE ARE NOW ACTIVELY
WORKING IN CREATING QUIRK. FOR
EACH ONE OF THESE INDICATORS ON
THE GOVERNOR AND- THE PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA AND YOU AND- FRENCH
RECOVER. TO PROVIDE REGULAR
UPDATES ON OUR PROGRESS WITH
REGARDS TO THE DEVELOPMENT OF
THE SIX. SO WE LOOK FORWARD TO
ENGAGING WITH YOU THE REST OF
THE PUBLIC AND ESPECIALLY OUR
PARTNERS. COUNTY LEVEL AS WELL
AS OUR HEALTH SYSTEM PARTNERS
AROUND EACH ONE OF THESE. WITH
REGARDS TO CASTING WE WILL
BACKGROUND APPROACH OUR TEST
WE'VE BEEN- AS THE GOVERNOR HAS
ALLUDED IN. PRIOR STATEMENTS
OUT WE HAVE WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING VERY HARD TO TRY TO.
INCREASE OUR TESTING CAPACITY
ACROSS STATE AND- AS PART OF
OUR STRATEGY HAVE BEEN MORE
WRONG ONE IS NOT YES YEAH. BUT
ALL OF OUR EGGS IN ONE BASKET
IN TERMS OF IT PASSED BUT LOOK
AT WHAT THEY'RE- TESTING. AND
SO. WE ARE. WITH OUR AFTER
INSTITUTIONS I IN ORDER TO
BUILD A- GROUP. NG SO THAT IS
ONE AREA IN WHICH WE CAN ACCU
DIGITAL ASK. WE ARE WORKING
WHERE I'M SECTOR COMPANIES YEAH
WEBER THREE. WHEN ASKED SO WE
READ AS YOUR OF MACHINES WHERE
THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO ASK
ADAM PROGRAMS IT'S NOT I GREW
BUT INDIVIDUALS OUT SO WHEN HE
I ORDER TO A RAP RESPONSE WITH
REGARDS TO CAST I AND THEN I
THINK FINALLY WE'RE REAL
LOOKING COMMUNITY CASTING
SERVING. ASKING TOGETHER SENSE
OF WHY EYED AS AND UNITY WITH
THE COMMUNITY LIKE A HOW SPREAD
OF THE VIRUS I CAN SO WE SOME
YOU KNOW PARTNERSHIPS WITH EASE
THE CRIME STATE REALLY YOU SOME
OF THE- MICHAEL I OR RIGHT
TESTING AFTER A LACK OF A
BETTER. IN ORDER US TO BE ABLE
TO INCREASE OUR ASKING YOUR
ASKING WE VIRTUALLY. ENSURE
THAT WE- THE ART OF SELLING A
SUPPLY WE HERE AND SO WE'RE
LOOKING AT WAYS WHICH WE CAN
MAKE IT I SSUE I JOIN THINGS
LIKE READING RENDON'S BOB BY
MAKING OUR OWN VIRAL. I'M ALL
OF THOSE THINGS ARE HALF
SIMULTANEOUS HERE WITH OUR
EFFORTS. ASK DO YOU SPEAK TO.
APPRECIATE THE WAY ON TEST USED
TO. THE CAR TRACING OF IT
BECAUSE WE NEED TO THESE THINGS
PARALLEL RIGHT WE DO AND- TAKE
AS LONG TO GET THERE. YOUR
ABSOLUTE RIGHT AND FOR MANY OUR
COLLEAGUE WHO DON'T KNOW WHERE
CONTACT. IS IT'S AN
EPIDEMIOLOGY I TERM IS YOU. IN
THINGS LIKE WORK IN MOST. CAN
BE USED IN THE- AS WELL AND
MANY ARE MANY INTERNET.
ACADEMIC AND HERE IS WHO ARE
THERE FROM. YEAH I KNOW JUST
ARE. OUT HOW YOU SOME THOSE AND
THAT WILL TO THE NOTION OF. I'M
NOT TRYING TO TRAYS AND YET
YOU'RE REAL IS LOOK AT HIM AND-
WHO MIGHT BE CORRECT POSITIVE
AND THAT YOU THAT CONTACT YOUR
SHE MIGHT HAVE. AND THEN
LOOKING AT WAYS WHICH YOU.
THOSE AND- TO MITIGATE SPREAD
OF THE VIRUS IT REALLY IS THE
TRIGGER. STRATEGY WE- EARLY ON
IN THIS. AND IN ORDER US TO LET
THOSE AND. YEAH I ARE MODIFYING
THOSE GUYS THE GOVERNOR LIVED
IN WE REALLY HAVE TO CREATE A
WE- AT WE ARE PRACTICALLY
LOOKING. FOR PIECE IT GOING TO
REQUIRE WORK WORDS ALSO. IRIS
TO BE CREATIVE AND OF HOW LEFT
TECHNOLOGY USED OF THOSE PIECES
AND SO THAT WAS WORK THAT WE
PEOPLE US AND THAT'S THE THAT
THE GUY. HAS CHARGES WE LOOK
FORWARD TO BRINGING SO MANY TO
OLD AND A GEN PUBLIC IN THE
COMING DAYS WEEKS AROUND AFTER.
I HAD READ SHEET THAT I THINK
YOU KNOW WE- THIS MAY TAKE LONG
THAN YOU THINK THEIR STAFFING
ISSUES BUT IF WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT LEVERAGING TECHNOLOGY
JUST TRYING TO BE SOME. ISSUES
ABOUT PRIVACY AND CIVIL RIGHTS
PEOPLE MAY BRING OUT DEPENDING
ON WHAT HOW DO WE PLAN TO USE
TECHNOLOGY AND THAT'S GOING TO
TAKE SOME TIME TO WORK OUT TOO
SO. I HOPE WE YEAH GET AHEAD OF
THAT AND- NOT WAIT TOO LONG TO
START ENGAGING IN DISCUSSIONS.
THE OTHER THING I ALSO WANT TO
TOUCH ON A YEAH AND TALK ABOUT
HOW WE GET BACK TO. THE LISTING
SOME OF THE ISSUES AND I WANT
TO BUILD ON WHAT. US CAMBIADO
BROUGHT OUT. IS THAT WHAT YOU.
RIGHT NOW- IS AN APPRECIATE
YOUR PRAISE FOR THE HOSPITALS
AND THE DOCTORS IN THE FRONT
LINE AND THEY'LL SAY THANK YOU
FOR THE PRAISE BUT WE COULD USE
MORE HELP- SO GRACE IS GREAT
BUT HELP IS BETTER- AND SO THE
CHALLENGE IS JUST THAT YOU'LL
DAIS. BUT YOUNGER LOSING MONEY
RIGHT- WE HAVE A CLINIC DOWN
SANTA BARBARA THAT'S THE THAT'S
THE MAIN PROVIDER THAT. STANDS
IN CLINIC THAT MAY BE GOING
BELLY UP OR AT LEAST- THEY'RE
LAYING OFF A LOT OF STAFF.
RIGHT ARE YOUR- DOCTORS
PRACTICE OF THE PRACTICE ITSELF
DOESN'T CLOSE THE NAY LAY OFF
THEIR STAFF. RIGHT AND- WE ARE
HERE FROM PRIMARY CARE DOCTORS
AND DATE BASICALLY- YOU KNOW
THEY'RE DROPPING THEIR VISITS
YOU'RE TRYING TO. TELL US ALL
SAFETY SHE USED TO WORK YEAH
GET PEOPLE REVERSE. ALL BUT-
BASICALLY IF THEY'RE NOT
AROUND- IT BECAUSE THE LAID OFF
THEIR NURSING STAFF THEY CLOSED
UP. BUT. AT WORK. WHAT PLAN
BILL ACTUALLY TAKE CARE. THE
ISSUES THAT GOT CUT OFF THESE.
ALWAYS TALK ABOUT LIKE DID
PROCEDURE. THOSE ARE NOT OP ALL
THE HAPPEN TO BE THING THAT NOT
NECESSARILY SPURGEON SO CALLED
IT BUT WE HAVE KOBE AND THESE
ON TOP OF EACH OTHER. AND SO-
WHAT ARE. AND YOU KNOW I'LL
FRANKLY JUST PUT IT OUT THERE-
BECAUSE I AM A SMALL BUSINESS
OWNER. THE FEDERAL MONEY FOR
THE SMALL BUSINESSES I'M STILL
WAITING FOR SOMEONE TO TELL ME
THAT SHE GOT A SINGLE CENT FROM
THE DISASTER. I HAVE NOT HEARD
ANYONE TO MY DISTRICT MAYBE
THEY HAVEN'T TOLD ME YET BUT
EVERYONE I'VE ASKED KNOWN
SENIOR CENTER- SO WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. A LOT OF PEOPLE AND
WORLD RIGHT NOW. AND CAPACITY.
IF WE- FIND A WAY. TO FIGURE
HOW TO USE THAT SO WHAT ARE YOU
GONNA DO TO BE SURE WE MADE
THAT CAPACITY OUR MEDIC ROLAND
I'M WE'LL GO UP WITH THAT
PEOPLE BEING OFF ON AND SO
FORTH AND ANY IN. SO WHERE WE
GOING TO BE SURE THIS NEXT IS
THERE TO CARE. THANK YOU CENTER.
THANK AYE YOU. NO I AM SAYING
YOU BECAUSE I THINK YOU'RE
MAKING A LOT OF THE POINT YOU
KNOW THAT ON TOP OF MY FOR THE
GOVERNOR FIRST OF ALL I KNOW A
SMALLER POINT THAT YOU MADE BY
EX ON THE STAGE. ACTION ACT THE
MINISTRY THE HONORS BEEN VERY
CLEAR YOU TO BE SEX AND NOT
ONLY NEEDS MORE MONEY BUT THE
HELP IS NOT REALLY GETTING TO
THE PEOPLE WHO NEED IT WE'RE
WORRIED I NAY FRIENDS ON THE
WEST COAST YOU KNOW WHY MONEY
RUNS OUT OR THEY REALLY HAD
TIME TO GET THROUGH SOMEBODY'S
NETWORKS. ON THE LANDING BOB
COSTAS LENDERS CRUZ YEAH AND
RELATIVELY SLOW DOWN WICKS. SO
THE GOVERNOR'S MAKE. EXCELLENT
JUST SMALLER. ANY ON THE
BROADER. AS KNOW THE LATE.
PRIOR TO THE MOSTLY. YEARS I.
THAT CALM APPROVED A SIX POINT
TWO PERCENTAGE POINT INCREASE
IN THE AFTERMATH OF THAT
FEDERAL MEDICAID. THE MEDICAL
ASSISTANCE PERCENTAGE AND WHILE
THAT'S GOOD AND THAT WILL
PROVIDING THE BILLINGS DOLLARS.
AGE FOR THE STAGE IT'S STILL
NOT ENOUGH AND YOU ARE RIGHT.
POINTING OUT THE IRONY THAT. IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE DAY GRAY
DAVIS HEALTH CRISIS THAT THE
COUNTRY HAS SEEN IN RECENT
MEMORY. OUR HEALTH INSTITUTIONS
ARE ACTUALLY UNDER SO MUCH
PRESSURE SO THE GOVERNOR HAS
ALSO CALLED FOR. DOUBLING THAT
SIX POINT TWO PERCENTAGE POINT
INCREASE MAKING AT LEAST 12% IF
NOT MORE. AND MORE THAN THAT
WERE VERY CONCERNED THAT THAT'S
NOT INCREASED IS ONLY FOR THE
DURATION. OF THE- NC ASK
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT FINDS IT SO.
YOU KNOW THIS EMERGENCY COULD
LAST FOR A COUPLE MORE MINDS
BUT THE ASSOCIATED IMPACTS.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING ABOUT. AND I
LOOKING ACCESS IS SO SEATED
HEALTH AND- IN TERMS OF
POPULATION HEALTH BUT ALSO
HEALTH AND FINANCIAL. YOU
SHOULD CAN ON FOR SOME YEARS SO
THAT. USE ONE TOLL WITHIN A
COUPLE MIND STANDING LOSING
THAT REIMBURSEMENT ADJUSTMENT.
THAT WE NEEDED MOST SO WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO QUESTION
VERY STRONG ON THAT NOT ONLY
SUMS LEVEL EXTENDING THE
DURATION AND THEN THE LAST
THING I'LL SAY IN THEIR CAREER
ON. HELLO THERE'S ALSO. IN THE
LAST YEAR'S ACTOR WAS A PUSH
FOR ADDITIONAL. BENEFITS
SOMETHING UP B. R. LEVEL BY
SIXTEEN PERCENT. AND IT DIDN'T
MAKE IT BRUCE SO WE'RE WORKING
REALLY HARD WITH OUR
CONGRESSIONAL DELEGATION TO
INCLUDE THAT IN THE NEXT
BUILDING CASE AT A TIME WHEN
MORE PEOPLE ARE GOING ON CAL
WORKS. I'M SORRY JOHN FRESH IN
ADDITION TAX MEDI CAL AND CAL
WORKS YOU AND IF THEY'RE NOT
GETTING THE RESOURCES THEY
NEED- AND- HEALTHY NUTRITIOUS
FOODS THAT'S GOING TO PUT
ADDITIONAL PRESSURE ON OUR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM AND SOCIAL
SAFETY NET AS- WELL SO. THIS IS
ALL TOP OF MIND FOR US AND
WE'RE LOOKING TO SEE WHAT MORE
WE- OKAY. AND JUST ONE MORE
QUESTION. TOLD OF THE CHECK BUT
SINCE. HEALTH AND HUMAN. ON
HUMAN SIR. SITES YOU KNOW THE
EXTENSION OF THE HOLD HARMLESS
PROGRAM WAIVERS SO WHERE PEOPLE
THEY HAVE TO RENEW THEIR-
SERVICES THAT ARE STAYING AT
HOME WHERE. YOU KNOW PEOPLE
WERE TELLING WORKERS TO TRY TO
STAY AT HOME IT CETERA- WE'D BE
SURE THAT. PEOPLE DON'T FALL
OFF BENEFITS THE DAIRY HAVE.
WELL WE'RE GETTING THROUGH THIS.
YES ON THIS QUESTION I'M GONNA
TURN IT OVER TO ADAM DORSEY
ATHLETES ARE HHS UNIT HERE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE NEITHER
HAMMER WE'VE GOT SOME OTHER
PEOPLE ON THE LINE WHO ARE AT
FOCUSED ON THE SOCIAL SERVICES
SIDE IN TERMS OF ELIGIBILITY
I'M SO THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO
SPEAK TO THAT. OKAY THANK YOU.
AND I'M REALLY SORRY THAT THEY
THEY SPECIFIC QUESTION WAS ON
THE WHICH PIECE OF THE
ELIGIBILITY. WELL BASICALLY THE
EXTENSION OF HOME HARM LISTS
THAT PROGRAM WAIVERS AND BEING
SURE THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE
GETTING THE SERVICES NOW THAT
HANDLES THOSE TO BE STAYING AT
HOME RIGHT. FAMILIES WHAT ABOUT
THE WORK THE- THE WORKERS AT
THE COUNTY AND SO FORTH- SO HOW
WE BE SURE PEOPLE DON'T FALL
OFF THEIR SERVICES BECAUSE
THEY'RE NOT. YOU KNOW BEING
ABLE TO CHECK IN- TO THIS IN
ADDITION THE FACT THAT MORE
PEOPLE ARE ROLLING. OUT LEVEL
THE PEOPLE CURRENTLY ON THE
SCHOOLS PEOPLE ENROLLING BE
SURE THEY DON'T FALL OFF-
DURING THAT WHILE WE'RE ALL
HOLDING UP AT ALL. YEAH SO I'LL
GO AHEAD AND START AND IF
THERE'S ANYTHING. THAT MARCO
FROM HHS AGENCY MUST ADD PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO JUMP IN. BUT THAT
WAS REALLY THE IDEA BEHIND THE
AUGMENTATION PARTICULARLY
AROUND THE COUNTY
ADMINISTRATION FUNDING- IS THAT
WE REALLY NEEDED TO MAKE SURE
THAT EVEN WHEN SOME COUNTY
OFFICES WERE BEING SHUT DOWN
THAT WE HAVE THE ABILITY. TO
CONTINUE TO PROCESS
APPLICATIONS AND GET PEOPLE
ENROLLED IN THE PROGRAM AND A
LOT OF THE FLEXIBILITY STAND
THAT WE SOUGHT. I'M WITH THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT ACROSS A
NUMBER OF OUR PROGRAMS ARE
DESIGNED TO GET PEOPLE INVOLVED
GETTING PEOPLE TO ACCESS
TELEPHONIC SERVICES- AND SO WE
REALLY DONE. YOU KNOW IT A
NUMBER OF THINGS THAT YOU KNOW
CROSS SOMEBODY'S AUGMENTATIONS
IN ACROSS SOME OF THE FEDERAL
WAIVERS THAT WERE SEEKING
CURRENTLY- TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE CAN GET ENROLLED STATE
ROLE NOT PROGRAMS. ARE
PARTICULARLY OVER THE NEXT
THREE MONTHS AS WE CONTINUE TO
KIND OF ASSESS THE SITUATION
BUT- I DON'T KNOW MARK UP
THERE'S ANYTHING ELSE YOU'D
LIKE TO ADD TO THAT. I I'LL
GIVE. YOU YOU SPECIFIC EXAMPLE
ON THE CAL WORKS NEAR WHERE.
VERY CLOSELY REFERENCE. OUR TO
GIVE THEM A MUCH LESS. AS
POSSIBLE SO. SPECIFIC EXAMPLES
YOU WHY IS WE HAVE THE TO FACE
REQUIRE. AND WE'VE ALSO THE WAY
SIGNATURE REQUIRED AND SO THE
IDEA HERE IS REALLY SURE THAT
WE ARE I HAVE YEAH. BALLPARK
ARE. STRANGE PROGRAM ARE BEHALF
BUT ALSO I AM SORT. WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES THE ABILITY TO
REALLY NAVIGATE THAT
ACCENTUATION WE ARE ALSO HAVING
TO BE MINE ALTHOUGH HOW WE
ENGAGE OR EVEN ON THE JOB. SITE
WHILE MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE
PROTECTING THE SOCIAL BURKE
WORKERS MIGHT. BE ENGAGING WITH.
BUT THERE WERE ALSO PROTECT
BECAME AND ARE IN THE WELL
SYSTEMS WE'RE HAPPY ABOUT THOSE
TWO THINGS. YEAH IN TERMS OF
GETTING. ON HOW WE THE WE
CONTINUE TO WORK OUR COUNTY
PARTNERS EIGHT. AND TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT. THE BULLET WE
MIGHT. RIGHT WELL YOU SIR I
MUCH MANAGER APPRECIATE THE AND-
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR PAN WITHIN TO MOVE ON TO
SENATOR NAILS ALL. LIKE THIS
ONE TO A NON THE FACT WE'VE HIS
OUR MAR WE'VE GOT CURRENTLY
ABOUT TWENTY FIVE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC ON QUEUE FOR THE
CALLS. AND I JUST ASK THAT YOU
BE MINDFUL IF YOU COULD LIMIT
YOUR QUESTIONS THIS IS YOUR
ONLY OPPORTUNITY TO POSE
QUESTIONS TO THE LTO OR FINANCE
WE JUST WANNA MAKE SURE WE ARE
MINDFUL OF THE AMOUNT OF TIME
THE PEOPLE WHO WORK IN THE
HEARING ROOM. HERE AND PUBLICLY
EXPOSE WITH THAT SENATOR
NIELSEN. THANK YOU CHAIR FOR
MISTER VISION NOT THAN. SENATE
MORE LIKE BEGAN THIS WITH. IN
QUERY AND OBSERVATIONS ABOUT
THE MASK CONTRACT. I MUST
EMPHASIZE THAT'S A BIG DEAL.
AND MANY OF US VERY VERY
INSISTENT AT SEEING THE TERMS
OF THAT CONTRACT. I MUST
CONFESS I AM NOT MUCH
CONFIDENCE IN THE BEING
DELIVERED. DASH SUGGEST FOR A
WHOLE LOT OF REASONS. AND WHAT
IS IN THE CONTRACT THE INSURERS
DELIVERABILITY TIMELY. IT'S
GOING TO BE REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT. AT THE LEAST WE
CANNOT BE JUST THROWING OUT A
FALSE HOPE TO PEOPLE. BUT
THERE'S A LOT OF MONEY INVOLVED
IN THIS TO. SO PLEASE DO
UNDERSTAND THERE THERE IS NOT
AN EXPECTATION BUT A DEMAND.
THE THAT THAT CONTRACT BECOME
AVAILABLE. OF MISTER BUSH
NOTHING THE ONE OF THE
GOVERNOR'S. THE NOW SINCE IN
DEALING WITH HOMELESSNESS THAT
WAS ATTRACTIVE TO ME WAS THE
DESIRE. AN INTEREST IN TRACKING
THE PROGRAMS THAT FOR THE
HOMELESS AND THAT WE HAVE IN
PLACE. BUT THERE'S NOT BEEN
MUCH SPECIFICITY OF WHAT THAT
LOOKS LIKE HOW WE ARE GOING TO
DO THAT FOR EXAMPLE THE DID
SOME DISCUSSION HERE JUST A BIT
AGO ABOUT TO PUTTING THEM INTO
THE FACILITIES OF OUR FAIRS
THAT I HAVE SOME ISSUES WITH
THAT BECAUSE IT'S NOT QUITE AS
EASY AS SOME WOULD THINK JUST
FILL UP THOSE. PURPOSES PLEASE
BUT HOW DO WE DIDN'T TUITION
FROM THE HOTELS AND MOTELS THE
FAIRS THESE VARIOUS FACILITIES.
TO THE NEXT LEVEL. AS WE
PROCEED I THINK THAT'S MORE
JUST AN OBSERVATION. I WOULD
LIKE TO ASK YOU TO BE A LITTLE
BIT MORE SPECIFIC MAYBE YOU
CAN'T THE GOVERNOR THE OTHER
DAY DID TALK A LITTLE ABOUT THE
COLLUDED ABOUT THE COST THE
CRITERIA. OF FOR WHAT'S BEEN
CALLED OPENING UP IN OTHER
WORDS DOING WHAT CAN BE
REQUIRED. TO HELP THE ECONOMY.
PROTECTING OUR SMALL
COMMUNITIES OR ARE STRICTLY OUR
SMALL BUSINESSES. HE HAD
OUTLINED CERTAIN PARAMETERS OR
BENCHMARK THINGS IS WE'RE GONNA
BE ABLE TO BE MORE SPECIFIC
ABOUT THAT AND HOW WE ARE GOING
TO DIRECT IN STAGE OR PHASE
THESE OPENING UP ATTEMPTS IN
CALIFORNIA. THAT'S GOING TO BE
IMPORTANT HAVE YOU HAD MUCH
DISCUSSION IN THOSE HIGHER
COUNCILS ABOUT THIS OPENING UP
CONCEPT. YES YES SENATOR AND IT
IS CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT
WILL BE BASED ON OF ALL THINGS
CONDITIONS ON THE GROUND BUT
ALTERNATE OVER TO MARK ON MAGIC
SHE WAS BEEN INTIMATELY
INVOLVED IN THOSE CONVERSATIONS
IS TAX. NIELSEN THANK YOU FOR
THAT QUESTION THEN I THINK IT'S
A REALLY IMPORTANT ONE AS THE
GOVERNOR ALLUDED TO. EARLIER
THIS WEEK WHEN YOU ROLLED OUT
THAT THE STATE'S INDICATORS FOR
HOW WE MODIFYING. THE
INTERVENTIONS THAT WE PUT IN
PLACE HE MADE IT VERY CLEAR
THAT YOU WANTED TO. CONGRESS
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA AROUND
HOW WE GET TO THAT POINT ABOUT
JUST. AND PROPPING SOMETHING
THAT WAS SO BEING OVER THE NEXT
COUPLE OF DAYS- IS AND WEEKS AS
PRICE TO REALLY BE. ALL ABOUT
HOW WE ENGAGE THE PUBLIC THAT
ARE I AND OUR COLLEAGUES AT THE
COUNTY LEVEL AROUND EACH ONE OF
THESE INDICATORS AND GOVERNOR
WHILE YOU'RE TRYING. WE ON THE
STANDING. ARE PROVIDE THE
GENERAL PUBLIC BUT WE ALSO DO
YOU. OUT WITH THE LEAD YOU. OR
HOW WE'RE MAKING A SEPARATE
INDICATE. LOOK QUITE QUESTIONS
WE TO ANSWER. IN THE- AND WHAT
THEY WILL. OUR DECISION MAY.
REALLY TERM WHETHER OR NOT THE
GOVERNOR LISTS THOSE.
INTERVENTION OR MODIFY SAYS
INTERVENTIONS AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. THERE WILL BE A LOT
MORE WORK I MEAN. IN THE-
COMING DAYS AND WEEKS WITH
REGARDS TO THE FRAMEWORK THAT
WE ARE NOT EARLIER THIS. YEAR
THANK YOU THAT THE LASTLY. FOR
MISTER MISSION NOT. I THE BY
PROCESS. NO THE LEGISLATIVE AND
BUDGET PROCESSOR GREATLY
COMPACTED THIS YEAR. MORE SO
THAN IN MY EXPERIENCE. HOW DO
YOU SEE THIS EVOLVING AND
DEVELOPING NOW AS WE PROCEED
WE'RE NOT GONNA HAVE THE TIMES
THAT WE'VE ENJOYED IN THE PAST
FOR IN DEPTH THAT SUBCOMMITTEE
HEARINGS. HOW WILL THIS BUDGET
PROCESS NOW COME TOGETHER AS
YOU'RE ENVISIONING IT. TO CALL
REACH CLOSURE ON OUR BUDGET.
TWO AS LA- MENTIONED SO MUCH
ABOUT EVERYTHING- INCLUDING THE
FIRST YEAR IN ECONOMIC
DECISIONS THAT WE MAKE WILL BE
BASED ON THE COURSE OF THE
VIRUS ITSELF WHICH WE CAN ONLY
CRITICS BUT WE CAN'T KNOW FOR
SURE RIGHT NOW THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PLAN IS TO
STAY WITHTHE MAY FOURTEENTH.
CONSTITUTIONAL DEADLINE FOR THE
NAY REVISIONS AND WORK WITH THE
LEGISLATURE THROUGH MAY AND
JUNE AND CERTAINLY WHILE
THERE'S SO MUCH THAT WE DON'T
KNOW OUR INTERNAL REVENUE AND
FORECASTING TEAM IT'S GOING TO
DO THE VERY BEST AND TO CREATE
JACKS THE TYPES OF THE REVENUES
IN THE TYPES OF ECONOMIC IMPACT
THAT WE'RE GOING TO SEE IN THE
UPCOMING. YOU ARE BASS.
PRESENTED AND THE LATEST IS ON
PASS ACT OF BALANCE I MY KIDS
SO WE'RE GONNA WITH PROCESS
THAT BEING SAID IT IS AS IF AS
IT TURNS OUT THE VIRUS INVOLVES
MOTHER IN A POSITIVE OR
NEGATIVE WAY DIFFERENTLY FROM
THE WAY WE EXPECT IN MAY AND IN
JUNE THEN WE CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND I SPEND A PRACTICE
AND- YEARS WHERE WE HAVE TO
DEAL WITH. OR ECONOMIC CRISIS
THAT WE MIGHT. THE BUDGET
SUBSEQUENT ACTION IN THE MIDDLE
OF NEXT FISCAL YEAR RIGHT NOW
WE'RE PLANNING TO COME TO YOU
THE LAST. INSTEAD NAY A REVISED
BUDGET BY MADE FOURTEEN. AND
HOPE TO WORK WITH YOU TO THE
PROCESS TO MEET THE
CONSTITUTIONAL THAT. THANK YOU
AND LASTLY FOR A- LEAD JANICE
PANIC. THE THIS ONE OF OUR-
AREAS OF OUR BUDGET
EXPENDITURES IT. IT'S BEEN
USUALLY PROBLEMATIC FOR DECADES
LETTER. ARE THE APPLICATION. OF
TECHNOLOGY THE EXPANSION
TECHNOLOGY THE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS THAT WE HAVE SPENT ON
PROJECTS THAT DID NOT WORK
CRASHED AND BURNED WERE LONG
OVERDUE. DO YOU SEE ANY ROOM
HERE IN THIS PARTICULAR TIME
WHERE WE CAN FOCUS ON GETTING
SOME OF THOSE THINGS UNDER
CONTROL. BEYOND JUST RE NAMING
A NEW AGENCIES. AS WE HAVE DONE
WITH DO IT DON'T DON'T AT ME
HITS IS NOTHING BUT CHANGES
NAMES- BUT THEN I SEE THIS IS A
IS AN OUT OF CONTROL AREA DO
YOU SEE THAT AS SOMETHING THAT
WE COULD. DEVOTE SOME ATTENTION
TO. YES SENATOR NIELSEN THANK
YOU- YES OUR OFFICE HAS BEEN
DOING SOME ANALYSIS. OF THESE
PROJECTS WITHIN THE- THROUGHOUT
THE STATE GOVERNMENT. INK MIKE
FOLEY CAROLYN CHIU MIGHT BE IN
A GOOD POSITION TO OFFER SOME
ADDITIONAL THOUGHTS WORK FOR
YOU ON THAT. THANK YOU. TURNER
NIELSEN THIS IS CAROLINE SURE
CAN YOU HEAR ME I CAN'T THANK
YOU. OKAY SO AS I A- MISTER
PECK MENTIONED AS A COMPONENT
OF OUR LOW BASELINE SCENARIO
ONE OF THE AVENUES THAT WE ARE
EXAMINING OUR- THE I. T.
PROJECTS FOR WHICH THE STATE
COULD POTENTIALLY EITHER PUT ON
PAUSE FOR. BACK SOME OF THE
FUNDING WE ARE LOOKING AT THE
POTENTIAL ARE TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND THE POTENTIAL
CONSEQUENCES OF SOME OF THOSE
ACTIONS AND THE CHOICES THAT
WOULD BE INVOLVED. IN THAT
THAT'S A VERY NEAR TERM ISSUE
OBVIOUSLY TRYING TO TRYING TO
IDENTIFIED YEAH ECCENTRIC JUST
IT COULD REDUCE COSTS IN THOSE
AREAS AS WEAKNESS BUT BUDGET
PROBLEM AND IN THE NEXT COUPLE
OF YEARS. THE DOOR UP AND MAKE
A THOUGH I THINK IS A LONGER
TERM ONE IN TERMS OF HOW THE
SPEAKER ARE AFFECTED WE DEPLOY
ITS RESOURCES FOR IT SOLUTIONS
AND THAT IS SOMETHING. AS YOU
KNOW WE ARE WE HAVE WORKED ON
AND OFF ON. ISN'T SOME CHANGES
PROCESS THE STATE UNDER YOUR TO
ENSURE THAT RESOURCES ARE
DEPLOYED EFFECTIVELY AND
EFFICIENTLY AND WE WILL
CONTINUE TO PROVIDE OUR
ANALYSIS OF HOW WELL THAT NEW
SYSTEM- IT'S GOING AS NEW
PROJECTS ARE CONTINUE FORWARD
IN YEARS TO COME BACK IN THE
PAST OBSERVATION IF I MADE THE
MISTAKE AND AGAIN IN YOUR TEAM.
FINANCE LOCAL GOVERNMENT IS
VERY PROBLEMATIC SITUATION
RIGHT NOW IN TERMS OF THEIR OWN
REVENUE ISSUES HUGE BECAUSE OF
THE ECONOMY AND OTHER OTHER
MATTERS. AS WELL. AT THE END
UNDERSTANDING THAT. COULD WE
EXAMINE MANDATE RELIEF THE OUT
THAT USED TO BE A REAL BIG
ISSUE. NOT MUCH CHANGED OTHER
THAN ADDING MORE MANDATES. BUT
I DO BELIEVE IF WE'RE GOING TO
BE TRULY HELPFUL TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT EMPOWERING LOCAL
GOVERNMENT WE SHOULD EXAMINE
SOME OF THE STATE IMPOSED
MANDATES ON LOCAL GOVERNMENTS.
CAN I TAKE A LOOK AT THAT DO
YOU SEE HIM MERIT THE UC OF A
VENUE IN THIS BUDGET WHERE WE
COULD. GIPSON MANDATE RELIEF TO
OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. PUBLIC
POLICIES SENATOR NIELSEN. YES I
MEAN THIS IS AN AREA WHERE OUR
OFFICE WOULD BE HAPPY TO DO
SOME ADDITIONAL. RESEARCH ON
YOUR BEHALF- BUT I THINK
CAROLINE CHIU AGAIN MY
COLLEAGUES POTENTIALLY OFFERS
DIGITAL STARTS HERE. CENTER
NIELSEN SO I AS YOU KNOW UNDER-
PROPOSITION ONE A LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS- DO NOT HAVE TO
PERFORM MANDATES THAT THE STATE
ARE JUST NOT FUN THERE ARE A
FEW EXCEPTIONS TO THOSE- BUT
OTHERWISE A LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ONLY NEED TO BE- PERFORMING.
BEING MANDATES FOR WHICH THE
STATE HAS PROVIDED FUNDING THAT
SAID I DO KNOW A NUMBER OF
MANDATES- REMAIN ON THE BOOKS-
THAT- I THINK MANY LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS COMPLY WITH I THINK
A GOOD EXAMPLE THAT OUR OFFICES
RIGHT NOW. ABOUT ELECTION NEEDS
ON AND SO CERTAINLY THERE'S
THERE IS THE QUESTION BEFORE
THE LEGISLATURE ARE THERE
PARTICULAR MANDATES THAT REMAIN
ON THE BOOKS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD ONCE YOU FIND.
ONE IN THE IN THE CURRENT- IN
THE BUDGET YEAR I'M KIND OF
DEPENDING ON WHAT THOSE ARE-
BUT ARE THERE OTHER SAY THAT
COULD BE THAT COULD BE-
ELIMINATED EVERY CERTAINLY
CORD. A LOOK AT ANY ONES THAT
YOU THERE ARE PARTICULAR
INTEREST YEAR OR MORE BROADLY.
AND THAT ARE SUSPENDED- AND WE
CAN OPERATE YEAR THAT LIST AS
WELL THAT'S HELPFUL. I WOULD
LIKE IT TO BE HERE ON THE MORE
OPTIMISTIC ABOUT HOW THIS IS
INVOLVED THAN THE THAN I AM.
THE YOU KNOW IT.
NOTWITHSTANDING PROP ONE AND
IF. THEY DON'T HAVE TO IF THEY
GET FUNDED- WE HAVE ANOTHER
ROUND IT'S CONSTRAINED A LOT OF
THAT OPTION OF THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS CALL LITIGATION.
AND CASE LAW HIS STOCK. THE A
LOT A LOT OF WHAT WE COULD DO
TO HELP AND GIVE THEM MANDATE
RELIEF SO I JUST SUGGEST WE
KEEP AN EYE ON THAT IS IT IS
STILL THE ISSUE THAT THE
DEVILS. OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU. THREE TO
NIELSEN THANK YOU MOVING ON TO
SENATOR SKINNER US SENATOR
SKINNER BE SURE TO IDENTIFY WHO
YOU'RE ADDRESSING YOUR QUESTION
TO PLEASE THANK YOU. ALL THE
STAFF BUT THIS YEAR IN
TOGETHER- THIS QUESTION IS TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- I
NOTICED THAT IN- NONE OF THE
SECTION EIGHT SECTION THIRTY
SIX ACTIONS THAT WE'VE RECEIVED
SO FAR- THERE IS NOT AND
BINDING TO INCREASE ACCESS TO
MENTAL SERVICES. I THINK WE'RE
ALL AWARE THAT IS THEIR
CHILDREN PLACE ORDER CONTINUES
AND- PEOPLE ARE ARE OBVIOUSLY
NOT ENABLE TO. SAYS NORMAL
SUPPORT SERVICES AND THE
ECONOMIC PRESSURES THAT WE HAVE
A LOT OF. INCREASED MENTAL
HEALTH STRESSES AND THAT WOULD
REDUCE THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WOULD COME IN ON THAT.
PLANTS THANK YOU I'M GONNA TURN
IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUE RIGHT
NOW OR IN OUR HHS UNIT. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION SENATOR
CAN YOU HEAR ME. ALL YES THANK
YOU I RYAN MILLER WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE WE'VE
BEEN- AS WAS DISCUSSED EARLIER
IN THE HEARING WE'VE BEEN IN
CONTACT WITH- YOU KNOW HOSPITAL
PARTNERS- YOU KNOW DOCTORS AND
ALSO ON OUR PARTNERS IN THE
MENTAL HEALTH WORLD TO YOU KNOW
BE IN CONSTANT CONTACT TO LEARN
ABOUT THE CHALLENGES THAT
THEY'RE FACING WE'RE ALSO
WORKING YES. OUR MEN'S HEALTH
CARE SERVICES NOTABLY IN THIS
CASE. SHOULD BE TRACKING THOSE
SITUATIONS AND WE ARE YOU KNOW
YOU KNOW WHEN WE- IF WE HAVE
ADDITIONAL DETAILS SOON ABOUT.
POTENTIAL SECTION THIRTY SIX
WINNING WILL BE SUBMITTING A
REQUEST. THANK YOU AND I'M SURE
THERE ARE A LOT. THE STATE
PROVIDE RIGHT INCREASED. HI MY
NEXT QUESTION IS LSO.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I NOTED
THE DIFFERENT- SECTION THIRTY
SIX LETTERS AND ACTIONS
REGARDING- INCREASED ACCESS FOR
GETTING HOMELESS FOLKS OUT OFF
THE STREET AND INTO SOME KIND
OF AN INTEL TOLERANCE OR OTHER
THINGS. AND WHAT COMMENT I HAVE
IS THAT WE ARE USING THE SAME-
SYSTEM THAT WE DID THROUGH THE-
HAPPENED HE WHICH IS THROUGH
THE COUNTIES AND I THINK
DIRECTLY TO COUNTY SOME NOT
SURE ABOUT CONTINUE MATURES YOU
COULD ANSWER THE ONE ABOUT TEEN
JUNIOR JERRY MINUTE- BUT WHAT-
I'VE OBSERVED IN MY OWN
DISTRICT IT MAY BE HAPPENING IN
SOME OTHER PLACES STATE THAT
THERE ARE A FEW CITY THAT ARE.
LOW THE REST OF DELEGATION FOR
HOMELESS FUNDING BUT HAVE LARGE
TOTAL NUMBERS OF HOMELESS
INDIVIDUALS VERY LARGE NUMBER
POPULATION OF AND SHELTERED
RESIDENTS IN THEIR
JURISDICTIONS AND THEY FEEL
THAT THEY ARE NOT GETTING THE
SAME ACCESS OR THE ACCESS TO
THE RESOURCES THEY NEED FOR THE
QUANTITY OF UNSTRUCTURED
PERSONS IN THEIR JURISDICTION
AND THEY'RE NOT SEEING THE- THE
ROOMS AND SUCH BEING UTILIZED
FOR DOES RESIDENTS. SO AFTER IF
IT'S SO WE COUNTIES OR CAN MUCH
ALSO BUT WHETHER YOU ARE GOING
TO IF THERE'S GOING TO BE ANY
LOOKING INTO THAT CIRCUMSTANCE.
YES SENATOR SKINNER I FIRST OF
ALL ON THE FUNDING AND AS YOU
POINTED OUT AND TELL US FOLLOW
AT THE SAME MODEL THE HOT MODEL
AND THAT INCLUDES CITIES
COUNTIES AND CONVENIENCE OF
CARE I'M ITS REMEMBER MY
COLLEAGUE CHRIS COOK WHO CAN
TALK MORE SPECIFICALLY ABOUT.
THE ALLOCATIONS ACROSS THE
DIFFERENT JURIST LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WHEN YOU MENTION.
THANK YOU YEAH AS MY COLLEAGUE
INDICATED THIS AS ALLOCATION
FOR THAT THE COLD AND- THE
HUNDRED MILLION WAS. CONSISTENT
WITH THE POINT IN TIME COUNTS
THAT WAS USED. FOR HALF WHICH
GOES TO COUNTIES- CITIES AND-
CONTINUES OF CARE AND FORGIVE
ME JUST CORRECTION CORRECTION
IT GOES TO CITY'S. POPULATION
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND AND ABOVE.
YEAH I BELIEVE THAT WAS THE
CASE FOR HE MIGHT BE YES YEAH
IT MIGHT BE THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND AND ABOVE BUT- I DON'T
THINK SO BUT THAT'S OKAY AND I
BELIEVE IT'S ONLY. TWELVE OR
FIFTEEN TOTAL CITIES BUT KEEP
GOING. RIGHT IT WAS CONSISTENT
WITH HOW I GET IT HAPPY TO
PROVIDE YOU THE ALLOCATION
SCHEDULE IF YOU'D LIKE- AND AS
FOR YOUR OTHER QUESTION I'M
SORRY I DIDN'T CATCH THAT LAST
QUESTION WITH REGARDS TO THE
HOTEL MOTEL AVAILABILITY. YEAH
THE POINT THE POINT IS THAT.
THE THAT. FORMULA IS A GREAT
FORMULA ON THE ONE HAND
HOWEVER. EVEN THOUGH IT
INCLUDES THE POINT IS THAT.
POINT OF TIME COUCH AND THUS
THE COMPANIES. OR THE CONTINUUM
OF CARE RECEIVE AN AMOUNT
ADEQUATE FOR THAT POINT OF TIME
COUNTY. IT DOESN'T REFLECT THAT
IN THAT POINT OF JAIL TIME
COUNTY THERE ARE HIGH
CONCENTRATIONS OF UNSTRUCTURED
RESIDENTS IN. VERY SPECIFIC
LOCALES WHO MAY NOT BE
RECEIVING THAT LEVEL OF SUPPORT
THROUGH THE COUNTY ALLOCATION
FOR THE OUR CONTINUUM OF CARE
THE US THERE ARE STILL
SIGNIFICANT NUMBERS OF
UNSTRUCTURED PEOPLE NOT GETTING
ACCESS TO THESE HOTEL ROOMS AND
SUCH. SO IT YOU DON'T NEED TO
FURTHER I JUST REALLY NEED TO
MAKE A POINT AND I THINK THAT
WILL BE ABLE TO PROVIDE YOU
SOME DOCUMENTATION. THANK YOU
WILL TAKE YOUR YOUR COMMENT IN.
THANK YOU. OKAY AND THEN ON
THAT ALSO THAT ISSUE WE HAVE
UNDER THE NORM A CERTAIN AMOUNT
OF PEOPLE THAT ARE RELEASED
FROM OUR STATE PRISON
FACILITIES. AND ARE WE DID
INCREASE THAT OR- RATHER- MOVE
UP A FEW PEOPLE- IN OTHER WORDS
THE OUR CORRECTIONS DEPARTMENTS
DID ALLOW FOR RELEASE OF THOSE
PEOPLE THAT WERE WITHIN SIXTY
DAYS OF THEIR NORMAL TROLL DATE
IT WAS NOT ANY UNUSUAL RELEASED
OTHER THAN. A LITTLE EARLIER
THAN THEY WOULD HAVE BEEN IN
ORDER TO BRING DOWN THE
POPULATION SOME TO DEAL WITH.
THAT YOU HAVE A LARGE
CONGREGATE YOU SILLY NOW MY
POINT HERE IS THAT THOSE FOLKS.
OUR PARTICULARLY ALL IN THE
BEST OF TIMES THEY HAVE
DIFFICULTIES FINDING HOUSING
FINDING EMPLOYMENT NOW IT WILL
BE THAT MUCH MORE SEVERE. AND
SO I WANTED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE HAVE COMMUNICATED TO
CONTINUUM'S OF CARE AND
COUNTIES THAT THAT RE ENTRY
POPULATION IS ELIGIBLE FOR ANY
HOMELESS FUNDING THAT'S
PROVIDED. ON OUR HOMES FUNDING
DOES ALLOW FOR IF SOMEONE IS
EXPECTED TO BE POTENTIALLY
BECOME HOMELESS WITHIN FOURTEEN
DAYS THAT THEY FIT THE CATEGORY
HOWEVER. THIS IS WHAT I
UNDERSTAND FROM VERY YES A
REENTRY SUPPORT INTO CHEESE AND
EVEN SOME OF OUR. PROBATION%
OFFICIALS IS THAT THEY'RE NOT
NECESSARILY BEING ABLE TO PUT
RE ENTRY POPULATION- ACCESS
THOSE FUNDS OR THOSE SERVICES
FOR REENTRY POPULATION. SO I'LL
TURN IT OVER TO IT'S AMY JARVIS
CAME THAT CAN SPEAK KID EVERY
ENTRY QUESTION AND CONNECTING
MEMBERS HOMELESS SERVICES. YES
IN YOUR PERSONAL DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE AND- AS YOU NOTED WE
DID PROVIDE SOME EXTRA MONEY
INTO THAT- COUNTY PROBATION
pPOPULATION GOING TO THEM- UNDER
A POST RELEASE COMMUNITY
SUPERVISION- PROCESS WE
ACTUALLY INCLUDED PROBABLY HAVE
MORE MONEY THAN WE INITIALLY
ORIGINALLY WHAT HAVE- PARTLY TO
ADDRESS HOMELESS IN HOUSING
ISSUES- YES WE HAVE HEARD THAT
THERE ARE SITUATIONS WHERE
THERE ARE SITUATIONS WHERE.
THOSE BEING RELEASED NEED TO BE
DIRECTED TO HOUSING AND WE ARE
WORKS. OUR INFORMATION
DEPARTMENTS TO TRY TO MITIGATE
THOSE ISSUES AS THEY COME UP
I'M AND I THINK THAT WE HAVE
COMMUNICATED THAT THEY ARE
ELIGIBLE. AND INDIVIDUALLY BY
COUNTY AND THEIR VARIATIONS AS
YOU CAN IMAGINE- BUT WE ARE
WORKING THROUGH THOSE ISSUES
AND CITIES ARE CONTINUES YOU
HAVE A- A RESOURCE LINE
AVAILABLE FOR THOSE QUESTIONS
AND SHOULD BE ABLE TO RESPOND
TO THEM AS THEY COME UP. OKAY
AND THEN ON THE PROJECT HOME-
ROOM KEEP PROJECT ROOM KEY.
THAT'S IT'S A GREAT UP PROGRAM
IN THE OTHER PROGRAMS ARE
GETTING HOTEL ROOMS FOR OUR
HOMELESS AND HOPEFULLY REENTRY
POPULATION OF WHAT I WONDERED
IS WHETHER THERE HAD BEEN
INCLUDED THE- ABILITY FOR THE
HOTEL WORKERS THAT ARE
OTHERWISE THEN OBVIOUSLY LOST
JOBS. ARE THEY BEING RE
EMPLOYED IN ORDER TO DEAL WITH
THIS IF WE ARE PROVIDING US
FUNDING TO THE STAR TELLS TO
PROVIDE THESE ROOMS ARE THEY
UTILIZING HOTEL WORKERS. THIS
ALL TURN OVER TEN MARKHAM
AGENTS AT HHS. START SENATOR
THANK YOU FOR YOUR QUESTION
JUST TO MAKE SURE I UNDERSTAND
I THINK YOU'RE SAYING THAT- THE
QUESTION IS AROUND WHETHER OR
NOT THE HOTEL WORKERS ARE BEING
UTILIZED IN THOSE ARE CAL'S. MY
UNDERSTANDING. IS THE CASE-
CERTAINLY DEPENDS ON TOP. BY
HOTEL BUT MY UNDERSTANDING BY
AND LARGE IS THAT THEY ARE
BEING USED IN THE HEALTH. WE
MIGHT WANT TO GET SOME.
CLARIFICATION ONLY BECAUSE- FOR
EXAMPLE UNITE HERE WHICH IS MY
IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING OR- THE-
UNION THAT REPRESENTS THE
LARGEST NUMBER OF HOTEL WORKERS
IN CALIFORNIA. HAS NOT SEEN
THAT SO WE MAY WANT TO GET SOME
CLARIFICATION. BY THEN- I WANT
TO GO BACK TO A QUESTION OR
POINT THAT- BOB WHITE HOUSE YOU
MADE ABOUT BE DEBT COLLECTION
AND I'M NOT SURE. WE OF COURSE
CAN'T- CONTROL WHATEVER THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DOES BUT I
KNOW THAT BOTH THE STATE
GOVERNMENT AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS WILL OFTEN IF THERE
IS THE DEBT EITHER FOR FINE
STRAINS FRACTIONS OR PARKING
TICKETS AND SUCH. THAT AS SOON
AS FUNDING COMES INTO A
PERSON'S BANK ACCOUNT THEY WILL
OFTEN SHOCKED THAT AND I THINK
RIGHT NOW WE WANT TO MAKE SURE.
THAT IT IS NOT CHAPTER JUST
BECAUSE OF THE ECONOMIC
SITUATION PEOPLE ARE FACING.
YES UNDERSTOOD AND ONE
ADDITIONAL POINT I WANT TO MAKE
IN A RECENT CONSENT ADDITIONAL
LIGHT ON THIS IS SPECIFIC TO IN
THAT COURT SYSTEM OF COURSE
THEY ARE MAKING THEIR DECISIONS
THAT THEY HAVE THAT MADE
CHANGES IN THIS REGARD WITH
REGARD TO- COLLECTIONS IN
ELECTIONS IN THE COURT SYSTEM
BY ASKING YOU YOU CAN CALL UP.
SORRY ABOUT THAT TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES. I'M THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL DID I'M I'D TAKE
SEVERAL EMERGENCY ACTIONS I'M
JUST LAST WEEK MANY OF THEM
WENT INTO EFFECT ON MONDAY
APRIL THIRTEENTH WHICH INCLUDED
THE SUSPENSION OF THE ENTRY OF
DEFAULT AN ADDICTION CASES. AND
SUSPENDED JUDICIAL
FORECLOSURES- SO OUR HOPE IS
THAT ALL OF THOSE THINGS
COMBINED WILL HELP PEOPLE STAY
IN THEIR CURRENT HOUSING. AND
WILL CONTINUE TO MONITOR AND
WORK WITH THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL-
ANYTHING THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
VERY PROACTIVE IN ADDRESSING
SOME OF THESE ISSUES- BUT THAT
THEY THINK THOSE ARE REALLY THE
THINGS THAT WE WOULD- LOOK TO
AS- I'M HELP. THREE I MAY. THIS
YEAH MICHAEL WASN'T SO MUCH
ABOUT THE- HOUSING- IN TERMS OF
FORECLOSURE OR DIRECT
PROTECTIONS THAT JUDICIAL
COUNCIL PROVIDED BUT RATHER. HE
STATE OR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CAP
BEING BANK ACCOUNTS FOR
INFRACTIONS ARE FINE SIR FEES
THAT ARE OF. SO THIS IS
INDIVIDUALIZED BY COUNTY AGAIN
FIFTY COURTS FIFTY DIFFERENT
WAYS OF DOING THAT SOME COUNTY
SAID CONTINUE DOING SOME
COLLECTIONS- BUT MOST ARE NOT-
BUT THEY ARE DOING SOME WE
DON'T KNOW THAT THEY'RE DOING
IN OUR DIRECT GOING IN DIRECT
TO BEING TAKE BUT THERE ARE
SOME- COLLECTION STOPPING
TRAFFIC IS PRETTY MUCH SHUT
DOWN. AND THROUGHOUT ALL COURTS
AND BUT SOME OF THESE OTHER AND
LONG LONG STANDING I DEBT
COLLECTION ACTIVITIES HAVE
CONTINUED BUT AND NOT VERY MANY
COURTS AND WE CAN GET BACK.
WITH MORE INFORMATION IF THAT
WOULD BE HELPFUL. THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE. THEN ON DECK
COMMUNITY CARE FACILITIES I
NOTICED THAT THE SECTION ONE OF
THIS SECTION THIRTY SIX.
LETTERS PROVIDED FORTY ONE
MILLION FOR ADULTS INGENIEUR
RESIDENTIAL SOMEBODY'S
OBVIOUSLY SEEING. INCREASING
CASES AND VERY VERY TRAGICALLY
DEATHS AD MANY OF THOSE I
WONDERED IF HOW. BUT IF WE'VE
BEEN MONITORING THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF THAT SPENDING.
AND WHAT I'M MORE. I THINK
OBVIOUSLY PEOPLE ARE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THEY DO NOT
WANT TO SEE INCREASED DEATHS IN
THOSE FACILITIES AND- I
UNDERSTAND FROM IT FROM. SOME
LEADERS AND WITHIN THIS SECTOR
THAT THEY DON'T FEEL THE
GUIDANCE STATUS GIVEN IS
ADEQUATE- SOME WONDERING ABOUT
THE LEVEL OF SPENDING SO FOUR
OF THAT ALLOCATION AND WHETHER
THERE'S GOING TO BE INCREASED
GUIDANCE REJECT THOSE PEOPLE
WHO LIVE UNDER THE SAUDIS. YES
THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE
I'M GONNA TURN IT OVER TO ADAM
DORSEY WHO CAN SPEAK TO IT AND
THEN PERHAPS AFTER AND MARCO AS
WELL. HELLO AT HELLO ADAM
DORSEY FINANCE THAT SO YEAH.
IT'S A VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE
THAT WE ARE GRAPPLING WITH AND
THAT'S WHY WE THOUGHT IT WAS
IMPORTANT TO MAKE SUCH A
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN THIS
AREA- IN REALLY THAT MONEY IS
THERE ARE TWO- I'D TEAMS TO GO
INTO THESE. CITIES WHEN-
THEY'RE IN. AS RESIDENTS THAT
ARE SYMPTOMATIC MAKE SURE THAT
WE CAN HELP THESE FACILITIES
ISOLATE AND WHEN WE CAN'T
ISOLATE- TO QUARANTINE AND MAKE
SURE. THAT WE ARE MINIMIZING
THE SPREAD IN THESE FACILITIES-
IS MUCH AS WE POSSIBLY CAN THIS
IS A REALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE IN
A VERY VULNERABLE POPULATION-
AND SO- ABSOLUTELY- THAT'S WHY
THE INVESTMENT IS THERE AND
WHAT. WE'RE DOING EVERYTHING WE
CAN IN THIS AREA I'M I'LL HIN
LOFT MARCO AND IF THERE'S
ANYTHING ELSE TO ADD ON THAT
HARD AND TO ALSO TALK ABOUT THE
GUIDANCE. THANK YOU. FOR THAT
QUESTION SO THERE'S A FEW
THINGS THAT WE'VE DONE IN THIS
AREA AND I THINK THIS IS A
REALLY IMPORTANT PIECE BECAUSE
THESE ARE INDIVIDUALS ARE. VERY
VULNERABLE FOR AREN'T COPING
NINETEEN OUR FIRST WEEKEND UP
QUITE A SERIES OF TEAMS TO EACH
ONE OF THE FACILITIES THAT ARE
I DON'T AND SENIOR CURRENT THAT
ARE LICENSED BY THE DEPARTMENT
OF SOCIAL SERVICES. INITIALLY
WHEN APPOINT PEOPLE IN THE
FIELD NOW WE'VE BEEN DOING
HOWEVER THE PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE WE REACH EVERY
SINGLE FACILITY TO NOT ONLY
PROVIDE THEM WITH. A ROUND. OUT
APPROPRIATE. ALL BUT ALSO NEED
SOMEONE DOES TEST POSITIVE IN
THE- HOW DEAL WITH THAT
INDIVIDUAL AND WHAT IT IS A
PART OF GERMANY CAN PROVIDE TO
THEM. WE HAVE BEEN ISSUE A
SERIES OKAY DOCUMENTS WERE HOW
TO UP WITH YOUR- MIND YOU A
LIST OF. AND STOCK YOU SO.
SHOULD IF YOU HEARING FROM
FOLKS I'M FOR MORE. TIME WE
WOULD LOVE TO HEAR THAT I WORK
WITH THOSE INDIVIDUALS TO SEE
WHAT ELSE WE CAN DO I'VE ALWAYS
BEEN VERY PROACTIVE TO TRY TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE PUTTING
NURSES. HELP THESE PARTICULAR
RESULT IN MANY INSTANCES THESE
ARE SMALLER AND SO THE PRINTER
STAYS BAD. OR LASSEN SO MAKING.
SURE THAT THEY HAVE. CALL I
JOIN SURE PAYMENT AGAIN KIND OF
DISEASE VIRUS WITHIN A
PARTICULAR WORK. THANK YOU WILL
PASS ON ANY COMMUNICATE REFER
SEVE AND THEN BETTER INSURED
COUPLE QUESTION. BUT UNDER
DIFFERENT GONNA JUST GONNA AT
IF YOU TRY TO KNOW IT PLEASE
AYE AYE LOSE. I NEEDED. TO
COMMENT BY ABOUT TEN TO SIX AND
I'VE GOT TWO MORE MEMBERS OF
FLEETWOOD RAPID ABOUT
APPRECIATED. CERTAINLY HAVE
TRIED TO STAY WITHIN THE
SECTION THIRTY SIX ITEMS. I'M
IN THE MOOD MEALS. ARE THERE
WAS TWENTY MILLION OR FOOD
NEEDS THAT WAS TWENTY MILLION
IN APRIL FIFTEENTH AND- NO
THERE WAS TWENTY MILLION
INITIALLY AND THEN. I CHEN IN
THAT BECAUSE THE TEAM. TO HELP
COUNTIES THAT FIRST ONE WAS FOR
GENERAL. I GET THANKS THE OTHER
WAS FOR COUNTY. TO HELL GET SAM
THE ACCESS TO THE- FOOD
BENEFITS. I NOTE I THINK ALL OF
US EXPERIENCE THAT. MANY OF OUR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN OUR SCHOOL
SITES ARE. AS WHAT EXPECTED
PROVIDING MEALS ARE AND- TO
THEIR STUDENTS AND THAT MAY
NEED TO CONTINUE THROUGH
SUMMER. BUT I'VE ALSO HEARD
THAT SOME SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE
SCHOOL ARE REALLY RUNNING OUT
OF FUNDS TO DO SO AND ONE THAT
ARE AT ITS USE MAKES DEPARTMENT.
AND ADMINISTRATION HAS IN MIND
THAT BUT DO THEY ANTICIPATE.
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL FRIENDS.
TO THIS ALL TURN OVER TO MARCO
AS WELL WHO CAN SPEAK MOST
ACCURATELY TO THIS. THANK YOU
FOR THAT'S REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT QUESTION AROUND THE
FOOD NEEDS ESPECIALLY AMONG OUR
CHILDREN WE'RE GETTING SOME OF
THE STEPS. THAT SCHOOL SO
THERE'S A FEW THINGS THAT WE'VE
DONE THAT WE YOU'LL GO LOOK AT
YOUR THE TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
ALLOCATED TO THE FOOD BANK. WE
ARE ALSO WORKING WITH CAL FRESH
PROGRAM WHICH IS THE FEDERAL
SNAP PROGRAM WE'RE DOING A FEW
THINGS THEIR- FIRST- WEEK OF
COURSE OUT O MERGING SEE A
LOT. OF ONE POINT THREE MILLION
HOUSEHOLDS IN THE LAST COUPLE
OF DAYS AFTER THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM THANK YOU YOU SHOULD
ONLY WE ARE REQUESTING THAT BIG
WAIVER FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. ENDEMIC HE HE WHICH
WILL ALLOW WESTERN AND ARAB WHO
BENEFITS TO CHILDREN WE'RE
GETTING SCHOOL MEALS ACTION
THERE WOULD BENEFIT ON THE EAST
SIDE. YEAH AND THEN THE OTHER
PIECE WE ARE WORKING ON WITHIN
THE- PROGRAM. I WE HAVE
RECEIVED APPROVAL. THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT. EACH YOUNG LEVINE
WHICH ALLOW. OUR ARE RECIPIENTS
ON THE TWENTY TO BE A TO
ENCOURAGE. ONLINE OUR- WITH
CERTAIN BE. SOMEWHERE BY THE-
GOVERNMENT WE- TO WORK WITH
SEAT COLLEAGUES AROUND COULD
MEAN ARE JOB. OUR WHO MY BE
GETTING GOODNESS. PROGRAMS AS
WELL AS OUR VOLUNTEERS ANOTHER
WITH PARTNERS I WITH REGARDS TO
THE WE BRING BACK WE WHAT DID
YOU SOME. IN REGARDS TO BENEFIT
AMONG OUR PREFERRED WITHIN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU
AND FINAL WITHIN MY OWN- SO.
YES STEPS FIVE I HAVE BEEN
HAVING ONGOING CONVERSATIONS
WITH THE ADMINISTRATION AND
WITH US YOU SEE OUR SECRETARY
SO I'M NOT GOING TO ASK.
QUESTIONS THERE OTHER THAN
MAKES THE POINT THAT THIS IS
OUR LARGEST CONGREGATE.
CONGREGATE POPULATION WITHIN
THE WHOLE STATE AND THIS LARGE
CORPORATE POPULATION IS 1100%
WARDS OF THE STATE. AND WHILE
THERE ARE AND MANY OWNER
ABILITIES WITHIN THAT
POPULATION RIGHT NOW THOSE WHO
ARE BEING HELD IN THE DORM LIKE
SETTINGS. ARE THE MOST EXPOSED
THEY HAVE THE LEAST ABILITY TO.
TO HAVE THIS SOCIAL DISTANCING
THAT EVERYONE ELSE IS AND SO
THEY'RE OBVIOUSLY- THERE'S A
WHOLE VARIETY OF WAYS THAT. WE
CAN ADDRESS THAT BUT I. WANTED
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
PUTTING THAT- FIRST AND
FOREMOST SO THAT WE ARE NOT WE
DO WE DO NOT EXPERIENCED. DEATH
SO LIKE WE ARE SEEING
UNFORTUNATELY IN MANY OF OUR
NURSING FACILITIES AND SENIOR
SWORDS- BUT IN THAT. WE ARE
JUST ON THE NATURAL BECAUSE
PEOPLE ARE PAROLED RELEASING
FOLKS INTO THE COMMUNITY. AND I
THINK IT IS VERY IMPORTANT THAT
THEY BE TESTED BEFORE RELEASED
NOT THEN BE HELD LONGER BUT SO
THAT WE CAN. ENSURE THAT THEY
CAN BE QUARANTINED SO THAT WE
ARE NOT TAKING THE SPREAD OF
POTENTIALLY AN INFECTION IN ONE
FACILITY INTO THE COMMUNITY. SO
I THINK IT'S VERY IMPORTANT WE
ENSURE THAT EVERYONE BEFORE. WE
NEED MORE TESTING OVERALL NIKKI
SO IT IS BUT I KNOW WE NEED IT
OVERALL EVERYWHERE IN THE
STATE. IT'S. CHEST X. LEAST.
UNDERSTOOD SENATOR WE WILL TAKE
THAT BACK TO SEIZE YOUR THANK
YOU FOR THE FEEDBACK ON THAT.
AND THAT'S ALL THANK YOU CHAIR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHAU THIRTY
SKINNER VERY MUCH SENATOR DOLLY.
WELL GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD TO SEE
YOU MADAM CHAIR ISSUED PERSON
SOON I HAVE A- DROP OR
QUESTIONS I WANTED TO PER SE.
THAT THERE WAS THAT POPULATED
AS SENATOR SKINNER TALKED ABOUT
THE POPULATION CAP WHICH SHOWED
SHE BELIEVED WAS REALLY I THINK
IT'S THREE HUNDRED DOLLARS I'M
NOT SURE- BUT MOST OF MY
DISTRICT DOESN'T FIT UNDER THAT
CAP BUT I WAS WONDERING WHAT
THE ADMINISTRATION PLAN TO DO
THOSE THAT WERE EITHER THREE OR
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS YEAH. THE
STATE'S. THESE ARE FOR FINANCE
I BELIEVE ALL MY QUESTIONS ARE
FINANCE. YES I'LL MAKE A COUPLE
BRIEF POINTS FIRST I THINK I
REALIZED IN THE CONVERSATION
WITH SENATOR SKINNER THERE IS
THAT THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND-
FOR THE SPECIFIC TAX PROGRAM
BUT THERE'S ALSO AND I'M SURE
MANY OF YOU HAVE BEEN GETTING A
LOT OF THE TIMING ON THIS. FIVE
HUNDRED THOUSAND PERSON CASPER
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AGE FROM THE
CENTRAL SAXON SO THERE ARE A
LOT OF CITIES AND OTHER LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS THAT ARE BELOW
FIVE THOUSAND PEOPLE. THREE
HUNDRED PEOPLE THAT ARE IN. FOR
BACK THROUGH A- UNDER THE CAR
LAW SO THERE'S NO LOT OF
DISCUSSION AROUND MAKE UP. VERY
AWARE AND WHAT I'M NOT ON PART
OF THE NAY. SEVERAL BILLS SO I
THINK. THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
THAT FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND EACH
I THINK ON THIS SPECIFIC ISSUE
WHEN IT COMES TO HOW. THE IS A
PROGRAM THAT WAS IN LAST BUDGET
THAT WE NOW. PUT IN SOME THIS
ADDITIONAL MONEY ON THIS. PART
OF IT IS THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
IN THE BOX BUT THEN THERE'S
ALSO THE COUNTY SAN MONEY DOES.
BASED ON THE COUNTY TO ALL THE
COUNTIES AND INTERACTIONS MEANS
OF CARE WHICH ALSO COVER ALL
AREAS OF THE STATE SO. THE
FOCUS ON THE CITY'S. IS THAT
SPECIFIC CAR OUT OF THE FUNDING
IS BASED ON THE UNIQUE
CHALLENGES THAT THEY FACE
CERTAINLY NOT THE ONLY PART OF
THE APPLICATION THAT IS
DESIGNED TO ADDRESS ISSUES
ACROSS THE STATE INCLUDING
PEARL HOMELESSNESS. I THINK THE
BROADER ISSUE THAT WE KNOW IS
THAT A HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS.
IT'S A GOOD START WE HAVE A LOT.
MORE TO DO THIS WAS AN ISSUE.
TO THE STATE. I WON THE BIGGEST
IN THIS. EVEN BEFORE COMING
NINETEEN. WE UNDERSTAND OCCURS
MORE TO THERE AND I THINK THE
LAST THING I'LL SAY IN ADDITION
TO THAT. I'M MORE FLEXIBLE
FEDERAL AID DOT RECEDING AND IT
DID IN ADDITION TO THE FACT
THAT. LARGER SEVEN LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE ENTITLED SHOULD
BE. THANKS I KNOW THE EMERGENCY
SOLUTIONS GRANT ARE ONE PART IN
IT OR WHAT YOU. THANK YOU YEAH.
JUST WANTED TO COMMENT YOU KNOW.
SOMEBODY WHO'S BEEN. HAD THE
OROVILLE DAM CRISIS AND WE GOT
THE CAMPFIRE WE'VE SEEN THOSE-
NATURAL DISASTERS BUT WE KNOW
WHICH WAY THE WIND'S BLOWING WE
KNOW WHICH WAS WATER FLOWING WE
CAN GET PEOPLE OUT WAY IN THIS
CASE WE HAVE AN UNPRECEDENTED
THE- OUTCOME IS GONNA BE
DIFFERENT AT THE END BECAUSE
IT'S WE DON'T KNOW THE DATE SO
I WE'RE BASICALLY. THROWING
MONEY RIGHT NOW JUST IN PLACES
WHERE WE TAKE IS GOING TO WORK
AND SO WHAT IS THAT WHAT IS THE
OVERALL OVERSIGHT. FOR EIGHT OR
APPROPRIATE OUT TO LIKE I KNOW
WE HAVE A- YES FOR THE HOSPITAL
IN IN MY DISTRICT AND NOBODY'S
AND HOSPITALS AND SOMEBODY
WATCH YOU KNOW. IT BABY ALL IN
A WEEK I DON'T KNOW. BUT IT
WHAT HAPPENS IS THAT WE NEED TO
CHANGE AND WE NEED TO. REDIRECT
SOME OF THOSE FUNDS WHAT'S THE
PROCESS THAT HIS OVERSEEING
THAT ARE YOU. DOING THAT. YES
SO WHAT THE PROCESS BY WHICH
THE FUNDS ARE ALLOCATED AT
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE YOU KNOW
WE'RE THE ONES KEEPING TRACK OF
EVERYTHING AND SENDING THE
NOTIFICATIONS. TO YOU IN THE
LEGISLATURE BUT IT REALLY IS A
WHOLE OF GOVERNMENT PROCESS YOU
KNOW AND THAT'S WHAT ONE OF THE
REASONS WE WANTED TINA AND MARK
ON THE PHONE BECAUSE WE'RE IN
THE STATE OPERATIONS CENTER
WITH. AND YOU KNOW WE'RE
WORKING DIRECTLY WITH HHS- WE
ASK AND OTHER. AGENCIES AND
DEPARTMENTS WE'RE WORKING ON
DAIS ON WITH REGARD TO THE MORE
SPECIFIC QUESTION YOU KNOW
CERTAINLY IN THE LAST COUPLE
WEEKS- YOU'RE IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT IT THE- AND MANY JUST AIMS
AND TRY TO. ROUTE AND MODEL
WHEN HE WILL BE SO THAT WE CAN
SEARCH OUR HOSPITAL CAPACITY. I
AM RIGHT NOW IT DOES SEEM AND
MARCO TO SPEAK MORE TO THIS
BUT- WE CERTAINLY- THERE ARE
SOME THERE ARE SOME REASONS FOR
OPTIMISM YOU KNOW IN THE SHORT
TERM BUT WE JUST DON'T KNOW
WHERE IT'S GONNA GO SO. JUST
STATE THE OBVIOUS THE FACT THAT.
THIS IS FULL. ACCESS TO GOOD
THING YOUR WERE WERE HAVE THAT
IT'S NOT STOLEN HOPEFULLY WILL
GET YOU TO STAY THAT WAY BUT WE
DID ONE BE PREPARED. FOR THAT
EVENTUALITY AND SHOULD BE THE
CASE THAT WE HAVE MORE REASONS
FOR OPTIMISM IN THE FUTURE. AND
WE CAN START TO REOPEN THE
ECONOMY AND ITS FRIENDS OUT
THAT. HE STARTS ACROSS THE-
WORKS IS NO LONGER NEEDED. WE
WERE JACKSON ACCESS LEAD IN
TERMS. OUT HOW TO REDEPLOY
THOSE RESOURCES WHERE THEY ARE
NEEDED AND THAT GOOD NEWS HERE
IS THAT THIS IS THEIR- DAY TO
DAY ASSESSMENT THAT THE
GOVERNOR'S MAKING. YOU STANDING.
IN ABOUT IT EVERY DAY AT NOON
IN TERMS OF WHERE THE NUMBERS
ARE. SOURCES ALMOST NEED. THANK
YOU BUT ONE OF THE OTHER AREAS
I WANT TO TOUCH ON IT JUST TWO
MORE AND THEN WE'LL WRAP IT UP
AND I HAVE A COMMENT- I WANNA
TAKE A SITTER CABALLERO FOR
TAKING THAT RURAL HOSPITALS AT
THE SAME ISSUES THAT SHE HAS
THAT SHE CAN TALK ABOUT
ARTISTIC AND PHYSICIANS WHO
ARE- YOU KNOW. WONDERING WHAT
THEY'RE GONNA DO IN THE FUTURE
SO YOU PARTY TOUCH ON THOSE-
BUT WE YOU TOUCH A LITTLE BIT
ON THE FOOD BANKS AND THE AND I
KNOW THAT THERE'S BEEN A
SHORTAGE- GETTING FOOD OUT AND
WE'RE GONNA SEE MORE PEOPLE
ACCESSING THE FOOD BANK BUT-
THE FARMERS ON THE- IN SOME OF.
DUMPING AND OF PROCESS. THE
FOOD CHAIN PROCESS IS. GETTING
JUST ROB IS GONNA BE DISRUPTED
IN A DIFFERENT WAY AND I THINK
THAT- AT LEAST IN MY DISTRICT
AND SOMEBODY WHO'S IN
AGRICULTURE BUSINESS THAT. THAT
THEY'RE THEY'RE BUILT A BEEN
MET LEFT OUT AND- AS FAR AS I
KNOW THAT THE- SHE- IS TALKING
ABOUT YOUR TONY. FARMERS TO
DONATE BUT WE HAVE TO. THE
THAT. THE PIPELINE AND BE SURE
THAT THEIR MAIN GOAL NOW I
THINK THEY'VE BEEN KIND OF
SKIPPED OUT SO THAT'S JUST
SOMETHING I WANT YOU TO. BE
AWARE OF. THAT IS. BEING AND
YOU CAN'T PROCESS IT IN YOU AND
YOU. WORKERS AS A VULNERABLE
ONES OUT IF WE DON'T HAVE SOME
THE NEXT TO KEEPING THEM.
ANYWHERE THE MIDDLE OF THE-
SEASON RIGHT NOW WHICH- YOU CAN
ARE. PLANS SO THOSE THINGS GOT
TO HAPPEN SO JUST WANTED TO
TOUCH ON THAT. I LOVE. ACTUAL
QUESTION WOULD BE. A LOT ABOUT.
WHATEVER APPROPRIATING MONEY
WHERE THE MONEY'S GOING AND WE
HAVE AND HOW THE BADGER
REACTING TO IT AND YOU KNOW
THEY'RE BASICALLY CREATING
MONEY. PAST THEY CAN'T PREDICT
FASTER AND WE'RE NOT GONNA HAVE
THAT LUXURY IN CALIFORNIA TO BE
ABLE TO PRINT MONEY WORK WE'RE
GONNA HAVE SOME SHORTFALL
THERE'S NO DOUBT ABOUT IT BUT
WHAT WHAT IS IT. WHAT WHAT'S
YOUR SENSE OF THE OUT HOW WE
CAN STIMULATE BUSINESS SOMEBODY
YOU. I MYSELF IS IN BUSINESS
AND I'VE BEEN. TALKING ABOUT
THE REGULATIONS IN CALIFORNIA
NOW- HOW DIFFICULT IT IS THE IN
THE BUSINESS I'M YOUR WHAT WHAT
DO YOU WHAT WHAT IS YOUR GOAL
OR WHAT WHAT DO YOU LOOKING
FORWARD TO. TRYING TO HELP
BUSINESSES. BE ABLE TO RESTART
AND I THINK WE SHOULD BE
STARTED TALK ABOUT THAT PROCESS
BECAUSE- WE'RE SURE GONNA NEED.
FUTURE YES AT ALL STATE TWO
THINGS THE FIRST IS THA YOU'RE
ABSOLUTELY RIGHTON. THE
DIFFERENCES. BETWEEN WHAT THE
STATE CAN DO AND THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT CAN DO BECAUSE THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CAN PRINT
MONEY. AND THEN THEY CAN ALSO
RUN YOUR LITERALLY IN THIS CASE
TRILLION MULTI TRILLION DOLLAR
DEFICIT SENSE AND- IN OUR CASE.
THE RAINY DAY FUND MECHANISM
ALLOWS FOR A LITTLE BIT OF
COUNTER CYCLICAL POLICY WHERE.
WE CAN SEND MORE. ON THESE
ISSUES INCLUDING THOSE THAT
YOU'RE NOT LINES WHEN THE
ECONOMY DECLINES BUT ONLY UP TO
A CERTAIN LEVEL AND YOU'RE NOT
CONTROLLING ARE OWN CURRENCY-
SO THEY ARE MORE FLEXIBLE THAN
WE ARE AND WE ARE CERTAINLY.
CAN DO A LOT AND WE'RE TRYING
TO DO THE BEST WITH WHAT WE
HAVE. IS ONE OF THE REASONS
THAT WE'VE BEEN SO CASE WITH
FEDERAL. I BROADER QUESTION YOU
RAISED ABOUT WE- DO. A SO MANY
DIFFERENT AREAS SPENDING THAT.
GOVERNOR'S FOCUSED ON AND I
THINK THIS IS ONE THAT REALLY
CROSSES DEMOGRAPHIC IN PARTY
MINDS IS TO FOCUS. ON SMALL
BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC RECOVERY
MAKING SURE THAT. THOSE FOLKS
WHO ARE ARTISTS. AND YOU KNOW
MAY NOT ALWAYS FEEL LIKE THEY
HAVE A VOICE. IN WASHINGTON AND
OREGON IN IN DIFFERENT
GOVERNMENTS COUNCILS ARE
GETTING THE HELP THAT THEY NEED
SO. CERTAINLY THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE WE'VE BEEN IN VERY
CLOSE TOUCH. WITH OUR
COLLEAGUES AT THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF BUSINESS AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT INCLUDING THEIR
OFFICES THE SMALL BUSINESS
ADVOCATES ONE THING THAT
THEY'VE BEEN REALLY FOCUSED ON
RIGHT NOW WE TALKED A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT. YOUR CREDIT FOODS
PEOPLE HAVE TO JUMP THROUGH
JUST THAT ACCESS THE PAYCHECK
PROTECTION PROGRAM AND THERE
ARE OTHER PROGRAMS LIKE THESE
ECONOMIC INJURY. DISASTER LOANS
UNDER SEVEN A LOANS FROM THE
FEDERAL SMALL BUSINESS
ADMINISTRATION. AND YOU KNOW.
THIS IS START CRISIS PEOPLE ARE
REALLY HAVING TROUBLE EVEN JUST
GETTING ON THE PHONE SO I THINK
IN THAT SMALL BUSINESS AREA AND
THE GOVERNOR HAS ANNOUNCED.
SOME INITIATIVES. TO HELP
PEOPLE GET FEDERAL ASSISTANCE
THESE ARE ALLOCATED SIXTY
MILLION DOLLARS OF THAT MONEY
THAT THE LEGISLATURE.
APPROPRIATED OFFERING
INFRASTRUCTURE DEVELOPMENT BANK
I TO HELP SPECIFICALLY THOSE
BUSINESS. THAT FOR A VARIETY
REASONS MIGHT NOT HAVE ACCESS.
TO THE FEDERAL. AND MORE GROW.
AND IN HE'S SIGNAL THAT HE'S
GONNA SPEAK MORE ABOUT THIS IN
THE DAYS AND WEEKS THE COMICS
THINKING ABOUT USING THEM EVEN
AS WE'RE CONFRONTING IMMEDIATE.
HEALTH CARE AND PUBLIC HEALTH
CRISIS HOW DO WE START THE
ECONOMIC RECOVERY BECAUSE WE
KNOW THAT WE HAVE. THE OUT A
AND THEN I THINK THE LAST THING
I'LL SAY WHICH IS SOMEONE
EDUCATION NOT EXACTLY A SMALL
BUSINESS ISSUE BUT CERTAINLY AN
ISSUE THAT MATTERS FOR WORKERS.
IS I THINK YOU'VE SEEN IN THE
LAST COUPLE DAYS THE
FRUSTRATIONS NATIONWIDE ABOUT
PEOPLE GETTING ACCESS TO THE
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS WHICH IS
BEEN MADE MORE GENEROUS BY THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THAT ACTUALLY
GETS INO PEOPLE'S. BANK
ACCOUNTS SO WHETHER IT'S
EXTENDING THE HOURS J.
INCLUDING THE WEEKEND DAYS AND
IN ADDITION TO THE WEEK DAYS
AND ADDING A HUNDREDS OF
ADDITIONAL WORKERS. FOR
UNEMPLOYMENT INSURANCE
ADMINISTRATION. DEPARTMENTS I
THINK THAT IS AN AREA WHERE THE
GOVERNOR WANTS TO MAKE SURE TO
HELP YOU. ALSO TRYING TO DO IS
JUST AND WE KNOW OUR SCHOOLS
ARE LIMITED COMPARED TO THE-
GOVERNMENT'S BUT CERTAINLY MORE
THAT WE'RE. GONNA ADVOCATE FOR
AND- WELL I JUST. THAT THEY Q.
FOR THOSE STEPS AND I KNOW THAT
I WANT TO COMMEND THE GOVERNOR
I THINK THAT. HE'S DONE SOME
GREAT THINGS THAT WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT A LONG TIME FOR
EXAMPLE. NURSES WHO WERE
WAITING ON LICENSES HE WEIGHED
THAT AND SOMETHING WE DIDN'T.
THERE'S A LOT OF OPPORTUNITIES
I WOULD JUST SAY FOR. US TO
STIMULATE BUSINESS BY
STREAMLINING THE PROCESS TO GET
WHERE THEY NEED TO GO TO EMPLOY
PEOPLE AND TO AND TO PROVIDE
SERVICES TO CALIFORNIANS IT
IMPROVE OUR ECONOMY SO I WANT
TO COMMEND YOU FOR THAT. LOOK
FOR MORE THOSE OPPORTUNITIES
ALONG WAITED TO MAKE IT HAPPEN
AGAIN THANK YOU THAT'S ALL MY
QUESTIONS THANKS CHAIR
APPRECIATE YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR DOLLY SENATOR ROTH. ONE
COMMENTED ONE QUESTION JUST
BEFORE STOP BY THE COMMENTS OF
MY COLLEAGUES THE SENATOR IS.
OF YOUR OWN AND- YOU KNOW IF
THE REPORTS ARE ACCURATE THAT
FAMILY PRACTICE SPECIALIST IN
SUB SPECIALISTS POSITIONS. AND
OTHER HEALTHCARE PROVIDERS IN
THIS STRAIGHTER EXPERIENCING A
DEVASTATING. A REDUCTION OF
CRAP. YOU AS PRACTICES ARE NON
COLBERT RELATED. AND THEIR
PRACTICES THE VIABILITY OF
PRACTICE IS IN QUESTION. THEN
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT IF WE WANT
TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE A ROBUST
HEALTH CARE DELIVERY SYSTEM A
PROVIDER NETWORK THROUGHOUT THE
STATE WHEN THIS IS OVER. WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO LOOKS MORE THAN
JUST FEDERAL GOVERNMENT SHUT A
SMALL BUSINESS THE RELIEF
PROGRAM TO DO SO AND SO
MINISTRY FINANCE I CERTAINLY
YES YOU WILL YOU TAKE A LOOK AT
THAT IS. MY QUESTION THIS TO DO
MEANT HEALTH. YOU KNOW WE KNOW
MYSTERY THAT DISASTROUS
ECONOMIC AND OTHERWISE. ARE
TYPICALLY ACCOMPANIED BY
INCREASES STAND DEPRESSION
POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS OTHER
DISORDERS. ALONG WITH THE
INCREASES IN CHILD ABUSE AND
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. WE ALSO KNOW
YOU'RE IN THE STATE THE
CALIFORNIA- USE UNDER CERTAIN
THE MENTAL HEALTH AREA IN THE
BEST OF TIMES. NOW I'M TAKING A
LOOK AT THIS INITIAL- SPENDING
PLAN FRANKLY I DON'T SEE MUCH
IN THE WAY OF SPECIFIC MENTAL
HEALTH. FUNDING AND SO MY
QUESTION IS WHAT DO YOU PLAN TO
DO. IN THIS AREA. THANK YOU
SENATOR ROSS I WILL MENTION-
ONE REFINISH THEM IT COVERS
JUST ONE PART OF YOUR QUESTION
AND THEN I'LL TURN IT OVER TO
RYAN MILLER ON OUR TEAMS WHO
COULD SPEAK MORE BROADLY I
THINK ONE CHANGE ESPECIALLY
BECAUSE OF THE UNIQUE NATURE OF
THIS CRISIS WHERE. SCHOOLS ARE
CLOSED KIDS ARE AT HOME OUR-
PEOPLE EITHER DEALING WITH ALL
DIFFERENT TYPES OF ISSUES. AND
THAT THAT THEY NEED HELP WITH
AND SO THE SURGEON GENERAL AND
GOVERNOR APPOINTED THE FIRST
EVER SURGEON GENERAL'S FOR
CALIFORNIA EIGHTEEN BURKE
TERRORISTS- HAS PUT OUT
SPECIFIC GUIDANCE AND I BELIEVE
THE GOVERNOR. THIS IN TURN THAT
YOU WORKS DEALING TRYING NOT
EXPERIENCE A- MAKING. THAT THEY
AND- TO THE BEST SCIENCE ON HOW
TO LIVE HEALTHY LIFESTYLES
GIVEN ALL THE MAN THIS ALL
AROUND US AND SO THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT THE SURGEON
GENERAL WORK. THE GOVERNOR AND
SENIOR TEAMS ARE WORKING TO GET
ALL CORNERS OF THE STATE. BUT I
WANT TO TURN IT OVER TO RIGHT
NOW OR BY MARKET. RESPONSE
SENATOR AGAIN RYAN MILLER FROM
THE DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE- WE
ARE CURRENTLY EVALUATING
WHATEVER FEDERAL FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES ARE AVAILABLE
THROUGH THE CARES ACT ANOTHER
RECENT FEDERAL LEGISLATION
OTHER DEPARTMENT IS PLANNING TO
APPLY FOR EXAMPLE FOR SOME-
MENTAL HEALTH GRANTSAVAILABLE
THROUGH SAM SO- AND IF I CAN
TURN IT TO MY COLLEAGUE MARCO
MEACHER AGENCY HE CAN TALK
ABOUT SOME OF THE OTHER. GROUPS
THAT HAVE BEEN GOING. THANK TO
ADD YOU IT MAKES BUYING A
SURGEON GENERAL WHEN SHE
RELEASED HER. INDIVIDUALS ARE
GOING THROUGH I AM WE ALSO
GATHER A LIST OF. AVAILABLE FOR
INDIVIDUALS. IN GEN AND THOSE
ALL ARE AVAILABLE ON OUR
WEBSITE AT YOU GOT SEE A DOCTOR
OUT WE CONTINUE TO MONITOR
THOSE- THOSE LINES TO MAKE SURE
THAT THEY'RE SUFFICIENT
RECORDING HAPPY BUT YOU THE
ANSWER AND CONNECT INDIVIDUALS
SIR THAT'S VERY RESOURCES ODD
THAT THEY MIGHT BE ELIGIBLE.
FOR WITHIN THE COMMUNITY.
INDIVIDUALS MIGHT NOT BE ABLE
TO GO THE DOCTOR MINOR BUT
THERE ARE THINGS THAT CAN BE
DONE THE PHONE AND B. B. I AYE
TECHNOLOGY IN ORDER TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE ARE. TAKING CARE
OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS TO MAKE
YOU SEEN ASTRA. THE AND DEMI
AND IN THE SEARCH THAT WE'RE
ALL BEING. WELL COURSE YOU HAVE
TO BE ABLE TO FIND A PROVIDER
IN ORDER TO RECEIVE MENTAL
HEALTH. SERVICES AND GIVEN THE
SHORTAGE OF UP THE BATTLE
HEALTH PROVIDERS IN FUNDING-
CERTAINLY IN THE INLAND
PORTIONS OF THE STATE PROBABLY
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AS YOU
MOVE FORWARD AND DEALING WITH
DISCO BUT NINETEEN CRISIS IS A
CRISIS AND THERE'S A LOT DEAL
WITH I CERTAINLY ASK THAT YOU
TAKE A LOOK. AT THIS CRITICAL
AREA AND THAT IS HOW DO WE
PROVIDE MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES
FOR OUR MOST ALL POLL WELL
INDICATED CALIFORNIA AND IT WAS
MY NEEDS. IN IN. THE SCOPE AND
THEY CORRECT SO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR WRIST. SO FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH ONE ON THIS AND
OTHER IS. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
SENATOR ROTH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND THANKS TO ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES FOR YOUR QUESTIONS I
SHOULD JUST SAY TO THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE. AND
THANK YOU FOR A LIMITING YOUR
QUESTIONS EITHER- I KNOW ALL OF
YOU HAVE MANY MORE QUESTIONS AS
TO WHY IN THAT AS WE ARE
HEARING FROM. CONSTITUENTS IN
SECTOR LEADERS IN OUR DISTRICTS
AND ACROSS. THE STATE- WE WILL
ALL CONTINUE- MISTER THIS ONE
OFTEN TO YOU KNOW USE OTHER
WAYS OF COMMUNICATING OUR
QUESTIONS IN RECENT ISSUES.
ABOUT WHAT THE ADMINISTRATION.
ARE JUST TO THEIR- PURPOSES OF.
TO MAKE SURE THAT I JUST ADD TO
ISSUES THAT WILL BE FOLLOWING
UP WITH THEM ONE IS WHETHER OR
NOT THE ADMINISTRATION IS
LOOKING AT POTS IN THE MINIMUM
WAGE IN JANUARY. AS WELL AS AN
ACKNOWLEDGEMENT THAT GOVERNMENT
ALONE DOES IT ISN'T THE ONLY
ENTITY THAT PROVIDES- SUPPORT
OF THE CENTRAL SERVICES THAT'S
THE NONPROFIT SECTOR- OUR
CHURCHES ACROSS THE STATE TO DO
THE SAME TO REALLY WANTED TO
MAKE SURE. THAT WE PROVIDE
APPROPRIATE SUPPORT SO AGAIN
WILL CONTINUE TO USE ALL OF OUR
OTHER. AVENUES OF COMMUNICATING
WITH FINANCE AND ADMINISTRATION
TO CONTINUE TO RAISE- ISSUES OF
CONCERN. WITH THAT. LET ME SAY
I'M ABOUT TO RUN PASSED THE
MODERATOR TO OPEN IT UP. BUT
BEFORE WE START WITH PUBLIC
COMMENT I WANT TO ADVISE ALL
THE CALLERS TO TURN THE VOLUME
DOWN OR OFF ON ALL OF YOUR
ELECTRONIC DEVICES SUCH AS YOUR
COMPUTER TO YOUR IPAD. THIS
WILL HELP THAT LIMITING
FEEDBACK OR OTHER DISRUPTION
DURING THE CALLS. MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE GIVE ME THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF PEOPLE ARE WAITING TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY. YEAH LET ME
CHECK FOR YOU HERE JUST A
MOMENT. OUT SO FAR WE HAVE NINE
PEOPLE QUEUED UP- I HAVE NOT
GIVEN INSTRUCTIONS YET TO THEM
BUT RIGHT NOW WE DO HAVE NINE
PEOPLE QUEUED UP OKAY IF YOU
WOULD GO AHEAD AND GIVE THEM
INSTRUCTIONS MODERATOR- ON AND
IF YOU OPEN THE LINES THAT
ANNOUNCED EACH CALLER
INDIVIDUALLY WHILE SHE'S DOING
THAT I'LL REMIND THE MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC IN THE HEARING ROOM.
ONLY YOU BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY IS VIA CELLPHONE
EXCELLENT THANK YOU. AND AS A
REMINDER IF YOU DO HAVE PUBLIC
COMMENTS YOU MAY PRESS ONE DâN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD
IF YOU WANT TO WITHDRAW YOUR
QUESTION AT ANYTIME YOU CAN DO
THAT BY REPEATING THE ONE ZERO
COMMAND. IF YOU ARE USING A
SPEAKER PHONE PLEASE PICK UP
THE HANDSET BEFORE PRESSING THE
NUMBERS AND AS A REMINDER THE
ONE ZERO WORKS LIKE A TOGGLE IF
YOU PRESS IT THE SECOND TIME IT
WILL REMOVE YOU FROM THE QUEUE
SO AGAIN IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
GET INTO THE QUESTION QUEUE YOU
WOULD PRESS ONE. ZERO ON THE
TELEPHONE KEY PAD I WE DO HAVE
A RIGHT NOW APPROXIMATELY TEN A
LINE IN THE QUEUE LET ME START
WITH DANIEL LARSSON FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT ARE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
ALL. IN ORDER. THE LIGHTS. THE
WOMEN'S OPEN PLEASE. ALL. FOR
TO THE- FOR FOUR. THE WHITE. I.
ONE SEVEN FIVE. HELLO THERE THE
THIRTY. AND THE END WITHOUT.
WHAT THE **** IN. FACT LIKE
WHAT PUBLIC GROUP. TOTAL THE
PROBLEM COULD BE GOOD FOR WITH
THE ELECTION ACT. THE END OF
GOVERNMENT. SHOULD BE UNDER.
WHO PROVIDED CLEAR CONVINCING
EVIDENCE BUT THE GOOD. WITH
LABOR. MICHAEL TO THE COMMUNITY.
THE WHAT CAN. THESE CONSIDER
THE BILL OF. FOR THE- NOT OF
THE- WHAT PLANS WILL BE WITH
THE COMMITTEE. THE LORD
CONSTRUED. ONE MILLION DOLLARS
WHAT THE DETAINED IN WHAT IT'S
COLD COLD BUT. I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE FOR THEIR CA I WANT
THIS CLEAR FIVE THIS IS COM
YOU'RE OUT TO PROVIDE US WITH
AN FOR US TO TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION DURING OUR
QUESTION ARE ANSWERED DURING
THIS POINT IN TIME SECONDLY I'D
JUST LIKE TO CLARIFY THAT- ALL
THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
SHOULD TURN OFF THEIR OTHER
DEVICES YOU USE YOUR HAND HELD
UNIT SO WE DON'T GET THE KIND
OF STATIC WE GOT FROM THE LAST
CALLER THAT WAS NOT ON OUR END
OR EIGHTEEN TEAS AND THAT WAS
ON THE CALLERS IN. SEOUL HELP
US YOU BUY YOU SURE THAT YOU
WERE SPEAKING DIRECTLY INTO
YOUR HAND HELD UNIT TO INCREASE
THE LIKELIHOOD THAT WE'LL BE
ABLE TO HEAR YOU CLEARLY I'M
ALSO GOING TO ASK THAT EACH
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC LIMIT
THEIR COMMENTS TO ONE MINUTE
THAT IS CUSTOMARY AS I CHAIR
BUDGET COMMITTEE I'M GOING TO
ASK YOU TO LIMIT YOUR COMMENTS
TO ONE MINUTE. MODERATOR IF YOU
TO PLEASE OPEN THE LINE TO THE
NEXT CALLER THANK YOU. YEAH
THANK YOU HELLO MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS CANYON MARTIN
ON BEHALF OF EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA. ON WITH WITH A
THANKS FOR TODAY'S REVIEW OF
THE INITIAL SPENDING AND WE
JUST URGE THAT AS WE NEED TO
MOVE INTO THE NEXT PHASES OF
RELIEF AFTER. THAT THERE BE A
CONSIDERATION OPPOSITIONAL
RESOURCES TO REACH OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES
INCLUDING. TARGETED SUPPORT FOR
THE LGBTQ PLUS COMMUNITY WHICH%
IS THE PROPORTIONATELY AT RISK
OF THE WORKING MEDICAL
FINANCIAL AND SOCIAL IMPACT OF
THE NINETEEN. AND I WIDELY
RECORDED AND MENTION LOCAL TIME
TODAY. FEDERAL DOLLARS HAVE
BEEN SLOW AND INSUFFICIENT. AND
PLAGUED BY DYSFUNCTION
UNCERTAINTY AND INEQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION AS THE STATE DOES
RECEIVING ALLOCATE FUNDING WE
JUST URGED. IMMEDIATE TARGETED
FUNDING FOR LGBTQ PEOPLE. AND
NONPROFIT THANK YOU AGAIN.
THANK YOU NEXT MONTH MY NECKS
QUESTION. THANK YOU A I'M SORRY
I WERE NOT PICKING UP THE
SPEAKER CLEARLY IT SOUNDS WITH
THE MICROPHONE MAY BE TURNED
LOW BUT I'LL GO ON TO OUR NEXT
QUESTION. OF OUR A COMMENT THAT
IS FROM THE LINE OF ELLIS
KESSLER THE LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU- HOPEFULLY YOU CAN HEAR ME-
THANKS MADAM CHAIR AND SENATORS
ALICE KESSLER I'M NOT BITING
COMMENT ON BEHALF OF THE DELTA
ADMINISTRATORS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. WHICH IS THE OF THE
CREATION OF ALL THE SPECIAL
EDUCATION LOCAL PLAN AREAS- WE
JUST WANTED THE COMMITTEE TO BE
AWARE THAT WE- CANNOT THE READY
TO WORK WITH THE LEGISLATURE
AND THE ADMINISTRATION ON SOME
OF THE- SPECIFIC CHALLENGES
WERE SEEING. WHAT THE COVERT
NINETEEN CRISIS AND PROVISION
OF. SPECIAL EDUCATION SERVICES-
WHICH HAS BEEN EXACERBATED BY
THE DIGITAL DIVIDE WORKFORCE
SHORTAGES AND INTERPLAY WITH
WITH FEDERAL LAW. WE HAVE
SUBMITTED. WRITTEN COMMENTS TO
THE COMMITTEE WITH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS. OF THE VERY
MUCH. VERY GREATER BOB PLEASE
OPEN IT UP THE NEXT THE LAST
TWO CALLERS ARE VERY CLEAR
CONTINUE TO SPEAK DIRECTLY INTO
YOUR HAND YOUR PHONE YOUR YOUR
ACTUAL HAND HELD UNIT. NEXT
QUESTION WONDERING IF- ON IF
YOU MIGHT WANT TO CHANGE
MICROPHONE BECAUSE YOUR SOUND
ISN'T COMING THROUGH REAL CLEAR.
OKAY THANK YOU I WILL NEXT
MEMBER THE PUBLIC ALARM HOW
MADRE LINE IS OPEN. YES I THERE
ARE THREE TWO MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE
MONEY TO COME OUT ON THE
MINIMUM. AT THE ASIAN LAW
CAUCUS AND YOU'RE REPRESENTING
FEED MILL P. D. IN CALIFORNIA
COALITION WE WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE WHO IS WORKING ON IT
CAPITAL AND THROUGHOUT THE
STATE TO RESPOND TO THE CRISIS
WE ALSO WANT TO RECOGNIZE THE
CRITICAL ROLE THE STATE
AGENCIES LIKE HELLO YES PLAY
OUR STATE RESPONSE OF IT.
HOWEVER IN THIS MOMENT INCREASE
COMMUNITY CONCERNS AROUND
GOVERNMENT OVER REACH INCREASE
SURVEILLANCE DATA IT'S AN
INCREASE UNNECESSARY A RELIEF
FOR DEEPLY CONCERNED ABOUT
CALIFORNIA. ON COOPERATIVE WITH
FEDERAL ARTICLE. NINE THIRTY.
OPERATION ELEMENT IT ON
APPROACH LIKE HE- EVERY
COMMUNITY BOTH OF WHICH ARE. ON
AND FBI. COUNTERING IN THE PRO.
IS PRO. HELLO YEAH. COLLABORATE
WITH THE AGE OF ARE DEEPLY
CONCERNING. AND WE ARE WHERE
THE AGAINST. AIDS VALUE.
THEREFORE MAKE. SUBCOMMITTEE
TWO ONE PREVENT STATE FUNDING
FROM GO TO TELL THE AT ET YOUR
CREDIT SEPARATE CAN PROGRAM. TO
REQUIRE THAT AT NOT YOUTH ANY
STATE CREATED PROVIDED THE
STATE FIND ENOUGH THESE PRO. AT
THE REALITY THEM FOR ALL
EMERGENCY RELIEF AND THREE ON
THE GOVERNOR AND THE DEFENSE.
HELLO YES PP INCREASE. AROUND
ON BEHALF OF THE NORTH
COALITION THANK YOU FOR YOUR
WORK AND FOR YOUR TIME AND FOR
ALL THE WORK. THAT YOU DO ON
BEHALF OF ALL CALIFORNIANS.
THANK YOU NECK WHAT. IT THE
FOUND- HAS IMPROVED LET'S GO TO
GIVE AREA TO MILK THE LINE IS
OPEN. HI THANK YOU- MY NAME
INTO VERY EDGY MAIL AND I AM
BUT ALSO WITH THE ASIAN LAW
CAUCUS- I WANT TO THANK SENATOR
MITCHELL FOR HOLDING THIS
IMPORTANT HEARING AND MEMBERS
AND STAFF OF THE STATE
GOVERNMENT FOR THAT I LIVE. IN
RESPONSE TO THE HOUSE. I READ
I'LL BE MORE THAN FOR THAT YOU
AS THE NEED INVOLVED AT THE
TIME THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT CAN
AND HAS IN THE PAST USED EXPAND
HOURS TO TARGET A FOR THE
CANNELLA LARGE AND I MAKE AND
RELIGIOUS ANYWHERE MEMBER HOW
JOHNNY GENERAL WITH BARR HIS
PREVIOUS TENURE IN THE NINETEEN
NINETY. EIGHT HOW QUITE.
PATIENTS MEN WOMEN AND TO THE
RAPIDLY STATES I'VE BEEN ABLE
BEING ONE TIME BAY I'M ARE SAID
TO MOMENT ACT WITH FORESIGHT
AND GOOD MEASURE THAN GOING AND
ENJOY THE KIND OF MANY AGENCIES
INCLUDING DOT. COM IN TOUCH
FEDERAL AND FOR THAT IS A GOOD
ACTORS THE LIBERTIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT BUSINESS. THANK
YOU LOCAL NEXT TO THE LINE OF-
SAMA MACADAM THE LINE IS OPEN-
PLEASE GO AHEAD WITH YOUR
COMMENT. THE REST OF THE
COMMITTEE AND STAFF MEMBERS THE
CAPITAL CREATED TO KILL NEEDING
PART OF THE SMARTPHONE IS YOUR
CALIFORNIA INCLUDING YOU KNOW
YOURSELF THAT RISK TO MAINTAIN-
THE DEMOCRATIC PROCESS IN
ENSURING THAT THE PEOPLE
CALIFORNIA REPRESENTED. MY TO
DO SO. AND I'M LOOKING AT THE
MEDICARE FOR HELP OR NOT.
SACRAMENTO VALLEY CALLED. I'M
HERE TO EIGHT. THE REQUESTED
SENATE AND THE COMMITTEE LET'S
TAKE A WHAT I. A COMPUTER YOU
CAN THE PROPOSAL PRIVATELY
SECURITY WITH A PARTICULARLY IN
TO THE TYPE PERSON FOR NOTEBOOK.
COMMUNITY AND CAL THAT MERE IN
RESPONSE BECAUSE NIGHT HE AND
YOU KNOW MY AFTER YOU KNOW THAT
I URGE YOU KNOW WHAT THE- FOR
THEM BUT ITEM COMMITTEE THAT
THE ITEMS AND- PRIORITY. YOU'RE
THE OF COMMUNITY THE COLOR AND
OTHER LARGE. FOR AND THAT THE
WORK WITH THE EXTRA RECORD ON
THE ISSUES THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU NOT WITNESS PLAY. YOU
MIGHT YOU KNOW LINE IS A- I
THINK YOU MEMBERS OF THE SENATE
BUDGET COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
WITH THE TRAIL AND THEN
CALIFORNIA QUALITY MANAGER
ASIAN AMERICANS ADVANCING
JUSTICE CALIFORNIA. WE FACE THE
PANDEMIC IT'S CLEAR THAN EVER
THAT OUR PEOPLE ARE LEAN AND
THAT WE ARE ALL IN THIS
TOGETHER THE ONLY BE AS THE
MOST VULNERABLE MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITIES. SEVEN NINETY IS
ALREADY SPREAD INSIDE JAILS
PRISONS AND DETENTION CENTER
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND THE
FISCALLY THING EVERYONE IN THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITY AT RISK
AS WELL AND UNDER CUTS OUR
EFFORTS TO THE- AND THE CREW.
NEEDS PASS NOW. IT LEADS
PROTECT ALL THE FAMILY AND
MEDICAL MONO PEOPLE FROM I
DEPEND AND- I'M ON AT. AT ITS
CORE NOW THAT COVERED MY- ON
FURTHER EXACT THE INADEQUATE
PRESENT IN OUR PUBLIC EDUCATION
SYSTEM FOR STUDENTS WHO ARE LOW
INCOME WHICH LANGUAGE LEARNERS
OR FOSTER. WE URGE THAT THE
SENATE BUDGET CAN BY ADDITIONAL
MEASURE. TO PROVIDE BROADBAND
AND HARDWARE TO RURAL AS WELL
AS HIGH POVERTY- URBAN
DISTRICTS AND TARGET FUNDING
FOR THE MOST VULNERABLE
STUDENTS IN OUR STATE TO
ADDRESS ISSUES. LIKE THAT OF
SUMMER SCHOOL. AFTER IT AND
IMMENSE HEALTH CARE AND COURSE
CREDIT. I'M SORRY TO MORE
THINGS ON ELECTIONS WE APPLAUD
THE STATE FOR COMMITTING TO
TRANSITION BECAUSE OF BY NOT
ALEX FOR EVERY VOTER BUT WE
KNOW THAT CALIFORNIA'S BLACK
WHITE NEXT LEARN LOW INCOME
DISABLED AND ENGLISH PROFICIENT
COMMUNITIES ARE LESS LIKELY
THAT THE BY NOW. AND THE SECOND
EIGHT SUPPORT VOTE. AND PROMOTE
LANGUAGE ACCESS WITH THE PUBLIC
SAFETY AND ACCESS TO THE MARKET
MY LAST PLEASE THANK GOD FOR
HIS CAN TO FINDING AND RELIEF
FOR AND TALKING IN WHO ARE INTO.
SOCIAL OUR- HELLO AT FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS PER INDIVIDUAL
THOUSAND BECAUSE THE ONLY THAT
PLAN WILL SERVE ROUGHLY A
HUNDRED. THOUSAND PEOPLE A DROP
IN THE BUCKET WHEN IT COMES TO
OUR ONE POINT SEVEN FIVE
MILLION UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS. THE ONLY HOPE THAT
A LOT MAKE SURE CAN WORK TO
EXPAND ON THE DISASTER. SIGN TO
PROVIDE ON. UNEMPLOYMENT
ACCEPTANCE TO THOSE IN YOUR
CLASS THE THING IS HARDSHIP
BECAUSE A LOT OF OUR- AND OTHER
GOVERNMENT. PROGRAMS THANK ONCE
AGAIN I'M GONNA ASK THE MEMBERS
THE- HE LIMIT YOUR CA TO ONE
MINUTE MODERATOR WILL TAKE THE
NEXT WITNESS. BUDGETARY BE-
CURRENT IN THE LINE IS OPEN. I
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AND I'M SORRY KERN IN
WITH THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
REPRESENTING ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTY. I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU
FOR THE HEARING TODAY IN THE
COURT THE COUNTY THE RECEIVED
FROM THE LEGISLATURE AND
ADMINISTRATION SINCE THE
PANDEMIC STARTED. I ALSO
APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS AS
BEEN ASKED TODAY BECAUSE IN
MANY CASES. CASES IT HIGHLIGHTS
THE WORK THE COUNTY IS YOU'RE
DEALING. COUNTY THERE ON THE
FRONT LINES RESPONDING TO THE
PANDEMIC AND CAN EITHER
PROVIDING THE CORE SERVICES ARE
KEEPING OUR COMMUNITY STATE
FROM PUBLIC HEALTH OFFICERS.
EMERGENCY OPERATIONS CENTER.
THIS IS GAIL MANAGE BEHAVIORAL.
NINE ONE ONE SERVICES TWO
CORNERS. PLEASE COUNTY SERVICES
AND COUNTY WORKLOADS ARE
INCREASING AND WE NEED TO MAKE
SURE WE HAVE THE FUNDING TO
KEEP THESE CRITICAL SERVICE ONE
PLACE. CANDY IS MUCH LIKE THE
STATE OR STATE PLANS AND
DOLLARS THAT. POINT WE WERE NOT
ON IN THE CURRENT YEAR BUT
WE'RE RESPONDING AND PARTNERING
WITH THE STATE ON A FEW
OCCASIONS TODAY YOU'VE HEARD
FROM THE ADMINISTRATION ABOUT
OUR- NEITHER. AND WE ASK THAT
THE BUDGET IS PROPOSED AND WE
USED REVENUE WHICH WE ALL
UNDERSTAND IS GOING TO HAPPEN
THAT WE WORK TOGETHER AS
PARTNERS MAKE SURE. THAT THE
FROM MY PROVIDER HAD THE
REVENUES ARE SERVICES- GOING.
THANK YOU ARE WITH THE CLIENT
THE REVENUE BECAUSE IT DIRECTLY
TIED TO OUR NINETEEN NINETY ONE
IN TWENTY ELEVEN REALIGNMENT.
THESE ARE THE ESSENTIAL FUNDS
THANK YOU FOR SERVICES IN
PLACE. TODAY HAVE HEARD A LOT
ABOUT HOMELESSNESS AND I WANT
TO EMPHASIZE THAT AND COUNTIES
ARE ENTERING INTO THESE
CONTRACTS WITH THE HOTEL MOTEL
NOT THE STATE NOT. MILLION
DOLLARS A NUMBER. BY AND
PROJECT ROOM JUST THE START TO
ADDRESS THE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
THOUSAND. PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA
COUNTY THEIR SPENDING
ADDITIONAL DOLLARS MAKE SURE
WE'RE KEEPING THESE PEOPLE
FACE. AND WITH REGARD TO
HOMELESSNESS- AND WE'RE
FIGHTING OFF IN SOME CASES
CITIES THAT ARE DEALING
COUNTIES TO PER DAY EASILY SET.
BALANCE AS THE NEW ORDER NUMBER
THE CURRENT. AND NEEDING WE
FEEL LIKE THEY'RE IN STEP CHILD
IT COMES HOMELESS. AND I WANT
TO OUT ARE INCREDIBLE AT MAY
SURE THE- POPULATION IS
BASICALLY MOVED OFF THE STREET
AND INTO GETTING THE SERVICE
THEN AND THEY NEED AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT COUNTIES AND
THE STATE ARE IN THE SAME BOAT
AS SPENDING MORE MONEY BUTTHERE ARE YEAR BUT LIKE FIND
OUR THAT IS OFFERING A- AND YET.
STRONGLY TO ENSURE CAL COMES OF
THIS PANDEMIC STRONGER EVER. I
JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THE
UP. AND I KNOW IF WE WORK
TOGETHER ABOUT HOW TO ENSURE
SERVICES IN MANAGING THE SHORT
SHORTFALL THROUGH CREATIVE
THINKING WE CAN KEEP. BEATING
COUNTY IS MOVING FORWARD. THANK
YOU THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS IS
MODERATOR. WE GO TO SERRA
BRANCH YOUR LINE IS OPEN. THANK
YOU THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS FOR HELPING THIS
IMPORTANT HEARING AT THEIR
BRIDGE ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICT. I WOULD
LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT THE COMMENTS
MADE EARLIER BY SENATOR CAFIERO.
REITERATE THE FINANCIAL
CHALLENGES THE HOSPITALS AND
CLINICS ACROSS THE STATE BUT
ESPECIALLY IN RURAL AREAS ARE
EXPERIENCING. IT YOU CAN BE
SURE AVERAGE JUST CARE
ADDITIONAL FEDERAL FOR HEALTH
SYSTEM. ORIGINAL TO CONTINUE
WITH. IN MIND THAT THE THREAT
TO IN OUR HOSPITAL CLINICS
GOVERNOR FACILITY HAVE AND
CONTINUE TO UNDER. AS THEY WORK
TO PROTECT AND BURGER KING. WE
LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH THE
LETTER. CREATION HI. THE RESULT
GOING FORWARD THANK YOU AGAIN
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY CALM. THANK
YOU NEXT TO IT. THANK YOU WE GO
TO LAW THE LINE IS OLD. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR OF THE MEMBERS
AND MODERATORS WHEN THE COUPLE
NURSES. NATIONAL NURSES NINETY
BILLION OVER A HUNDRED THOUSAND
NURSES PROVIDING DIRECT PATIENT
CARE WE APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COMMENT
PARTICULAR LIKE TO COMMENT
ABOUT OUR CONCERNS REGARDING P.
PIECE OF PIE SB. CONTAMINATION
PARTNERS WANT TO BE A TO DO
THEIR JOBS BUT THEY NEED THE
PROPER PROTECTION EQUIPMENT AND
TRAINING TO DO IT SAFELY IN THE
FACE OF AN INFECTIOUS DISEASE
PANDEMIC. NURSES ARE COMPETENT
CAN HELP STOP THE SPREAD OF CO
IN NINETEEN BUT THEY NEED TO
HAVE THE RIGHT PROTECTION THING
TO STAY HEALTHY AND NEED TO
RIGHTS BASKING IN THE TOOLS TO
DO THEIR JOBS AND PROTECT THE
PUBLIC. WE UNDERSTOOD FORTY
POINT FIVE NINETY FIVE RIGHT.
DISTRICT OF. WE STATE COMMITTED
FIFTEEN SIR CALIFORNIA NOT.
EIGHT PROTECT OUR NURSES AND
OTHER FRONT LINE HEALTHCARE
WERE. BUT WE- REPORT YOU THAT
ARE HAVE SEEN THE EMPIRE. THAT
THIS DISTRIBUTION IN THEIR UNIT.
IN MANY CASES. HAVE LOCKED UP
OR RATIONED IN NINETY A
RESPIRATOR. LEAVING OUR NURSES
ON. IN SOME CASES NURSES HAVE
BEEN DISCIPLINED FOR BRINGING
THEIR OWN PP. ORCHID MAN AND
THAT APPROPRIATE PP BE PROVIDED
WHEN TREATING COPING NINETEEN
POSITIVE PATIENT WE HAVE ALSO
ABOUT CHAIN ISSUES INCLUDING A
LACK OF CLARITY ABOUT WHERE THE
FORTY ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
RESPIRATORS HAVE BEEN
DISTRIBUTED- DESPITE. ORDER AND
THIRTY EIGHT TWENTY WHICH
PRIORITIZE PP FOR THE
HEALTHCARE PURPOSE- PROVIDERS
PROVIDING CARE TO THE SICKEST
PATIENTS. WE WOULD ENCOURAGE
YOU TO PLEASE AND THE
INFORMATION BUT IT IS AT THE
TOP AS POSSIBLE INCLUDING
FACILITY LEVEL INFORMATION.
GIVEN THE SPENDING COMMITMENTS
FOR P. P. THE NEED HEALTHCARE
WORKER. AND OTHERS HAVE THIS WE
ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT THE STATE
IS PLAYING TO TRANSPORT YOU
CONTAMINATE AND RE ISSUE AND
NINETY FIVE RESPIRATORS USING
THE- BUT HELD THE
DECONTAMINATION SYSTEM. WHICH
IS A VERY HIGH IN PEROXIDE
SYSTEM WE HAVE SIGNIFICANT
CONCERNS ABOUT- ABOUT THE
CONTAMINATION. THE BILL REST
FOR LIKE THE IN AND- IN A- THAT
YOU HAVE ABOUT THIS TECHNOLOGY
IN THE G. G. J. L. PC LETTER TO
ADMINISTRATION. OUR RESEARCH
HAS FOUND THAT THERE'S NO SAFE
WAY TO THE CAN AND
DECONTAMINATE A MASK OR
RESPIRATOR BETWEEN USES. WE
MUST HAVE WHEN YOU'RE NOT IN
NINETY PRESIDENT AVAILABLE WHY
DIDN'T THE STATE TURN TO PP
DESIGNED TO BE REUSABLE AND
DECONTAMINATED SAFELY LIKE
POWER. YEAH BUT LEFT TO MERRICK
RESPIRATORS ALSO APPEARS AT THE
TWO HUNDRED MILLION RESPIRATORY
RISEN MATH COMING TO CALIFORNIA
WILL BE NEW AND NOT REVIEWS.
BECAUSE YOU CAN IN NINETY FIVE
IS NOT ENTIRELY CLEAR AND WE
WOULD ASK FOR CLEAR. TO YOU ON
THAT POINT. PROP AND THERE
GOING TO BATTLE WE THE PROPER
WE APPRECIATE COMMITTEE TO
CONCERN BRING CHAU HEALTHCARE
AND PROBLEMS INTO WORKERS ARE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONCERN OF
THESE COMMENTS. THANK YOU FOR
PROVIDING THEM I'M GOING TO
ASK. THE WITNESSES TO ONCE
AGAIN PLEASE RESTRICT YOUR
COMMENTS TO ONE MINUTE. IF YOU
HAVE WRITTEN TESTIMONY YOU CAN
ABSOLUTELY SEND IT IN TO THE
SENATE BUDGET COMMITTEE WHICH
IS OUR CUSTOM MERRY PATTERN AND
PRACTICE. AGAIN IF YOU WOULD
RESTRICT YOUR COMMENTS TO ONE
MINUTE IF YOU EVER WRITTEN
TESTIMONY YOU CAN MAIL IT IN.
MY NEXT WITNESS PLEASE ONE
MINUTE. CONSUMERS MAKE IN THE
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MEGAN BURKE ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA HEALTH PLUS
ADVOCATES REPRESENTING MORE
THAN THIRTEEN HUNDRED COMMUNITY
HEALTH CENTERS IN CALIFORNIA TO
PROVIDE CARE TO SEVEN POINT TWO
MILLION PEOPLE THANK YOU FOR
HOLDING THIS HEARING A VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE
CONVERSATION EARLIER ON THE
IMPACT OF PRIMARY CARE WANT TO
BRIEFLY TOUCH ON THE IMPACT
THAT PERFECTLY. TO PRIMARY CARE
HEALTH CENTER DURING THE PUBLIC
HEALTH EMERGENCY HEALTH CENTERS
ARE PROVIDING TRIAGE TESTING
TREATMENT REFERRALS AND WORKING
IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENT ON AVERAGE
HEALTH THAN ANY OTHER THING A
DROP IN PRIMARY CARE VISITS
ABOUT ABOUT ABOUT 50% AND 90%
REDUCTION DENTAL ENCOUNTERS.
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH CENTERS ON
AVERAGE TAKE TODAY I THINK
EITHER GENERATE ABOUT SIX
HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION
DOLLARS A MONTH THROUGH PATIENT
ENCOUNTERS PRE AND THANK.
PRIMARY CARE. THANK I COMPLETE
CLOSE OF DEBT OVER IN A MONTHLY
FOR CRAP ABOUT LEAST THREE AND
MILLION DOLLARS A MONTH NINETY
TO SO WE TO DATE WE ARE OF
HUNDRED HEALTH CENTER SITE
BETTER TEMPORE BECAUSE IN OVER
EIGHTY HOW CENTER BETTER
REPORTING FOR LOAD OR LAY OUT
AND WE DO NOT WANT THESE
CLOSURES TO BE PERMANENT THE
LEGISLATIVE LEADERSHIP AND
ADMINISTRATION THE GENTLE OUT
HEALTH CENTERS. PER TELEPHONIC
CARE AND LIVE PICTURES ON HOW
HELP BUSINESS HAS MADE AN
IMMEDIATE POSITIVE IMPACT FOR
MANY HEALTH CENTER AND WE MUST
ENSURE THAT THESE TYPE SO THAT
THEY CAN CONTINUE ON PP I
DECLINED TO SAY THAT HE NEEDS
AND HELP IN ORDER. TO THE-
OKAY. I'LL NINETY I'M- FROM
ADDRESS RELEASE NATIONAL DAY
THE ONLY THIRTY PER HELP AND
REPORT ADEQUATE PP SUPPLY FOR
THE NEXT WEEK. YOU SHORTAGES
ARE LIMITING ABILITY AFFECTED
AND SAFELY. TRIAGE AND FOR
PATIENTS AND AS YOU OVER TO THE
AT AND- WE ASK THE CONSIDER
THERE WILL BE FUNDS AND- HEALTH
CENTERS AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH IN YOUR- I THINK
MOVE FORWARD YOU. THANK YOU
KNOW WOULD. ONE MINUTE PLEASE.
EMILY YOUR LINE OF. MADAM CHAIR
AND SENATORS HELLO GIVES THE
ANGELES COUNTY AND OF SCHOOLS.
ONE OF THE. SENATOR MCCONNELL I
WILL. THREE YOU HAVE RENTERS
AND FIVE AT THE ONE OF THE
HIGHLIGHTS POPULAR. ONE OF THEM
BEING ON THE CONSIDERING ISSUE
WE HAVE MADE A REQUEST FORM
SUPPORT FOR CAL HELLO CONNECT
FUNDS. YOU RAISE DISCOUNT
PROGRAM THE HOME OF SCHOOLS
HOME DIVIDE AND WIRELESS ROUTER
TO SUPPORT A FAMILY IN PART
CANNOT PROVIDE DIGITAL ARE
INTERNET ACCESS FOR THEM. ALSO
OF THANK YOU THE OF AND ONCE.
WHICH ME SERVICE MAINTAINING
SERVICE DOWN. THANK YOU FOR
THAT AND LASTLY ARMED WITH A
FOUR TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
WHAT SEVERITY FOR PAT. IF YOU
CAN LOOK PLANS NOT REALLY FROM
COSTS INCREASES. ON CERTAIN
FISCAL FUTURE YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR. MITCHELL ON MEDICARE
AND SENATORS AND THE ROCK YEAH.
THANK YOU ARE BEFORE WE MOVE TO
THE WITNESS LET ME JUST SAY NO
ONE HAS HIT THE ONE MINUTE MARK.
PAUL ALL BEEN INTEREST UP TO
THIS POINT BUT- NOW I WILL JUST
I'M GOING TO TELL YOU IT'S TIME
TO GET ASKED TO CUT YOU OFF. SB
IT'S OUT OF RESPECT TO THE
PEOPLE ARE BEHIND YOU IN Q. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE THIRTY ONE
PEOPLE ON THE QUEUE AND SO I'M
GOING TO STOP YOU AT ONE
MINUTE. AGAIN YOU CAN. NAIL IN
YOUR WRITTEN TESTIMONY TO THE
SENATE BUDGET COMMITTEE AND IT
WILL BE DISTRIBUTED TO EVERY
MEMBER. SO WITH THAT. I'M GONNA
HAVE FAITH THAT THE NEXT CALLER
IS GOING TO STICK TO ONE MINUTE
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINE. YOUR NEXT GOAL KEY JANET
AND NELSON PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU WELL DONE NOTHING
NOTHING WITH COMMUNITY WATER
CENTER LINE COMMUNITY FORMER
HER COMMUNITIES NEED URGENT
ACTION HERE ACT THAT THE WATER
IN THE HOME NOW WHEN IN THE-COMING MONTHS BOTH FOR THEIR
HEALTH AND OUT THE STATE.
MEDICAL NINETEEN WE DO APPLY
THE GOVERNOR THIRTY TAKEN THAT
APRIL SECOND EXECUTIVE ORDER
THAT REQUIRES WATER WE
CONNECTION FOR ANYONE WITH
BLOCKS WATER BEGINNING MARCH
FOR THAT PROTECT AGAINST FUTURE
WATER SHUT. WATER THROUGH A
STRONG AND COUPLE ACTION DILLON
INCLUDING MAKING THAT ANYONE
WHO HAD THE WATER SHUT OFF
MARCH. ACTED CRAFTING IN THE
SHELTER PLACE AND COULD PREPARE
TO FINANCE PLEASE AND THE COME
MONTHS BOTH THE WATER SYSTEM
AND THE LOW INCOME IN MEDIA
UNABLE TO YOU BILLS FOR A LONG
AND ONLY LIKE THAT THE SENATE
CAN AND PROTECTION FROM LATE
TEENS AND COLLECTION PLEASE FOR
THE WORKING ON THE URGENT ISSUE
THANK YOU CARE THANK YOU.
CALLER IRAQ'S. CARMEL COME FROM
AND RIVERA PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON KEREN MEMBERS MY
NAME IS ANDREA RIVERA
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA AND
THAT POLICY CENTER I'D LIKE TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
ON CALLED THE NINETEEN RESPOND
ON BEHALF OF COMMUNITIES OF
COLOR STATE. CRITICAL THAT WE
CAN BUILD ON THE MOMENTUM AND
ENSURE THE PUBLIC FIFTY OF ALL
CALIFORNIANS. CONVEYED BY
EIGHTEEN OF THE PANDEMIC THAT
REQUIRES EXTRAORDINARY RESPONSE
IN ORDER TO MITIGATE THE
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON
COMMUNITIES. CALIFORNIA THE
EXERCISE EVERY OPPORTUNITY
POSSIBLE TO REDUCE POPULATIONS
AND IN DETENTION FACILITY
ESPECIALLY GIVEN THE RECORDED
INCREASE AND COLLEAGUES
NINETEEN CASE. COMBINED WITH
THE LACK OF PROPER PRECAUTIONS
FROM FEDERAL IMMIGRATION
AUTHORITIES. I CURRENTLY
ESTIMATED THERE'S A TOTAL OF
ONE HUNDRED AND TEN CONFIRMED
CASES IN DETENTION FACILITIES
AND THEY RESPONDED BY OPTING TO
LOCK ALL DETAINEES AND FAILS
FELL BUT UP TO TWENTY THREE
HOURS EACH DAY. OKAY I THINK
AREAS. STATION LEADER OF THE
NATION IN THE AFTER AND MANY
OPERATIONS COULD LEAD TO THE
CONFINEMENT OF INDIVIDUALS AND
THEREFORE WITH THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF EMPLOYEES AND KATIE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS. MOORLACH GOAL TO
MARK. MOLSON PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MARK YOUR LINE IS OPEN YOU MAY
BE NEEDED. HELLO YOU MAY NOW.
YES YOU HAVE ONE MINUTE MY MARK
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUT LIVING NETWORK
CHAIR OF THE PASSPORT THANK YOU
I WANT TO READ YOU HAVE A
POPULATIONS THAT HAVE BEEN
TALKED ABOUT. HEARING THE
PEOPLE THE BILL ON INFLUX
DEVELOPMENT NOBODY'S LISTENING
INDEPENDENTLY OWNED FAMILIES.
OF ISOLATED AND IS EVEN FURTHER
ISOLATED NOW. WHO ARE BOTH
MEDICALLY FRAGILE IN THE
COMPLEX MEDICAL HE COULD ONLY.
IN FURTHER HIT BY DESIGN
BECAUSE WE VALUE CAN. AND ARE
COMMITTED I THINK THAT ARE THIS
OF THE OFFENSE DIRECT
PROFESSIONAL PROVIDE THE
OFFENSE SERVICES. THEY ARE
AMONG THE HEROES OF MINE DIDN'T
PAY FOR THE SPEND DOWN AT.
PROVIDERS SUPPORTED LIVING
LIVING ARE. AT THAT OVER TO THE
CO BUT NINETY. TROUBLING HEREBY
LIFESAVING PROTECT EQUIPMENT
AND NINE THE CLASS THE CLIENT
BACK. I GREW UP IN NINETY I
THINK HE SAID YOU CAN CLEARLY
THAT WOULD ACTIVATE AND YET BUT
LOOK ARE THE CARD PPP EVEN OPEN
NIGHT FIVE CRIPPLING SERVICE
PROVIDERS I THE WENT TO A
PERCENT ADDITION FEDERAL. AND
THAT ALREADY POINT EIGHT
BILLION UNDERFUNDED OTHER ANY
PLANS THE STATE PROVIDE
EMERGENCY FUNDING TO THE OF
SERVICES FUND COMMUNITY
PROVIDERS OVER NINE P. P. AND
CORPORATE NINE THE PRICE YOU
EXCEEDED YOUR TIME WHEN YOU
PLACE A MAILING TEST. EIGHT YOU
THANK YOU. NEXT WE PLEASE ONE
INUTE THANK YOU. MODERATOR
WILL TAKE THE NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. MICHELLE KEVIN YOUR
LINE IS NOW OPEN. THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON MICHELLE GIVEN
WITH THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVE ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA THAT LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS AND ONE THING IT
CUT THE NINETEEN IS
DEMONSTRATED IS WHAT WE'VE
ALREADY KNOWLEDGE IS WHEN
THERE'S NOT THE RESOURCES
INVESTED MANY OTHER IN PUBLIC
HEALTH MANY FACTORS ARE
ADVERSELY IMPACTED I WE MUST
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE BY PROVIDING
LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT THE
OPENING NOW. CAN YOU. PLEASE I
ON OUR ABILITY TO CON COMBAT
CONTACT KATIE AND I. WHAT THE
COURT HEALTH ROLE IN EITHER A
TECHNOLOGY AND- SUPPLEMENTING
EFFORT WE STILL IN THE LONG
TERM CAPACITY LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENT. TO ENSURE
ADEQUATELY RESOURCE AND AGAINST
YOU KNOW KOBE NINETEEN PEOPLE
TO PARTICULAR. OR FEATURE
PUBLIC HEALTH THREAT. WE
RECOGNIZE THE STATE'S FISCAL
CONSTRAINTS RIGHT NOW THAT THAT
OUR THAT ONE FACING HOWEVER. WE
BELIEVE THE VIABILITY OF OUR
ECONOMY IN THE COMMUNITIES WE
SERVE DEPEND. ON THE WORK OF
ART. RESPECTFULLY WERE THAT
ADMIN. AND LET. SIGNIFICANT
RESEARCH HUMBLE AMERICA TO DO
THAT THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT-
WITNESS PLEASE MODERATOR. NEXT
CALL TO MY AREA AND GRAMM
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY ANGER BUT
THE ACLU CALIFORNIA WE
APPRECIATE THE DISCUSSION OF
GIVING FUNDING TO LOCALITIES
THE SHELTER AND HOUSE RESIDENTS
BUT AS THEY FAILED TO MOVE
PEOPLE QUICKLY AND THE HOTELS
AND MOTELS WE'VE SEEN A STEADY
OUTBREAK THE GROUP'S SHELTERS.
IN SAN FRANCISCO NINETY ONE
PEOPLE BECAUSE POSITIVE SHELTER
AMENDED A DETAILED LIST OF
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT- CLASS
BUT SHARE THE STORY OF A
RESIDENT FROM ORANGE COUNTY WHO
IS IN A CROWDED SHELTER OVER
TWO HUNDRED PEOPLE THAT CLEARLY
LAST SPOKE WATER. PAPER TOWELS
A MAN AND THAT IS SO HE DIED IN
HIS BED BUT KNOWS THAT HE HAD
CALLED THE NINETEEN THERE BEEN
TRADE THE PREMISE FOR A WEEK
NOW BUT STAFF AS THEY WILL BE.
IN SEAT. AN OFFER. HOST ROOM
DESPITE THE LIMB PUBLIC THREAT
THE FACILITY I'LL- AS MEMBERS
OF THE DEBT FREE JUSTICE
COALITION WE THE POOR REQUIRE.
FOR COLLECTION OF GOVERNMENT
THAT. GIVEN THE- FIVE AT THIS
TIME. AND AS CO THE NINETEENTH
SPREAD THIRD STATE PRISONS WE
ARE THERE'S STATE TO EXPAND ITS
RELEASE PROTOCOLS AND RELEASED
MEDICALLY VULNERABLE PEOPLE
FROM PRISON THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE MODERATOR.
ONE OF OUR NEXT CAT DEEP.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE BURKE WITH
THE HOPE OF THE THIRD THE THIRD
SEASON OF CALIFORNIA THANKS FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY UNLIMITED
EVERYTHING MY COLLEAGUES CHAVEZ
AND I WANT TO THANK SENATOR PAN
FOR HIS QUESTIONS ABOUT CONTACT
TRACING ON CONTACT. HAS SPENT
EVERY DAY EVEN BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC AND ESPECIALLY. SINCE
BY LOCAL HEALTH DEPARTMENT. A
LOT OF TALK ABOUT AT AND HOW
THEY MIGHT HELP BUT RELYING ON
ASK FOR CONTACT RETHINK IT'S
KIND OF LIKE RELYING ON YOUR
POWER POINT SOCCER CAN MAKE A
CONSULTATION FOR YOU. HE ONLY
PEOPLE IN TRAIN PUBLIC HEALTH
WORKERS ON THE OTHER END OF
THAT HAPPENED- LOCAL ABOUT A
THIRD OF THEM OF THE HEALTH
DEPARTMENT HERE DURING THE
FIGHT TO WORK EVERY DAY- BUT
OUR EMERGENCY UP. CENTERS HAVE
ABOUT THE SAME AMOUNT OF
RESOURCES THAT THAT A MONTH
AGO. FORWARD TO WORKING WITH SO
THAT WE CAN HAVE MORE THANK YOU
AS A HEALTHY. THANK YOU SAME TO
YOU. NEXT WITNESS MODERATOR. WE
HAVE A NOT SO LINE OF RUN RAP.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS RON RAP
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS FIRST
LET'S SEE IF HE WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE GOVERNOR OF THE
LEGISLATURE FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
DURING THE CUP IN NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. OUR NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY IS TO PROTECT OUR
STUDENTS AND EDUCATIONAL POISON
TO ENSURE THAT WE CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE A HIGH QUALITY
EDUCATION. HE WILL SUBMIT A
DETAILED LETTER TO THE GOVERNOR
AND THE LEGISLATURE THE NEXT
FEW DAYS THAT OUTLINES THEIR
SPECIFIC BUDGET RECOMMENDATIONS
IN THE CONTEXT OF THE CLUB IN
NINETEEN PANDEMIC A HIGHLIGHT A
FEW- TODAY. FIRSTLY LET. FIRST
WE RECOMMEND THAT THE GOVERNOR
GOVERNOR AND THE LEGISLATURE
PROVIDE SCHOOL DISTRICTS WITH
AT MINIMUM. THE LEVEL OF
FUNDING THEY RECEIVED IN TWENTY
NINETEEN TWENTY TWENTY PLUS THE
COST OF LIVING ADJUSTMENT IN
ADDITION WE RECOMMEND THAT OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES RECEIVE THE
SAME AMOUNT OF FUNDING FROM
TWENTY. TWENTY PLUS ACOSTA LIVE
AND- THAT'S NOT. SECONDLY WE
RECOMMEND THAT THE GOVERNOR AND
LEGISLATURE PROVIDED ADDITIONAL
TARGETED DOLLARS FOR SCHOOLS TO
CONTINUE TO PURSUE TO PURCHASE
PERSONAL PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT.
FIVE AND COVER LABOR COSTS
INCURRED FOR CONTINUOUSLY
SANITIZING OUR SCHOOLS. IN
ORDER TO KEEP OUR STUDENTS IN
OUR SCHOOL EMPLOYEES SAY. THIRD
HERE HE RECOMMENDS THAT
ADDITIONAL FUNDING BE PROVIDED
SO THAT ALL OF OUR STUDENTS
HAVE THE TECHNOLOGY AND
INTERNET ACCESS THEY NEED TO
LEARN FROM HOME. AND EDUCATE
THE PROFESSIONAL TO LAMENT
THANK YOU TO AFFECTED LEAKAGE
IN A DISTANCE LEARNING
ENVIRONMENT. FINALLY SEE IF HE
RECOMMENDS WITH A STATE ENSURE
THAT THAT DOLLARS PROVIDED BY
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT DO NOT
THE PLANT STATE. OR ONE. YOU
FIX YOUR TO YOU SAID YOU CAN IS
CERTAIN LETTERS WE APPRECIATE
THAT. THANK YOU. MODERATOR NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. NEXT CALL
CAROLINE OF ALYSSA SO HIGH
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS ELECTED
SO HIGH ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA DISTRICT WITH
INFORMATION IN A MINUTE BUT FOR
THIS BACK ON THE FRONT LINES OF
CODE NINETEEN RESPOND
CONTINUING TO ENSURE THE
DELIVERY OF CRITICAL LOCAL.
WATER WASTEWATER WITH TEXT
HEALTHCARE DELIVERY AND FIRST
RESPONDER AMONG OTHERS WE THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR HOLDING THIS
OVERSIGHT HEARING AND WANT TO
LET YOU KNOW THAT THAT GROW
OPERATIONAL AND ADMINISTRATIVE
CHALLENGES THE SPECIAL
DISTRICTS WITH LOW INCOME IN
NINETEEN RESPONSES ARE MANY AND
MOUNTAIN AND- READY TO WORK
WITH YOU AND THE- LISTEN.
FORWARD WE APPRECIATE SEVEN
YOUNG FOR MARK ENTERED THE
RELEASE HEALTH MARKETS ARE. THE
CAN FOR THEM. AND WE ARE
CONCERNED THAT MOST OF. PART
THE- SIGNIFICAN MAJOR. AND ALSO
WOULD LIKE TO KNOW THAT MANY OF
THE- ARE PORTANTINO'S FISCALLY.
BY THE ACT OF NINETEEN ARE THE
THING PROVIDERS BY LOOKING. FOR
IN QUITE A AND- IN A- IMPACTED
BY THE STATE CATASTROPHIC
WILDFIRES IN RECENT. EVENTS I
JUST SPOKE REFER WRITER AND
RURAL VOCAL. IN ORDER CAN YOU
CONTINUE TO BE. AGAINST THE
NEXT NOTABLE TO. DISTRICTS WILL
ACCESS TYPICAL MATTER WITH YOU
ASK THAT LOCAL GOVERNMENT OF
ALL SIZES INCLUDING SPECIAL
DISTRICTS RECEIVE AN EQUITABLE
SHARE OF FINANCIAL RELIEF
MCCORKLE THE MOST FUN NOW BEING
ALLOCATED TO THE STATE. AND THE
OTHER DOES NOT THE GLOOMY
BECOMES AVAILABLE THAT. WOULD
BE INCLUDED IN A DETERMINATION
THANK YOU THAT'S OVER ONE
MINUTE PLEASE SUBMIT IN WRITING
APPRECIATE YOU MODERATOR. NEXT
THIS. MAX AND WILL BE CARL THE
DOOR PLEASE HAD. THANK YOU
KAREN MEMBERS OF THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CARL CIGAR
FROM THE C. E. O. THE MONTEREY
SALINAS TRANSIT DISTRICT IN
MARIN COUNTY CALIFORNIA PASSED
MEDIA CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
TERMS THIS ASSOCIATION.
CALIFORNIA TRANSIT OPERATORS
ARE AT THE FRONT LINES
DELIVERING PERSONS ARE WHO ARE
DELIVERING CARE. AND OTHER
ESSENTIAL GOVERNMENT SERVICES
ARE THE RECENT FEDERAL FUNDS
THAT WE RECEIVE ARE JUST A
SMALL PART OF WHAT WE- ARE OVER
7% OF OUR FUNDS COME LOCAL
SALES TAXES. AND OTHER SOURCES
THAT ARE. DECIMATED WE WANT TO
WORK TOGETHER WITH. STATE TO
MAKE THAT ARE CASH NEEDS ARE
MET WHILE WE WAIT FOR THE
GOVERNMENT TAKES VERY LONG. I'M
NEXT SIX TO TWELVE MONTHS TO
RECEIVE THE FOR THE WHOLE WILL
BE THAT CASH. AND THAT BRINGS.
JUST A MINUTE. TRANSACTION
THANK YOU APPRECIATE THE
TRANSIT GUIDE THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS MODERATOR. A LITTLE
NEXT DOOR THE BROWN- CALL MAN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS RONALD COLMAN ON
BEHALF OF HEALTH ACCESS
CALIFORNIA WE THANK YOU ALL
VERY MUCH FOR PROVIDING PUBLIC
MECHANISM FOR ENGAGEMENT WE
SUPPORT THE CALL BY THE
LEGISLATURE AND THEN
MINISTRATION ON THE NEED FOR
MORE FEDERAL AID FOR STATE
HEALTH ACTIVE JUSTIN. THE COP.
OR ASKING FOR AT. HELP ENSURE
AFFORDABLE ASSIST. EMIGRATE
INCLUDES AN- IN. AND FEDERAL
AND ENSURING THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT COVERS ALL COST.
FROM THE STATE RELATED TO.
HERRING FROM PATIENTS FOR
TREATMENT- WE UNDERSTAND THE
DECISION HE MADE GIVEN THE GO
OUT LOOKING GIVEN THE WORKLOAD
BUDGET THAT WILL MOVE FORWARD
BUT WE ALSO BELIEVE THAT IN THE
HEALTHCARE CRISIS HEALTHCARE
INVESTMENTS MUST. OKAYGET OUT
OF THIS PANDEMIC AND BETTER
PREPARE FOR FUTURE ONE WITH
MASSIVE JOB LOSSES WILL SEE A
LOSS OF EMPLOYMENT BASED
COVERAGE THAT MEANS PEOPLE WILL
BE SHOPPING COMING. BUT WE ALSO
KNOW THAT AND WHAT AND MAKE.
GOOD NIGHT. I GO OUT MY FORTY
CHRIS WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE CAN MAKE PERMANENT THE
ABILITY SO THESE DONE LAST YEAR
AND FEDERAL OFFERED WE CAN
SUPPORT FAMILY PURCHASING OF
THAT SO THE SEVENTY FIVE
MILLION STATE FUNDING FOR THE
FUND FOR UNDOCUMENTED WORKERS
BUT WE STILL. WANT TIME I WOULD
I'M THE DAHLE SELECT CARE
COVERAGE THAT COULD BE ABLE FOR
FOOD MEDICAL IF IT WAS EXPANDED
MISTER COLEMAN THAT EXCEED YOUR
ONE MINUTE I KNOW THAT WE'LL
GET A LETTER FROM YOU THANK YOU
SO. MUCH THIS CALL HER PLEA.
BUT YEAH JOSE READ PLEASE AHEAD
HI THANKS FOR ALL THE SPACE
WHERE WE CAN TO COMMON THEY
REALLY APPRECIATE THAT- I JUST
WANTED TO POINT OUT THAT THE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL DECISION OF
APRIL SIXTH- IT ONLY PROTECT
TENANTS UP UNTIL. AND AFTER THE
THEN PEOPLE CAN. I WILL GET
EVICTED IN ORDER WORK THE COURT
EVICTION CAN CONTINUE TO MOVE
FORWARD SO WE NEED ADDITIONAL
PROTECTIONS. FOR PEOPLE WHO
CANNOT PAY- RIGHT ON TIME AND
ALSO WE NEED. URINE BUT THE
SHARDS. ARE AND- LOCKING PEOPLE
OUT OF THEIR HOUSES IN OUR
THINKING IS THERE ANY OTHER. WE
ALSO NEED TO MONITOR ANY OF THE
FUNDS THAT ARE GOING TO GOING
TO WORK WITH LIKE COUNTIES. I'M
FOR THE COLBERT NINETEEN
RESPOND BECAUSE I THINK THAT.
THERE HAVE BEEN USED IN THE
PAST AND I WHAT I WANT TO SEE
THAT HAPPENING RIGHT NOW.
QUESTION PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
THE HONDA MAKE A KNOW HOW ON.
THE THIRTEENTH FREDDY INCOME
AND ALL WE NEED TO ADDRESS THE
REGION WITH THE BIG. ISSUES
SUCH AS YOUR HOME PARK. RIGHT
GOOD PEOPLE HOW RELIABLE FOR ME
TO REACH TO THE GIRL COMMUNITY
OF THE EASTERN COACHELLA THANK
YOU SO MUCH OUR KEEP YOU ANY
LONGER THAN WE HAVE LIKE HI
LIMIT THANK YOU SO MUCH THE
SAKE. THANK YOU. FOR YOUR- MY
PLAY NEXT. ON THE GOAL TO LOSE
IN BOTH THE IT OCCURRED OUR
VERY CARTER PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH HI I AM LUCY HOSPITAL
CARTER POLICY DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
NONPROFIT. AS WITH NOTED BY THE
COMMITTEE CHAIR NONPROFITS ARE
STEPPING UP DURING THIS CRISIS
AS THEY DO IN ANY CRISIS TO
PROVIDE A SENSE SERVICES AND
OTHER VITAL PROGRAMS. NONPROFIT
CAN'T KEEP GOING UP WITH THAT
THE FIRST. WITH NEARLY ELEVEN
HUNDRED NONPROFITS. OUR LETTER
TO STATE LEADERS WE ARE
REITERATING OUR ASK THAT THE
STATE REPORT NON PROFITS BY
ENSURING THAT NONPROFIT
CONTINUE TO GET PAID ON STATE
CONTRACTS AND HAVE CONTRACTS
FLEXIBILITY TO RESPOND TO THE
CRISIS. BY ALLOCATING AGENCIES
TO ADDRESS THE INCREASED COSTS
ASSOCIATED WITH PROVIDING
UNINTERRUPTED DELIVERY OF
ESSENTIAL SERVICES AND BY
INCLUDING NONPROFIT RELIEF
PROGRAMS FOR EMPLOYERS
COMMERCIAL TENANTS. HELLO THE
RATE PAYERS. THANK YOU MITCHELL
AND THE COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE MODERATE.
WHY AS JOHNSON PLAY GO AHEAD.
GOOD EVENING MAYOR AND MEMBERS
THE COMMITTEE IS IN A JOHN WITH
JOHN BYRNE FOR YEARS AND WE ARE
PART OF A LARGER COALITION OF
CHILD WELFARE YOUTH JUSTICE AND
HOMELESS YOUTH ORGANIZATIONS-
WHERE WE OBSERVE MINUTES PAST
THE MONNING JUST WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
SO FAR. DESIGNING HOW AND
YOU'RE NOT. DONE FOR PORTION ON
YOUTH OF COLOR. OF THE BE KEY
Q. U. AND OF COURSE AT RISK OF
HOMELESS. THE ALSO LIVE WITH
UNDERLYING HEALTH CAN. AND OUR-
MORE OFTEN AND CON. CARE SAID
SUCH. HOME BECAUSE THE SHOWED
HER. OR IN JAIL JUVENILE HALL
SO WE HAVE SUBMITTED A WRITING
WE NEED TO LOOK FORWARD TO.
CONGRESO ON HOW TO PROTECT. OUR
USERS ARE FAMILY ARE CARE
GIVERS ARE PROVIDER THAT WORK
AND I. THANK THE DURING THE
TIME OF CRISIS THANK YOU FOR
MUCH THANK YOU NEXT. MODERATOR
MY GOAL. A COLA QUICKLAW. YES
GOOD EVENING MADAM CHAIR AND
SENATORS I'M RICHARD CALLIN THE
FORMER CHAIRMAN OF YOUR
HISTORIC STATE CAPITOL
COMMISSION WHICH IS EXPRESSED
GRAVE CONCERNS WITH THE
PLANNING AND DIRECTION OF THE
CAPITOL ANNEX PROJECT A GROUP I
REPRESENT TO DATE PUBLIC A OF
FOR OUR CAPITAL AS SUBMITTED
UNDER TWO YEARS SUBCOMMITTEE
STAFF. WHICH PROVIDES SAID
DETAIL ON THE GROWING PUBLIC
DISSATISFACTION WITH THE DAMAGE
TO CAPITOL PARK ASSOCIATED WITH
THE PROJECT- PLANNING TODAY WE
SIX AT YES DO YOU SUBCOMMITTEE
PLACE TO FIND BUT THE FOURTEEN
DAY. WE ASK YOU TO ASK THE
DRIVER CAN. DOOR A SUSPENSION
OF SPENDING OF THE SEVEN
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS ON THE CAPITAL PLAN
NEXT PROJECT. THIS WOULD BE A
FREE UP A SIGNIFICANT AMOUNT OF
THE MONEY YOU NEED TO HELP
CALIFORNIANS SO SEVERELY
IMPACTED BY THE VIRUS PANDEMIC.
AND WILL GIVE THE TEAM TIME TO
GET THE PLANNING RIGHT TO
INVOLVE THE PUBLIC IN THE
PROJECT PLANNING AND FIND WAYS
WE BELIEVE IT TO SAVE MULTIPLE
TENS OF. ALORS THE PROJECT. FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY SO YOU SAID
LETTER AND WILL REVIEW THEM ONE
WE GET THEM I LIKE TO ASK
FUTURE WITNESSES TO FOCUS YOUR
PUBLIC COMMENT ON THE CONTENT
PRESENTED IN TODAY'S BUDGET
HEARING THANK YOU MODERATOR
NEXT WITNESS ONE MINUTE. WE ARE
NOT CULTURAL AS GALLAGHER OLD
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
HELLO. HI DAVID LUCCA YEARBOOK
FROM CALLING ON BEHALF OF A
BUILDING LEGAL CENTER WHERE
NONPROFIT REGIONAL ORGANIZATION
HERE IN THE INLAND EMPIRE AND
COACHELLA VALLEY A BEFORE YOU
START CUTTING MY MINUTES OF MY
MINUTES A FULL DISCLOSURE WE
HAVE MEMBERS ON THE LINE
COMMUNITY MEMBERS BUT THEY HAVE
TO GET OFF BECAUSE THEY WERE
SELLING WELL IT TAKES. ALL
CUSTOMER I'M GONNA TRY TO GET
THROUGH THAT FIRST BECAUSE WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE FOR ELEVATING
DIGRESSION VOICES BUT- BEFORE
WE ARE GOING TO THAT- WE TAKE
THE BLOOD OF OUR CALIFORNIA
BORDER IT'S MEANT WITH ON THE
CURRENT. KOBE STEPPING UP IN A
COMMUNITY WE WERE ASK THAT ARE
LOOKING TO HELP OUR ELDERS AS
WE CAN SEEING OUR ELDERS IMPACT
BY IN OUR REGION AND L. THEY
DON'T HAVE ANY TO LET COVERAGE
SO HOW BROUGH L. AND ALL CAL
THE EXPANSION. OKAY AND HAVE
BEEN CUT THIS TO SOME TYPE OF
EIGHT WHAT IF I TAX AND ALSO TO
WORK WORRIED YEAH THE BETTER
HAPPENING WITHIN THAT WILL GET
HAPPEN I NOTICED DID A LOT OF
STUFF BUT REGARD THE VENTURE
BUT WE PUSHING LOCAL COULD
PAYMENT BUT OF CITIES ARE
REALLY OPERATING WE THOUGHT WE
APPRECIATE IT. ANYTHING ELSE.
YOUR CALL OVER PARKING IS NOT
GONNA UP MY TO OUR THE RENT
PAYMENT PLANS ARTICLES ARE SO
THE TESTIMONY IS FROM ONE OF
OUR MEMBERS IT'S BEEN SPANISH
SO I'M GONNA GO AHEAD AND SAY
HOW MUCH IT IS BUT- HOPEFULLY
TO BE TRANSLATED YOU CAN.
BANISHING YOU'RE GONNA ONE
MINUTE TO PROVIDE THAT
TESTIMONY THAT I'M GOING TO CUT
YOU OFF SO THANK YOU ONE MINUTE.
GO AHEAD. I'M SORRY WE LOST
THAT LINE IF YOU HAVE A COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO.
COULD WE ASK THAT WOULD MISTER
CINDY IN THE TESTIMONY FROM
PEOPLE WHO ARE NO LONGER ABLE
TO STAY ON THE LINE IT WILL GO
TO THE NEXT WITNESS ONE MINUTE
PLEASE. ON YOUR MAC GO TO A LOT
OF METALLIC AND VIçT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MOTHERLY KINCAID WITH PUBLIC
ADVOCATES REGARDING THE HIGHER
EDUCATION BUDGET WE RECOMMEND
THE LEGISLATURE REQUEST THE
PUBLIC INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION TO PRIORITIZE
TRANSPARENCY AND PROVIDE A
REPORT REGARDING HOW THEY WILL
BE SPENDING THE FEDERAL
DOLLARS. HOW THEY WILL
COLLECTION INCLUDES INPUT ON IT
NEEDS THE CRITERIA. DISTRIBUTE
DIRECT IN EIGHT STUDENTS. EVERY
IT IS ALSO PRIORITIZE
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS WITH THE
SUPPORT AND WE THOUGHT THAT
THEY NEED AND THEY ARE NOT
INCLUDED IN THE CARE OF THAT
AND FINALLY THAT THE STATE
PROVIDES SUPPORT TO CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND THE
THIRD MANY STUDENTS PART TIME
STUDENTS INCLUDING UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS AND WITH HIGH KNEE BUT
ARE NOT INCLUDED IN THE CARE
THAT. YOU THAT YOUR MITCHELL
GOT THE GOVERNOR AND ALL STAFF.
FOR TO WORKING WITH YOU ON
THESE REQUESTS THANK YOU THANK
YOU APPRECIATE IT NEXT WITNESS
ONE MINUTE. AND WE WILL NOT GO
TO LINE OF JANET TRAVELL PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ALEX ROCCO ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNITY ALLIANCE WITH FAMILY
FARMERS AND IT'S EIGHT THOUSAND
MEMBERS. ARE MOSTLY SMALL AND
MID SIZE FARMERS ACROSS THE
STATE WE APPRECIATE THE
INCLUSION OF THE AG INDUSTRY IN
THE FOOD SUPPLY IN THAT
COMMITTEE BACKGROUND. AND SOME
OF THE COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS
EARLIER. 80% OF CALIFORNIA
FARMERS ARE SMALL FARMERS
INCLUDING MANY IMMIGRANT
FARMERS THEY'RE SCRAMBLING TO
CHANGE THEIR OPERATIONS WITH
CROPS ALREADY IN THE GROUND.
THE VICTIMS OF RESTAURANT
LEADERS- AND OTHER LAW
CONTRACTS WE WOULD ENCOURAGE
YOU TO CONSIDER A FEW THINGS AS
YOU MOVE FORWARD. PUSHING
ACCOUNT THE FARM CRISIS CENTER
FOCUSED SMALL AND MID SCALE
CHRYSLER. THE COULD PROVIDE US
WITH ONE OF ONE SUPPORT BETWEEN
LOCAL STATE FEDERAL AGENCIES
AND RESOURCES. WALKING A
STATEWIDE PROCUREMENT STRATEGY
HELLO FINE CALIFORNIA BY FRESH
BY LOCAL MARKETING EFFORTS AND
HELPING HE EMERGENCY FOOD
SYSTEM IN SCHOOL TO LIVE LOCAL
FOOD THANKS FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE ONE MINUTE. ONLY
ON ACT GO TO LINE UP CAN LIVE.
YEAH HI HOMELESSNESS NUMBER OF
COLLISIONS THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THINKING I MIGHT HAVE ONE
OF THE THAT THE NEEDS THAT OUR
YOUTH THING HOMELESSNESS IS
ACTUALLY IN TERMS OF- A
RESPONSE AS- I'M AT AROUND A
HUNDRED MILLION. GOING TOWARD
PLAN. AND MAKING SURE THAT I
KNOW A LOT OF THE FUNDING OF
GOING TOWARD. AND FOCUS ON OUR
SENIOR POPULATION AND WE KNOW
THAT THERE'S NOT A- LOT I MEAN.
DON'T WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE NOT GOTTEN. THEM IN
TERMS OF WHAT A RESPONSIVE AND
CONSERVE DOLLARS DON'T HAVE THE
SAME RESTRICTIONS THAT THE
STATE HAD WHEN IT CAME TO THE
8% THAT LINE. THE REAL DANGER
THAT ARE YOU PART. IN ALL OF
THE TIME. AND I. SUCH AS TO
AND THEN IN. BECAUSE THE
DEADLINE AND THEN AND COMPLAIN
AS WELL THANK YOU FOR THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NICK WITNESS MY- AND
WE'RE MEXICO TO ERIN. HE'S
PLEASE GO AHEAD ERR NOT YEAH OF
PUBLIC TRAFFIC THE NUMBER OF
YES THAT PLAY BECAUSE- THANK
YOU CHAIRMAN TELL GOVERNOR AND
THAT WE AGREE THE LEADER OF THE-
AND THE CAR ABOUT. AND WORK
WITH AUTISTIC THANK THE PRICE.
THE CURRENT THINK THEIR
CULTURAL OUT DISTRICT TO DECIDE
THE PRIORITY AND HOW TO
IMPLEMENT WITH REGARD ANY OF
THE MOST CAUGHT. POORLY LIKELY
TO FORGET THE THING CORNER YEAH
YOU TO PROVIDE THAT A FEDERAL
RELEASED BY. I'D INCREASE
SERVICE FOR MY IMPACT COMMUNITY.
TO ADDRESS CONCERNS RAISED BY
GRASSROOTS. IF YOUR CALL THAT
NINETEEN ARE SHOULD FOCUS FOR
SCHOOLS BOARD JUNE AND FAMILIES
OF THE NEED. BUT ALSO LIKE TERM
AND ALLEGED THAT PROPOSITION I
EIGHT A MINIMUM GUARANTEE NOT A-
AND ALLEGE TO PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL FUNDING FOR OUR
SCHOOLS BEYOND THE MINIMUM
GUARANTEE OUT. OF EDUCATION BUT
IT STARTED A THING INTO THE
CRISIS LINE LAST SPRING WORLD
EXACERBATE EXISTING IF YOU MAKE
OUT AND RESULT EVEN GREATER
FINANCIAL. BE THANK. GOODNESS
WHEN I CALLED HER REBEKAH
ARTICLES THAT HAD. WHEN I
STARTED NUMBER IS MY BAG ONE LS
STAND BY IN A NINE THE COMPANY
IN OUR ALLOW THEM HE- RIGHT
CLICK INTO MY- WENT. ON THE
THAT WE NEED STATE A ANYA. THE
LAST ONE I THAT. YEAH IN A
MODEL I FOUND I COULD BE BASE A
KID IN. BUT ANY MUST COME FROM
THE SOUTH. THANK YOU CAN ONLY
LIKE BUT I CAN LOOK AT THE ON
THE NINETEEN NINETY. IT'S NOT.
ANYTHING I'M CLASS BY THANK
THAT LESS COMMONLY OTHER WILL
ALLEN. THAT MARK LEVINE YOUR
THREE ANSWER THANK I FELT THAT
MET. BUT I CAN PLAN A- CLICK
LAST. SELECT AN IRANIAN BRANCH
BUT I'M BY FIFTY FIVE. YES
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. WELL
OKAY SURE RHONDA WAIT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME
WAS SHORTENED AWAITING MY
MUSCLES TO WORK WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF CHILDREN AND
FAMILY SERVICES I ALSO AM A
MEMBER OF THE GREATEST
COMEDIANS IF YOU GUYS WANT A
LOS ANGELES COUNTY I'M HERE TO
SPEAK FOR THE CHILDREN WHO HAVE
NO VOICE OUR HOTLINE CALL
INCREASE BY. SERVICE HERE. ONE
THING I'VE LEARNED IS CAN YOU
NOT THE HOW. OR THE POLICE.
OFTEN WHEN A HAPPY IN THEIR
HOME THEY RELY ON KEY FOR THE-
ONE. BUT IN. WE DO. HOT LINE
BUT SHOULD HAVE BEEN A FEW AND
NEGLECTED I'M ASKING BUDGET
COMMITTEE CONSIDER THIS NEVER
TALK ABOUT WE FOR HEALTH
SUBSTANCE ABUSE RICHARD WHO
HAVE BEEN ABUSED THANK YOU
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS FOR. I'M
NOT. CAN MATCH AT ME GO AHEAD.
MITCHELL NUMBERS CONNIVING
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS.
HOLDING MAKING CRITICAL OR
HEALTHCARE SYSTEM WHEN IT COMES
TO DISCUSS THEM. WE ALL WANT
DIFFERENT. AVAILABLE ON A
TWENTY FOUR SEVEN BASIS. ON THE
CRISIS. THE COMMISSION ARRIVE
BEING ON THE FRONT LINE HEALTH
ANYONE BECAUSE IT APART. IN A
THAT IS THE CASE WITH THE-
ACOSTA AROUND LIES THAT. IN
ORDER LOCAL. BEGIN WITH A
NUMBER OF THE VOLUME OF
PATIENTS COME NUMBER PASSPORT
SIX WE HAD TO QUALIFY OF A
THIRTY. IN A NUMBER OF OKAY
COVER. ORDERED PERCENT DECLINE.
THE PHYSICIAN WHO ARE NOT
EMPLOYEES THE HOUSE. THIS IS
RESULTING IN THE HAVING INCOME
REDUCE. THIS INCLUDES ARE
CUTTING CON ABOUT THE CARD AND
WEBER. ALIVE THE LINE. TO THE
AFFECTED THE PRODUCTION AND
TAKING THAT THE TECHNICAL
CONTINUE CONTROL IN TWO
THOUSAND FOUR ONE THE CHALLENGE
FOR MURDER. IN A LOCAL STAFF AT
OUR MERCY APARTMENT BUT IT
NEEDS CONTINUE THE ORDER SEARCH
IS THERE ARE TWO THINGS TO
OCCUR. WE NEED A REQUEST TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ASSISTANCE TO
HELP WITH TOOTH FAIRY AND WE
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING YOU.
APPRECIATE THAT THANK YOU.
WITNESS ON BOTH THE ADELINE
LOMBARD PLEASE CALL AHEAD. YES
MY NAME IS LONG FOR THE FIELD
HELLO BY CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
BOB SMALL IN MICRO BREWED HAVE
BEEN THERE WAS TO YOU CAN DOWN
CALL BUCKLE ARE CO NOT CLEAN.
WE APPRECIATE THE GOVERNOR'S
FIFTEEN DOLLARS THAT PUT IN TO
BOOKS MAXIM BUSINESS. ELIMINATE
THE ORGANIZATION THAT HAVE ACTS
TO THESE FUNDS TO THE USUAL
SUCH. IN THE ORGAN OF THE HAVE
NEVER BEEN FOR TO OUR SMOKE
BUSINESS. WE HAVE TO
LEGISLATURE OF NEW ASSEMBLY OUT
THE GOVERNMENT TO EXPAND HAS
ACCESS TO THESE ON. THE WE ARE
ORGANIZATIONS CAN BE
CONSIDERED. AN ARE OUR- ACCESS
TO- THE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM IN ALL THE- GOING TO BE
MADE AVAILABLE THANK YOU THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESS IS ONE. NEXT
CALL. PLEASE AHEAD. THANK
BROWNIE MAY BE NEEDED. I HAVE
ONE NEXT COURT THE LINE OF JEAN
HEARD PLEASE LAW HAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR IN HER HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE URBAN COUNTIES
OF CALIFORNIA- GREATLY
APPRECIATE THAT THE COURT AND
THE CAN FROM THE STATE AND
FEDERAL GOVERNMENTS AS- OUR
WORK THE STATE OF MIND
RESPONDED FOR THE CARPET
NINETEEN. MAY ORDER. WE SHOULD
HAVE A- THE FOR YOUR CLIENT I.
THINK I'M URBAN CARRY THEM BUT
IT GROUND THIS. PUBLIC HEALTH
ECONOMIC CREE. WITH THE BACK
MAJORITY OF CO GOOD POSITIVE HE
SAID AND HOSPITALIZATIONS IN
OUR COMMUNITY. I'LL BE AND HATE
THAT ARE ARE CURRENTLY WORK
WILL CONTINUE TO BE REQUIRED AT
ARMS WILL BUST LEVEL FOR MEN.
SELECT OF SHELTER AND ORDER.
ARE HIS WILL CRITICAL TO CAL
WHO ARE FROM ILLNESS OR WHO
HAVE BEEN LAID OFF. AT THE SAME
TIME KEEP POLITICAL PUBLIC
PROGRAMS WILL INCREASE REVENUES
FOR THESE PROGRAMS YOUR LATEST
HEALTHCARE WILL COMMENT. YOU
CAN READ ROLE IN THAT PANDEMIC
IS ACT AS AN EXTENSION OF THE
GOVERNMENT AND AS A RESULT WE
WANT TO CONTINUE TO WORK IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
LEGISLATURE IN ADMINISTRATION
THROUGH PUBLIC HEALTH CANNOT
CREATE THAT. YOU INSURE THAT WE
HAVE BEEN VERY RESOURCE TO KEEP
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTHY THANK YOU
THANK YOU WITH. ON CONTAGEM BY
IT PLEASE AHEAD. GOOD EVENING
CHAIR WOMAN MITCHELL AND
MEMBERS JIM LIGHTS ON BEHALF OF
THE SAN FRANCISCO BAY AREA
RAPID TRANSIT DISTRICT- WALL
THE CUES THAT PROVIDE NEAR TERM
FUNDING FOR TRANSIT AGENCIES IN
PARTS CAN WIDER SHIP IS DOWN
NINETY FOUR. WE RELY ON YOUR
BOX REVENUE 460% OF OUR
OPERATING BUDGET THE PROJECT IN
THE CURRENT YEAR OPERATING LOSS
IN THE NEIGHBORHOOD OF A
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FOUR
MILLION DOLLARS. THE NATURE AND
MEANING OF THE RE OPENING IS SO
ON CERTAIN WE DO ANTICIPATE BUT
DIVISIONAL RELIEF FUNDS WILL BE
NECESSARY FOR TRANSIT AGENCIES
IN ORDER TO CONTINUE TO OPERATE
AND SELECTING TO COMMUTE.
CANCEL PLEASE CONTINUE TO
SUPPORT OUR OWN PAYROLL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS ONE MINUTE. OUR NEXT
CALL DANIELLE SANCHEZ PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD EVENING- DANIEL
CONTENT ON THE UP AND THE G.
PROBATION OFFICERS AND I JUST
WANNA AND OUR APPRECIATION TO
THE GOVERNOR AND YOU- THIS
COMMITTEE AND THE LEGISLATURE
FOR YOUR- COURTNEY ON ALL OF
THE THESE EFFORTS. THANK THE ON
THAT. COUNTY COULD BE AND TAKE.
OUT GREAT STEP TO ENSURE THAT
THE OF THOSE THAT WE WORK WITH
THE- WITHIN OUR FACILITIES AND
IN THE COMMUNITY WE SUBMITTED A
LETTER THAT OUTLINES THE- STEPS
THAT WE HAVE TAKEN TO. FURTHER
LIMIT YOU CAN JUVENILE
FACILITIES BY REVEALING THE HE
SAYS THE HALLS WITH THE
POSSIBLE FOR STOPPING YOU- AND
IN USING TECHNOLOGY AND OTHER-
PRACTICES. WHAT WITH THE
COMMUNITY WHO ARE NEED SERVICE
AS- I DO JUST WANT TO THAT WE
ALL TO TAKE GREAT THAT. IS THE
OTHER PART OF THE SYSTEM IT TO
HELP MANAGE OF GREAT BECAUSE
ONE OF THOSE BEANS CALORIE
RELEASE OF PR C. S. RELEASES I
WOULDN'T KNOW AND MANY THOSE
INTO THE- WITH EVENTUALLY
COMING BACK TO IT BUT CERTAINLY
ARE RETURNING. MUCH MORE
QUICKLY IN INTO AN ENVIRONMENT
WHERE- THE THING AT HOME ORDERS
ARE COMPETING- SOME OF THE
TRADITIONAL SERVICES THAT WOULD
BE IN PLACE THAT ALLOWS SELECT
TIME YOU CLEANED GETS CHARGED.
I DID JUST WANT TO HIGHLIGHT.
WITH THE COMPLETE BY SENATORS.
SENATOR ROTH REGARDING THE
IMPORTANCE OF THE- HOUSING COME
FOR THAT POPULATE AS WELL AS-
THEIR- WE LOOK FORWARD TO MORE
DISCUSS BONTA OF THOSE ITEMS.
ADDITIONALLY WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH THE COURTS AND COUNTY
OFFICIALS TO UTILIZE PRE TRIAL
OPTIONS THERE COULD BE XIN
SUPERVISION. TO AGAIN HELP
MANAGE AND- IN ALL THREE THAT
WE ARE ON LOOKING AT. ALL OF
THE THAT COUNT COMPOUND ON. THE
IMPACT ON PROBATION SERVICE
SAYS- AND I WOULD JUST-
INCLUDING CAN STAY WITH THE HE
WAS ELECTED IMPACT IN THE
SYSTEM CHANGES NOTED. IMPORTANT
A NUMBER THAT SUPPORT PROVIDED
CAN YOU- OD TO ENSURE THAT
CREATION CAN OFFER. HE
CERVANTES AND AGAIN TO THAT GOT
COMMUNITIES GOT CLIENTS THAT WE
SERVE AND WITH OUR STAFF SO
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO OFFER COMMENTS WE ALSO
SUBMITTED WRITTEN COMMENTS AND
EXCELLENT THANK YOU THE TRUE
THAT THE MINUTE WILL REVIEW
YOUR WRITTEN COMMENTS FOR
SHADED NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. NO
I'M NOT. I SHALL BERRA PLEASE
PLOT HAD. NUMBER COUNTY HEALTH
RECORDS ASSOCIATION AND I JUST
WANT TO THANK SENATOR BOXER
LEAVING INTO MENTAL HEALTH BARS
ARE COLLEAGUES AND FEEDBACK AND
THE PROBATION OFFICER COLLUDED
NINETEEN HAD ALREADY RESULTED
IN AT AND CREEK FOR PUBLIC OF
THE- ACCORDING TO A-OUT TODAY
BY MENTAL HEALTH AMERICA AND-
THE IN THE PRESS NOT FIGHT. 20%
ACROSS THE COUNTRY WITH YOUNG
PEOPLE PARTICULARLY IMPACTED
AND THOSE WITH SEVERE CYCLE UP
7% FROM PRIOR MONTH MANY OF THE
DEVASTATING LIFE CHANGES BE
ABLE TO COME BACK FROM. ILLNESS
THE DESK JOB LOSS IN THE OF ONE
THE FACT THAT. THE PUBLIC.
PATIENTS WILL TRY. HEALTH HELLO
FIVE AM ON AFTER THE AND THE-
AND BELIEVE THAT. IT'S BEEN A
VITAL. BUT THE THIRTY WITH
DOLLARS WILL BE A CLOCK
POPULATION. HI ECONOMIC IMPACT
THEIR DRIVE MANY MORE OPEN ARE
FOR CAL. COUNTY WHERE AND OUR-
COUNTRY THE PROVIDER THE MY BUT
RESPOND. AND GOING TOGETHER
WITH PARKING BUT AFTER AND
REALIGN THOUSAND SEVEN THREE
BLACK HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR IN
THE MAKE REALLY FUN TO HELP
RIGHT OUR PUBLIC THEATER HOW
THE YEAH BECAUSE THERE THE
FIFTH WHEN THE. WE'VE BEEN
BUILDING OUT THIRDS HALF ON A
OWN WITH NO WITH NO FUNDING
COMES GET THE MEANS THAT
BECAUSE OUR COMMUNITY. WE ARE
AS WELL AS THE OF THEY'LL POP.
IN UNIX YOUR MEN CAN YOU MAIL
IN THE BELL OF YOUR TO. THANK
YOU. NEXT ONE IT WOULDN'T
PLEASE A WOMAN COURAGE OF TO
GET THE HIGH. OF THEIR- INTO A
MINUTE AND THEN MAIL LIST REST
NEXT MODEL. ONE CAROLINE BUT
PLEASE CALL. THANK YOU CHAIR
THE PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE
STRONGLY SUPPORTS URGENT
FUNDING TO LOCAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS FOR THE WARM BODIES
AND RESOURCES THAT ARE
ESSENTIAL TO PREVENT WE'VE TO
CALL THAT AS SENATOR CAN NOTED.
BUT WE ALSO NEED TO PREVENT THE
THIRD WAVE THAT OF THE GREAT
HEALTH CONSEQUENCES OF THE
ECONOMIC FALLOUT. WHEN ALONE
INCREASES MORTALITY BY 62% OVER
A DECADE. THE THIRD WAVE OF
INCREASED CHRONIC DISEASES AND
DEATHS OF DESPAIR ME FAR
SURPASS WHAT WE SAW AFTER THE
LAST RECESSION. WITHOUT
CONCERTED ACTION FOR THE ROCKET
FROM EXAMPLES WE URGE THAT EVEN
IN THE FACE OF SCARCITY YOU
PRIORITIZE SUSTAINED INVESTMENT
IN OUR- LOCAL COMMUNITIES. TO
COMMUNITY PARTNERS INCLUDING
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
COMMUNITY CLINICS TRIED AS WELL
AS PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS TO
ADDRESS THE COMMUNITY BASED
PREVENTION OF THE HEALTH
CONSEQUENCES. AND TO ADVANCE
HELP COULD BE EVEN IN THE THIS
CHALLENGE AS PART OF OUR
COMMITMENT KEEN RESPONSE PLAN
FOR THE STATE. THANK YOU. FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY AND FOR YOUR
REFERENCE. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. CONTACT OUR
BURKE. BELIEVES THERE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS PARK REPLACE IT
WITH THE CALIFORNIA HOSPITAL
ASSOCIATION HOSPITAL VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THE STATE'S RAPID
RESPONSE TO ADDRESS THE CODE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC. INVESTMENTS
THE STATUS MADE IN PERSONAL
PROTECTIVE EQUIPMENT
UNDOUBTEDLY SAVE LIVES. AND
HOSPITALS ARE DEEPLY GRATEFUL
FOR THE WORK OF THE GOVERNOR
AND HIS TEAM AS WELL AS THE
SENATE THE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS WHO
ARE HELPING THEIR MEMBERS ON
THE GROUND. FOR THEIR KIDS.
MATH AND NINETY FIVE GREATER.
THAN AND OTHER LIFE APPLY.
HOSPITAL FOR THE FOREFRONT OF
CALIFORNIA'S RESPONSE AT THIS
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY HAVE
BEEN CRIPPLED FINANCIALLY
BEGINNING IN FEBRUARY TO
PREPARE TO CARE FOR TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF POTENTIAL COCA
NINETEEN CONSTIPATION HOSPITALS
BEGAN TO PURCHASE MASSIVE
AMOUNTS OF THE PIE. BATES
OFFENDED NON EMERGENCY SURGERY
ANOTHER PROCEDURE AND AGAIN THE
TRANSFERS SO THEY CAN PATIENTS
TO OTHER APPROPRIATE CARE
SETTING. IS THAT. SOLD WITHIN
SHARP ON. READ IN RATHER. AS
MUCH AS 50% IN SOME CASES
MAKING IT HARD FOR SOME
HOSPITAL MAKE WEEKLY PAYROLL
AND PRESENTING A GREAT THREAT
TO MANY HOSPITALS BY ABILITY.
IS EXTREME FINANCIAL DISTRESS
IS AN EXISTENTIAL THREAT TO
CALIFORNIA'S HEALTH CARE
HOSPITALS ARE GRATEFUL FOR THE
ABILITY TO BE PART OF THE
CONVERSATION AS WE WORK TO
REBUILD THE DEVASTATED SYSTEM.
THANK YOU FOR HOLDING THIS INTO
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
COMMENTS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WITNESS AND I WOULD
ENCOURAGE EVERYONE USE IN
MINUTES ON CONTACT. WE FEEL
THANK THAT APPRECIATED SO YOU
AND. WELL NOT OKAY ADD LITTLE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I WILL MEXICO
COULD CLEAR RAM PLEASE GO AHEAD.
CLEARLY IN HERE THANK YOU MADAM
MEMBERS I WOULD PROJECT IN
AGING AND I JUST WANTED TO
HIGHLIGHT THE NEED FOR MORE
FUNDING AND MORE DISCUSSION
ABOUT THESE OLDER ADULTS DURING
THE CRISIS. THE OLDER DON'T
COLOR WORK HEARING THING- YOU
TO HELP DISPARITIES AND GOT
DURING THE PANDEMIC WE ALSO
WANT TO LOOK MORE AT. FUNDING
FOR NURSING HOMES AND HOW TO
GET PEOPLE OUT OF THEIR HOMES
AND IN THE HOME AND COMMUNITY
BASED CARE. HOW TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS HEALTH FOR ALL YEAH
SO THEY HAVE ACCESS TO THAT
ACCOUNT. YOUR BUT- YOU'RE HAVE
RESOURCE RESOURCES. WE'VE BEEN
HOME DELIVERED. AND YOUR
LOOKING FORTUNATELY AND GETTING
PAID A TO MAKE SURE WE ARE
UNDERSTANDING. PANDEMIC IS
AFFECTING AND- WHAT COMMUNITIES
WITH THE MOST SUPPORT- TO.
DRIVE AND YOU WELL OUT OF THIS
CRISIS THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS PLEASE. ON THAT SCORE
ISHIDA AS THE MAN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I AM A MAN FROM THE
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY COMMITTEE
YOUR QUESTION IN THE SAME
MARKING AND IF CANNELLA
VALLEY'S ARE EXPERIENCING
STARTLING IMPACT OF THE
NINETEEN MOST URGENTLY WATER
AT. ALL CALIFORNIANS MUST BE
IMMEDIATELY RECONNECTED
REGARDLESS OF EIGHT THEY LOST
SERVICE COMMUNITIES IMPROVE
BANKING DIRECT ACCESS TO
PRODUCE AND NOT BE LEFT TO ROT
IN THE FIELD WE NEED A- THAT
ARE CLOSER MORATORIUM AND- GET
MATH FOR LOW INCOME. TWENTY AND
AFTER SHELTERING PLACES. THE
MOBILE HOT SPOT THE PAID I'VE
BEEN INTEREST EXPANDED. AREAS
FARMWORKERS AND FOOD INDUSTRY
WORKERS NEED PP AND STATE
PROTOCOL FOR THINK SOCIAL
DISTANCING AT WORK. LASTLY
INTERPRETATION AND FULL
PARTICIPATION NOT REMOTE PUBLIC
MEETINGS BOTH LOCAL AND STATE
NEEDS TO BE A SHORT. WE URGE
YOU TO PRIORITIZE THESE
CRITICAL AND BASICALLY FIRST AN
INLAND CALIFORNIA EVERYTHING
EXACERBATED BY CO. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS PLEASE.
CALL TO BLANCA ESCONDIDO PLEASE
BUT I HAD. WINDOWS WILL THREE
HUNDRED GRAND OWNERS WHO
INTENDED CANNELLA TO LEADING
THE LOCAL MATERIALS AND A
MILLION DOESN'T AGREE THAT THE
P. PEOPLE NOTHING. THE BODY
THIRTY NOT. IN THE EVENT THAT
COULD BE. OKAY THOSE I MET BUT
I COULDN'T OTHERS THAT IS AND
OPEN MOSCOW WITH IS A LEAST YOU
A MILLION FOUR TIMES THAT THEY
HAVE A HECK OF A LOT. BUT I
COULD DO THE AT THE IS GOING ON
THE SCHOOL WHEN. WE GOT A
CHANCE IT WITH ANOTHER THING
PROVIDED BEFORE MODEL SO THAT
PARTICULAR CORNER THE. I THINK
IT A COMMENT STARKILLER FOUR
DONE BUT ARE THE ONES BUT I
ELECTION WHEN I WILL. I WANT IN
HIS BE SENDING A LOT OF FORGET
YOU TO THE- PLUS. KAMALA IS THE
LEADING I WILL USE WOULD. THE
NEED TO A COMMON CATEGORY
TESTING GROWTH THAT THREE TODAY
IN BILL. AND PICK THREE PUT. IN
A- AT GRANTLAND. YEAH SOME OF
THE YOUR LOCAL BILLS FOR ONE OF
THE IN BUT I GET INTO HIM A CAN
BE AS WELL YEAH THAT ARTICLE OF
YOU DON'T BUT I'M A GOOD THEY
LEFT IN THE A LOCAL. REPORTER.
THE. INVESTMENT LOCAL DIVERSE.
STATE PROGRAMS AND MAKING
CONSTRUCTION. ALSO THE POOR
WAITRESS FROM I CAN CUT. WE CAN
BE MUCH MORE. INVEST IN A
RESOURCE NEEDED EMPLOY ALL OF
THE RELEASED A COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS AND DOING ALL WE
CAN. AND MOST OUT OF ALL BUT
AND POPULOUS PROVIDE. THE CARD
TO AND BASIC. THANK YOU MUCH
THANK YOU NECK WITNESS. ONE
MINUTE. AND OUR THEIR FINAL.
EXCELLENT WE WOULD LIKE TO SAY
ALL ALL OF THE IN THE WHO
CALLED IN TO PUT IN TEST TODAY.
AGAIN IF YOU WERE NOT A TO
TOUGH OF VIA THE TALK ARE
PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS ARE
SO AND- TO THE SENATE AND
REVIEW COMMITTEE OR THE OUR WEB.
YOUR COMMENTS THE ARED TO US
WE WILL TO INCLUDE YOUR IN THE
IF HEARING RECORD WE THANK YOU
IN A YOUR TOP I'M AN
PARTICIPATION. LIKE THANK ALL
THE OF THE TWO. PART OF THE
FIND. BILL JOH. CENTER ON
BUDGET AND POLICY FOR STILL
WITH US FOR A FOUR HOUR HEARING
UNDER LOW IN IDEAL SO.
APPRECIATE YOUR THOUGHTFUL NAY
CA. KNOW THAT THIS NOT THE
END BUT REALLY THE BEGINNING OF
OUR OFFICIAL CONVERSATION. I'D
LIKE TO THANK. ALL OF THE STAFF
THAT MADE TODAY POSSIBLE- BILLS
IN THE HEARING ROOM THOSE WHO
PREPPED AND EQUIPPED THIS
UNIQUE PROCESS BY WHICH WE WERE
ABLE TO CONVENE. LAST BUT
CERTAINLY NOT LATE LEASE LET ME
THANK. THE GOVERNOR IN THE
ADMINISTRATION. THESE ARE
CURIOUS TIMES IN WHICH WERE ALL
LIVING AND I DON'T BELIEVE
THERE'S ANY MEMBER OF THIS
LEGISLATIVE BODY. THAT WANTS TO
IMPEDE. RESOURCES GOING TO
CALIFORNIANS WHO ARE IN NEED.
THE POINT OF TODAY'S HEARING IS
FOR US TO ENGAGE IN A DYNAMIC
AND INTENTIONAL WAY TO SUPPORT
ALL EFFORTS THAT ARE NEEDED TO
SUPPORT CALIFORNIANS DURING
THIS HISTORIC. PUBLIC HEALTH
AND ECONOMIC PANDEMIC WE ARE
CLEAR THAT WE HAVE WORK TO DO
AS ELECTED LEADERS AS APPOINTED
LEADERS AS PUBLIC SERVANTS AND
WE WON'T SHY AWAY FROM THAT. SO
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
PARTICIPATION TODAY WILL
CONTINUE TO ENGAGE AS
APPROPRIATE. THE SUBCOMMITTEE
ON CALL THE NINETEEN RESPONSE
STANDS ADJOURNED.